thank you
hi everyone welcome to this artificial
intelligence 2022 full course video by
simply loan artificial intelligence
applications are being widely used in
various fields to solve business
problems in this video you will learn
the important skills that will help you
understand Ai and its implementation
better
our highly proficient trainers will take
you through this course
so let's look at the agenda for today's
topic
we will start by learning the basic
companies for 2022.
next you will understand machine
learning in detail and explore some of
the top machine learning algorithms that
are used to build intelligent machines
so here you will look at linear
regression logistic regression decision
tree k-means clustering KN PCA and other
techniques such as regularization
reinforcement learning and Q learning
moving forward you will understand the
working of artificial neural networks
and deep learning algorithms such as
convolutional neural network recurrent
neural network Keras image
classification and sequential model so
let's get started
picture this a machine that could
organize your cupboard just as you like
it or serve every member of the House a
customized cup of coffee makes your day
easier doesn't it these are the products
of artificial intelligence but why use
the term artificial intelligence well
these machines are artificially
Incorporated with human-like
intelligence to perform tasks as we do
this intelligence is built using complex
algorithms and mathematical functions
but AI may not be as obvious as in the
previous examples in fact AI is used in
smartphones cars social media feeds
video games banking surveillance and
many other aspects of our daily life the
real question is what does an AI do at
its core here is a robot we built in our
lab which is now dropped onto a field in
spite of a variation in lighting
landscape and dimensions of the field
the AI robot God must perform as
expected this ability to react
appropriately to a new situation is
called generalized learning the robot is
now at a crossroad one that is paved and
the other Rocky the robot must determine
which path to take based on the
circumstances this portrays the robot's
reasoning ability after a short stroll
the robot now encounters a stream that
it cannot swim across using the plank
provided as an input the robot is able
to cross this stream so our robot uses
the given input and finds the solution
for a problem this is problem solving
these three capabilities make the robot
artificially intelligent in short AI
provides machines with the capability in
AI is classified into
weak AI also called narrow AI focuses
solely on one task
for example alphago is a maestro of the
game go but you can't expect it to be
even remotely good at chess
this makes alphago a weak AI
you might say Alexa is definitely not a
weak AI since it can perform multiple
tasks well that's not really true when
you ask Alexa to play despacito it picks
up the keywords play and despacito and
runs a program and is trained to Alexa
cannot respond to a question it isn't
trained to answer for instance try
asking Alexa the status of traffic from
work to home
Alexa cannot provide you this
information as she is not trained to
and that brings us to our second
category of AI strong AI
now this is much like the robots that
only exist in fiction as of now Ultron
from Avengers is an ideal example of a
strong AI
that's because it's self-aware and
eventually even develops emotions this
makes the ai's response unpredictable
You Must Be Wondering well how is
artificial intelligence different from
machine learning and deep learning we
saw what AI is machine learning is a
technique to achieve AI deep learning in
turn is a subset of machine learning
machine learning provides a machine with
the capability to learn from data and
experience through algorithms deep
learning does this learning through ways
inspired by the human brain this means
through deep learning data and patterns
can be better perceived Ray Kurzweil a
well-known futurist predicts that by the
year 2045 we would have robots as smart
as humans
this is called the point of Singularity
well that's not all in fact Elon Musk
predicts that the human mind in for you
which of the below AI projects don't
exist yet a an AI robot with citizenship
B a robot with a muscular skeletal
system C AI that can read its owner's
emotions the AI that develops emotions
over time
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comments section below since the
human brain is still a mystery it's no
surprise that ai2 has a lot of
unventured domains for now ai is built
with humans and make our tasks easier
however with the maturation of
Technology we can only wait and watch
what the future of AI holds for us well
that is artificial intent
intelligence for you in short get to
leave your in the comments section below
like share and subscribe to our Channel
if you enjoyed this video stay tuned and
keep learning
now let's look at the different types of
artificial intelligence
so AI can be classified based on
capabilities and functionalities
it is there are three types of
artificial intelligence
they are narrow AI General Ai and super
AI
under functionalities we are Fort of
mind and self-awareness let's look at
them one by one
first we will look at the different
types of artificial intelligence based
on capability so what is narrow AI
narrow AI also known as vki focuses on
one narrow task and cannot
it aims at a single subset of cognitive
abilities and advances in that Spectrum
applications of narrow AI are becoming
increasingly common in our day-to-day
lives as machine learning and deep
learning methods continue to evolve
Bridge with a limited predefined range
of functions
Siri often has challenges with tasks
outside its range of abilities IBM
Watson supercomputer is another example
of narrow AI which applies cognitive
Computing machine learning and natural
language processing to process
information and answer your questions
IBM Watson once outperformed human
contestant Ken Jenkins to become the
champion on the popular game show
Jeopardy other examples of narrow AI
include Google Translate image
recognition software recommendation
systems spam filtering and Google's page
ranking algorithm
next we have General artificial
intelligence or general AI General AI
also known as strong AI has the ability
to understand and learn any intellectual
task that a human can
General artificial intelligence has
received a one billion dollar investment
from Microsoft through open AI it allows
the machine to apply Knowledge and
Skills in different contexts AI
researchers and scientists have not
achieved strong AI so far to succeed
they would need to find a way to make
machines conscious programming a full
set of cognitive abilities
Fujitsu built the K computer which is
one of the fastest computers in the
world
it is one of the most notable attempts
at achieving strong AI
it took 40 minutes to simulate a single
second of neural activity so it is
difficult to determine whether or not
strong AI will be achieved in the near
future
tan HE2 is a supercomputer created by
China's national university of Defense
technology
it currently holds the record for CPS at
33.86 petaflops although it sounds
exciting the human brain is estimated to
be capable of One exaph log
now CPS means characters per second that
A system can process
third in the list of AI that is based on
capabilities we have super AI super AI
exceeds human intelligence and can't
perform any task better than a human
the concept of artificial super
intelligence sees AI evolved to be so
akin to human emotions and experiences
that it doesn't just understand them it
evokes emotions needs beliefs and
desires of its own its existence is
still hypothetical some of the key
characteristics of super AI include the
ability to think solve puzzles meet
judgments and decisions on its own
now if you have enjoyed watching this
video so far please make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to stay updated with all
the latest Technologies also if you have
any questions related to this video
please put it in the chat section A team
of experts will help you address your
questions
moving ahead now we will see the
different types of artificial
intelligence based on functionalities
in this category first we have reactive
machine
a reactive machine is the basic form of
AI that does not store memories or use
past experiences to determine future
actions
it worked the world and react to it
reactive machines are given certain
tasks and don't have capabilities Beyond
those duties
IBM's deep blue which defeated just
Grand Master Gary Castro is a reactive
machine that sees the pieces on a chess
board and reacts to them
it cannot refer to any of its prior
experiences and cannot improve with
practice
deep blue can identify the pieces on a
chessboard and know how each moves
it can make predictions about what moves
might be next for it and its opponent
it can choose the most optimal moves
from among the possibilities deep stance
right now and choose from possible next
moves
up next we have limited memory
limited memory AI learns from past
unique decisions
the memory of such systems is
short-lived
while they can use this data for a
specific period of time they cannot add
it to a library of their experiences
this kind of technology is used for
self-driving vehicles they observe how
other vehicles or move data gets added
to the static data within the AI machine
such as lean markers and traffic lights
they're included when the vehicle
decides to change lanes to avoid cutting
of another driver or being hit by a
nearby vehicle
Mitsubishi Electric is a company that
has been figuring out how to improve
such technology for applications like
self-driving cars
then we have theory of mind
theory of Mind represents a very
advanced class of technology and exists
as a concept
this kind of AI requires a thorough
understanding that the people and the
things within an environment it should
be able to understand people's emotions
sentiment and thoughts
even though a lot of improvements are
there in this field this kind of AI
is not complete here one real world
example of theory of Mind AI is Kismet
put head made in the late 90s by a
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
researcher Kismet can mittens and
recognize them abilities are key in
theory of Mind AI but Kismet can't
follow gazes or convey attention to
humans
Sophia from hand robotics theory of Mind
AI was implemented
cameras within Sofia's eyes combined
with computer algorithms allow her to
see
can follow faces sustain eye contact and
recognize individuals
is able to process speech and have
conversations using natural language
subsystem
finally we have self-awareness
self-awareness AI only exists
hypothetically
such systems understand that internal
traits States and conditions and
perceive human emotions
these machines will be smarter than the
eye will not only be able to understand
and evoke emotions in those it interacts
with but also have emotions needs and
beliefs of its own while we are probably
far away from creating machines that are
self-aware we should focus our efforts
towards understanding memory learning
and the ability to base decisions on
past experiences I am keerthana and
today we shall be talking about the top
10 artificial intelligence Technologies
before getting into the video he has a
gently remind her to subscribe to our
Channel and any update from us
so without further Ado let's quickly
jump into the topic in the list we have
natural language generation smart
devices virtual agents speech
recognition augmented reality machine
learning robotic process automation
decision management
deep learning and finally image
recognition
please note that the list is in no
particular order
natural language generation
communicating or conveying the
information
efficiently and transparently is very
much crucial in contamination to say the
right words in the right sequence to
convey the message clearly humans find
it tricky and when it comes to machines
it's trickier
natural language and real trendy
technology that converts the structured
data into a native language the machines
are programmed in such a way that the
algorithms convert the data into a
desirable format for the users
this technology is widely used in
customer service report generation and
summarizing business intelligence
insights
some of the sample vendors are at Evo
automated insights SAS Kindred semantics
digital reasoning narrative science
Etc
on the list next we have Smart devices
with every passing day smart devices are
becoming more popular and more trendy
technologies that people were using Once
Upon A Time are now remodeled and
modified as smart devices
they can be used in almost every
industry to improve efficiency and
optimize the operations
smart devices are everyday objects meet
intelligent with Advanced computations
which include artificial intelligence
and machine learning
they are electronic gadgets that are
able to connect are smart watches smart
glasses smartphones smart speakers
Etc virtual agents they are computer
generated intelligence that provides
online customer assistance they can
effectively communicate with humans in
most of the web and mobile applications
we see chat Bots as customer service
agents who interact with us answering
our queries
in simple virtual agents are a manifest
aims to create an effective but digital
impersonation of humans
virtual agents can make reservations
book an appointment place an order and
can even Avail product information
some of the best examples of virtual
agents are Google assistant and Amazon
Alexa and the companies that provide
virtual agents are Microsoft Google
Amazon and assist AI
next we have speech recognition
recognition
speech recognition is yet another
sub-discipline of artificial speech
recognition is yet another
sub-discipline of artificial
intelligence which is used to convert
human speech into a comprehensive and
useful format for Computer Applications
to process
it can be said as a bridge between
computer interactions and humans it's
presently used in interactive voice
response systems and mobile applications
some of the companies offering speech
recognition services are Nuance
Communications open text nice and
variants and wearing systems
augmented reality yet another trendy
technology in the field of artificial
intelligence augmented reality is an
enhanced version of the real physical
world that is achieved using sound
digital visual elements and other
sensitive stimuli delivered via
technology
augmented reality uses the existing
environment and adds information to it
to make a new artificial environment it
Alters the perception of the real world
environment augmented reality is making
its way into several retail stores that
make makeup selection and Furnishing
much more fun and interactive if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
machine learning machine learning is an
application and an important branch of
artificial intelligence which refers to
machines being able to learn by
themselves without being explicitly
programmed
it enables systems to learn and improve
from experience automatically
machine learning platforms are becoming
more and more popular with the help of
algorithms apis big data and
applications and training tools
Enterprises are heavily investing in
machine learning to reap its benefits
for the various domains
machine learning is widely used for
categorization and prediction
to sample vendors are Amazon
fractal analytics Google Microsoft
Etc robotic process automation
configuring a report to interpret
communicate and analyze data is robotic
process automation
it uses grips and other methods to
automate the human actions which in turn
supports efficient business processes
robotic process automation is widely
used in those areas where the physical
presence of a human is dangerous Fields
like Warfare mining Etc is where it's
currently being used we need to remember
that artificial intelligence is not
meant to replace humans but instead it
is to complement their abilities and
reinforce human Talent
companies that are focusing on robotic
process automation are Pega systems
automation anywhere blue prism
Etc next on the list we have decision
management
decision management is yet another
technology and artificial intelligence
that helps companies make valid
Decisions by providing up-to-date and
relevant information and Performing
analytic functions
artificial intelligence when combined
with decision management helps translate
customer data into predictive models of
key trends
it also helps in making quick decisions
avoidance of risks and in the automation
of the process
decision management is widely used in
the healthcare sector financial sector
Insurance sector e-commerce and many
more
the companies that provide this service
are Informatica Advanced systems
Concepts Pica systems Mana
Etc deep learning
deep learning is a branch of artificial
intelligence that mimics the workings of
the human brain in processing data
this data is used for a variety of
purposes like recognizing speech
detecting objects translating languages
and making decisions
deep learning uses hierarchical level of
artificial neural networks for carrying
out the process of machine learning
which is used across several Industries
for various applications
some of the sample vendors are deep
Instinct fluid AI math Works saffron
technology
Etc
at last we have image recognition
image recognition is the process of
detecting an object or feature in a
digital image or video it can be used to
analyze clients and their opinions
verify users based on their faces detect
license plates and diagnose diseases the
present-day image recognition is
comparable to human visual perception
many social media platforms like
Facebook use this technology to enhance
innate search and Aid visually impaired
users clarify Googles and senstein
provide this technology
decades ago the term artificial
intelligence was just another
Frankenstein story but today it could be
a citizen in your next door right from
its Genesis artificial intelligence was
programmed to probe into human life and
eliminate the fortifications of the
impossibilities in many areas like
healthcare Transportation communication
and much more there are hundreds and
thousands of organizations Tech
communities and Engineers worldwide
working Round the Clock to make Miracles
a reality and today we are going to
discuss the top 10 amongst those who are
contributing a significant part so here
we are the top 10 artificial
intelligence companies to watch in 2022
at number 10 we have this AI this AI is
a revolutionary approach to dramatically
improvise the way Healthcare is
delivered with AI focuses on
implementing artificial intelligence to
diagnose and detect abnormalities in the
human body via CT CTA MRI X-ray
ultrasound
Etc
this AI coordinates both the patient and
Healthcare professionals at the same
time the patient reports are shared by a
boulder concerned Medical Teams results
are astonishing with with AI there is a
significant Improvement in productivity
and reduction of time required for
patient and discharge this AI was
founded in 2016 and established in
November 2021. the company runs with 223
employees and the headquarters is in San
Francisco
with AI mainly focuses on improving and
filling all the gaps between patients
and Healthcare professionals with AI
offers hands and salaries to its
employees in India the salaries range
from 4 lakhs to 18 lakhs per annum and
in America the wages range from one ten
thousand dollars to two ten thousand
dollars per annum so at number nine we
have Farm boys ten years ago an
automated wheat killing Robo was science
fiction
now its rise of practical weed killing
Robos with millimeter thanks to farmwei
first product of the californian-based
company was an automated robo-weeder
based on AI computer vision and also
robotics the robot would eliminate weeds
from the vegetable fields farmwise tends
to build Innovative systems and
efficient procedures that help farmers
streamline farming with efficiency
farmwise was established in the year
2020 the company functions with 50
employees on board and actively looking
for expansion
the company follows the procedure of
paying farming equipment employees and
contract Personnel hourly
farmwise makes an annual turnover of 8.5
million US Dollars on average an AIML
engineer at farmwise earns anywhere
around 113
000 per annum
up next we have amp robot
robotics at number eight we have amp
robotics
While others are busy trying Revolution
is mankind with AI amp robotics came up
with an Innovative idea that happens to
be a kind gesture of gratitude towards
nature
amp AI artificial intelligence that
recycles plastic waste and waste from
construction sites and much more the
Ropo precisely identifies paper Plastics
and metals by learning and recognizing
them via color size shape and a few more
factors the colorado-based company is
currently operational with 137 employees
in total and looking forward to expand
the ideal globally AP robotics aims to
re-imagining recycling and to create a
world without waste through artificial
intelligence amp robotics pays handsome
salaries to their employees with an
average salary of an employee amp
robotics varies between ninety six
thousand dollars to one Thirty one
thousand dollars per annum
coming up next is a giant at number
seven we have automation anywhere
automation anywhere is a global robotics
Automation and soft founded in the year
2003. the company's headquarters is
located in San Jose California
the global RPA leader offers Cloud
native web-based intelligent automation
solutions to the world's leading Cloud
companies
automation investigation 360 offers a
variety of intelligent tools and
self-learning systems to automate every
redundant task
automation anywhere is focusing on
transforming the companies to be RPA
oriented and the current covet
situations have triggered the need for
automation even more
a recent survey States the RPA adoption
rates will increase by 57 in just one
more year
the globally recognized multinational
company works with more than 2 200 plus
employees on board
the company pays decent salaries as well
at number six we have Microsoft AI
Microsoft integrated AI into cloud
computing Microsoft's AI platform
provides robust solutions to Cloud
related problems Microsoft's AI division
is headquartered in Redmond Washington
with around 5000 employees specifically
in the AI Division and aims to train and
certify 15 000 employees by 2022.
Microsoft AI is a robust framework
designed for developing AI Solutions
using machine learning data science
Robotics iot and more AI enables
Services accelerate productivity to a
greater level
Microsoft Azure uses AI to get best of
breed infrastructure with Enterprise
create security availability compliance
and manageability Microsoft
their employees
the average fatality of an employee at
the Microsoft AI division earns up to
160 000 and
at number five we have data Robo data
Robo has its headstones it is one of the
AI Cloud leaders providing a humidified
platform into a cloud user to accelerate
the delivery of AI to Club data stand
and release orbiters Predictive
Analytics with no knowledge of machine
learning it uses automated ml to build
and deploy accurate predictive models in
a short span of time
the global Cloud leader currently
operates with more than a thousand
employees worldwide
data Robo compensates its employees with
handsome salaries an average employee a
data Robo earns up to 160 000 per year
and up to three lakh four hundred
thousand rupees in India
at number 4 we have Amazon the Alexa
Maker Amazon is one of the tech Giants
interested in adults maybe you have one
of them who's a customer at your store
or you have five of them or customer at
your store and they have a lot in common
with five others who are not customers
at your store how do you Market to those
five foreign customers at your store yet
they fit the demographs of who's going
to shop there and you'd like them to
shop at your store not the one next door
of course this is a simplified version
you can see very easily the difference
between a triangle and a circle which
might not be so easy in marketing
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is an important type of machine
learning or an agent learns how to
behave in an environment by performing
actions and seeing the result we have
here where the in this case a baby it's
actually great that they used an infant
for this slide because the reinforcement
learning is very much in its infant
stages but it's also a prop forcement
stages but it's also probably the
biggest machine learning demand out
there right now or in the future it's
going to be coming up over the next few
years is reinforcement learning and how
to make that work for us and you can see
here where we have our action in the
action in this one it goes into the fire
and hopefully the baby didn't think it
was just a little candle not a giant
fire pit like it looks like here when
the baby comes out and the new state is
the baby is sad and crying because they
got burned on the fire and then maybe
they take another action the baby's
called the agent because it's the one
taking the actions and in this case they
didn't go into the fire they went a
different direction and now the baby's
happy and laughing and playing
reinforcement learning is very easy to
understand because that's how as humans
that's one of the ways we learn we learn
whether it is you know you bring
yourself on the stove don't do that
anymore don't touch the stove in the big
picture being able to have a machine
learning program under an AI be able to
do this is huge because now we're
starting to learn how to learn that's a
big jump in the world of computer and
machine learning and we're going to go
back and just kind of go back over
supervise versus unsupervised learning
understanding this is huge because this
is going to come up in any project
you're working on we have in supervised
learning we have lay labeled data we
have direct feedback so someone's
already gone in there and said yes
that's a triangle no that's not a
triangle and then you predict an outcome
so you have a nice prediction this is
this this new set of data is coming in
and we know what it's going to be and
then with unsupervised training it's not
labeled so we really don't know what it
is there's no feedback so we're not
telling it whether it's right or wrong
we're not telling it whether it's a
triangle or a square we're not telling
it to go left or right all we do is
we're finding hidden structure in the
data grouping the data together to find
out what connects to each other and then
you can use these together so imagine
you have an image and you're not sure
what you're looking for so you go in and
you have the unstructured data find all
these things that are connected together
and then somebody looks at those and
labels them now you can take that
labeled data and program something to
predict what's in the picture so you can
see how they go back and forth and you
can start connecting all these different
tools together to make a bigger picture
there are many interesting machine
learning algorithms let's have a look at
a few of them hopefully this give you a
little flavor of what's out there and
these are some of the most important
ones that are currently being used we'll
take a look at linear regression
decision tree and the support Vector
machine let's start with a closer look
at linear regression linear regression
is perhaps one of the most well-known
and well understood algorithms in
statistics and machine learning linear
regression is a linear model for example
a model that assumes a linear
relationship between the input variables
X and the single output variable Y and
you'll see this if you remember from
your algebra classes y equals MX plus C
imagine we are predicting distance
traveled y from speed X our linear
regression model representation for this
problem would be y equals m times X plus
C or distance equals m times speed plus
C where m is the coefficient and C is
the y-intercept and we're going to look
at two different variations of of this
first we're going to start with time is
constant and you can see we have a
bicyclist he's got a safety gear on
thank goodness speed equals 10 meters
per second and so over a certain amount
of time his distance equals 36
kilometers we have a second bicyclist
who's going twice the speed or 20 meters
per second and you can guess if he's
going twice the speed and time is a
constant then he's going to go twice the
distance and that's easy to compute 36
times 2 you get 72 kilometers and so if
you had the question of how fast would
somebody is going three times that speed
or 30 meters per second is you can
easily compute the distance in our head
we can do that without needing a
computer but we want to do this for more
complicated data so it's kind of nice to
compare the two but let's just take a
look at that and what that looks like in
a graph so in a linear regression model
we have our distance to the speed and we
have our m equals the ve slope of the
line and we'll notice that the line has
a plus slope and as speed increase is
distance also increases hence the
variables have a positive relationship
and so your speed of the person which
equals y equals MX plus C distance
traveled in a fixed interval of time and
we could very easily compute either
following the line or just knowing us
three times ten meters per second that
this is roughly 102 kilometers distance
to this third bicep this has traveled
one of the key definitions on here is
positive relationship so the slope of
the line is positive as distance
increase so to speed increase let's take
a look at our second example where we
put distance is a constant so we have
speed equals 10 meters per second we
have a certain distance to go and it
takes them 100 seconds to travel that
distance and we have our second
bicyclist who's still doing 20 meters
per second since he's going twice the
speed we can guess that he'll cover the
distance in about half the time 50
seconds and of course you could probably
guess on the third one 100 divided by 30
since he's going three times the speed
you can easily guess that this is 33
point 333 seconds time we put that into
a linear regression model or a graph if
the distance is soon to be constant
let's see the relationship between speed
and time and as time goes up the amount
of speed to go that same distance goes
down so now your m equals a minus ve
slope of the line as the speed increases
time decreases hence the variable has a
negative relationship again there's our
definition positive relationship and
negative relationship dependent on the
slope of the line and with a simple
formula like this and even a significant
amount of data let's see what the
mathematical implementation of linear
regression and we'll take this data so
suppose we have this data set where we
have x y x equals one two three four
five standard series and the Y value is
three two two four three when we take
that and we go ahead and plot these
points on a graph you can see there's
kind of a nice scattering and you could
probably eyeball a line through the
middle of it but we're going to
calculate that exact line for linear
regression and the first thing we do is
we come up here we have the mean of x i
and remember mean is basically the
average so we added five plus four plus
three plus two plus one and divide by
five and that simply comes out as three
and then we'll do the same for y we'll
go ahead and add up all those numbers
and divide by five and we end up with
the mean value of y of I equals 2.8 or
the x i references it's an average or
means value and the Y I also equals a
means value of y and when we plot that
you'll see that we can put in the y
equals 2.8 and the x equals 3 in there
on our graph we kind of gave it a little
different color so you could sort it out
with the dashed lines on it and it's
important to note that when we do the
linear regression the linear regression
model should go through that dot now
let's find our regression equation to
find the best fit line remember we go
ahead and take our y equals MX plus C so
we're looking for M and C so to find
this equation for our data we need to
find our slope of M and our coefficient
of c and we have y equals MX plus C
where m equals the sum of x minus X
average times y minus y average or y
means and X means over the sum of x
minus X means squared that's how we get
the slope of the value of the line and
we can easily do that by creating some
columns here we have X Y computers are
really good about iterating through data
and so we can easily compute this and
fill in a graph of data and in our graph
you can easily see that if we have our x
value of 1 and if you remember the x i
or the means value is three one minus
three equals a negative two and two
minus three equals a negative one so on
and so forth and we can easily fill in
the column of x minus x i y minus y i
and then from those we can compute x
minus x i squared and x minus x i times
y minus y i and you can guess said that
the next step is to go ahead and sum the
different columns for the answers we
need so we get a total of 10 for our x
minus x i squared and a total of 2 for x
minus x i times y minus y i and we plug
those in we get 2 10 which equals 0.2 so
now we know the slope of our line equals
0.2 so we can calculate the value of c
that'd be the next step is we need to
know where it crosses the y axis and if
you remember I mentioned earlier that
the linear regression line has to pass
through the means value the one that we
showed earlier we can just flip back up
there to that graph and you can see
right here there's our means value which
is three x equals three and Y equals 2.8
and since we know that value we can
simply plug that into our formula y
equals 0.2 X plus C so we plug that in
we get 2.8 equals 0.2 times 3 plus C and
you can just solve for C so now we know
that our coefficient equals 2.2 and once
we have all that we can go ahead and
plot our regression line Y equals 0.2
times X Plus 2.2 and then from this
equation we can compute new values so
let's predict the values of Y using x
equals 1 2 3 4 5 and plot the points
remember the one two three four five was
our original X values so now we're going
to see what y thinks they are not what
they actually are and we plug those in
we get y of designated with Y of P you
can see that x equals 1 equals 2.4 x
equals 2 equals 2.6 and so on so on so
we have our y predicted values of what
we think is going to be when we plug
those numbers in and when we plot the
predicted values along with the axial
values we can see the difference and
this is one of the things that's very
important with linear regression in any
of these models is to understand the
error and so we can calculate the error
on all of our different values and you
can see over here we plotted X and Y and
Y predict and we'd run a little line so
you can sort of see what the arrow looks
like there between the different points
so our goal is to reduce this error we
want to minimize that error value on our
linear regression model minimizing the
distance there are lots of ways to
minimize the distance between the line
and the data points like sum of squared
errors sum of absolute errors root mean
square error Etc we keep moving this
line through the data points to make
sure the best fit line has the least
squared distance between the data points
and the regression line so to recap with
a very simple linear regression model we
first figure out the formula of our line
through the middle and then we slowly
adjust the line to minimize the error
keep in mind this is a very simple
formula the math gets even though the
math is very much the same it gets much
more complex as we add in different
dimensions so this is only two
Dimensions y equals MX plus C but you
can take that out to x z i j Q all the
different features in there and they can
plot a linear regression model on all of
those using the different formulas to
minimize the error let's go ahead and
take a look at decision trees a very
different way to solve problems than the
linear regression model decision tree is
a tree shaped algorithm used to
determine a course of action each branch
of a tree represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction we have data
which tells us if it is a good day to
play golf
if we were to open this data up in a
general spreadsheet you can see we have
the Outlook whether it's a rainy
overcast Sunny temperature hot mild cool
humidity windy and did I like to play
golf that day yes or no so we're taking
a census and certainly I wouldn't want a
computer telling me when I should go
play golf or not but you could imagine
if you got up in the night before you're
trying to plan your day and it comes up
and says tomorrow would be a good day
for golf for you in the morning and not
a good day in the afternoon or something
like that this becomes very beneficial
and we see this in a lot of applications
coming out now where it gives you
suggestions and lets you know what would
fit the match for you for the next day
or the next purchase or the next
whatever you know next meal out in this
case is tomorrow a good day for playing
golf based on the weather coming in and
so we come up and let's determine if you
should play golf when the day is sunny
and windy so we found out the forecast
tomorrow is going to be sunny and windy
and suppose we draw our tree like this
we're going to have our humidity and
then we have our normal which is if it's
if you have a normal humidity you're
going to go play golf and if the
humidity is really high then we look at
the Outlook and if the Outlook is sunny
overcast or rainy it's going to change
what you choose to do so if you know
that it's a very high humidity and it's
sunny you're probably not going to play
golf because you're going to be out
there miserable fighting off the
mosquitoes that are out joining you to
play golf with you maybe if it's rainy
you probably don't want to play in the
rain but if it's slightly overcast you
get just the right Shadow that's a good
day to play golf and be outside out on
the green now in this example you can
probably make your own tree pretty
easily because it's a very simple set of
data going in but the question is how do
you know what to split where do you
split your data what if this is much
more complicated data where it's not
something that you would particularly
understand like studying cancer they
take about 36 measurements of the
cancerous cells and then each one of
those measurements represents how
bulbous it is how extended it is how
sharp the edges are something that as a
human we would have no understanding of
so how do we decide how to split that
data up and is that the right decision
tree but so that's the question that's
going to come up is this the right
decision tree for that we should
calculate entropy and Information Gain
to important vocabulary words there are
the entropy and the Information Gain
entropy entropy is a measure of
Randomness or impurity in the data set
entropy should be low so we want the
chaos to be as low as possible we don't
want to look at it and be confused by
the images or what's going on there with
mixed data and the Information Gain it
is a measure of decrease in entropy
after the data set is split also known
as entropy reduction information gains
should be high so we want our
information that we get out of the split
to be as high as possible let's take a
look at entropy from the mathematical
side in this case we're going to denote
entropy as I of P of n n where p is the
probability that you're going to play a
game of golf and N is the probability
where you're not going to play the game
of golf now you don't really have to
memorize these formulas there's a few of
them out there depending on what you're
working with but it's important to note
that this is where this formula is
coming from so when you see it you're
not lost when you're running your
programming unless you're building your
own decision tree code in the back and
we simply have a log squared of p over P
plus n minus M over P plus n times the
log squared of n of p plus n but let's
break that down and see what actually
looks like when we're Computing that
from the computer script side entropy of
a target class of the data set is the
whole entropy so we have entropy play
golf and we look at this if we go back
to the data you can simply count how
many yeses and no in our complete data
set for playing golf days in our
complete set we find we have five days
we did play golf and nine days we did
not play golf and so our I equals if you
have those together nine plus five is
14. and so our I equals 5 over 14 and 9
over 14. that's our p and N values and
we plug into that formula and you can go
with 5 over 4T equals 0.36 9 over 14
equals 0.64 and when you do the whole
equation you get the minus 0.36 log root
squared of 0.36 minus 0.64 log square
root of 0.64 and we get a set value we
get
0.94 so we now have a full entropy value
for the whole set of data that we're
working with and we want to make that
entropy go down and just like we
calculated the entropy out for the whole
set we can also calculate entropy for
playing golf and the Outlook is it going
to be overcast or rainy or sunny and so
we look at the entropy we have P of
Sunny Times e of 3 of 2 and that just
comes out how many sunny days yes and
how many sunny days no over the total
which is 5. don't forget but we'll
divide that five out later on equals P
overcast equals 4 comma 0 plus rainy
equals two comma three and then when you
do the whole setup we have 5 over 14.
remember I said there was a total of
five five over fourteen times the I of
three of two plus four over fourteen
times the four comma zero and five
fourteen over I of two three and so we
can now compute the entropy of just the
part it has to do with the forecast and
we get 0.693 similarly we can calculate
the entropy of other predictors like
temperature humidity and wind and so we
look at the gain Outlook how much are we
going to gain from this entropy play
golf minus entropy play golf Outlook and
we can take the original 0.94 for the
whole set minus the entropy of just the
rainy day in temperature and we end up
with a gain of 0.247 so this is our
Information Gain remember we Define
entropy and we Define an information
gain the higher the information gain the
lower the entropy the better the
information gain of the other three
attributes can be calculated in the same
way so we have our gain for temperature
equals 0.029 we have our gain for
humidity equals 0.152 and our gain for a
windy day equals 0.048 and if you do a
quick comparison you'll see the 0.247 is
the greatest gain of information so
that's the split we want now let's build
the decision tree so we have the Outlook
is it going to be sunny overcast or
rainy that's our first split because
that gives us the most Information Gain
and we can continue to go down the tree
using the different information gains
with the largest information we can
continue down the nodes of the tree
where we choose the attribute with the
largest Information Gain as the root
node and then continue to split each sub
node with the largest Information Gain
that we can compute and although it's a
little bit of a tongue twister to say
all that you can see that it's a very
easy to view visual model we have our
Outlook we split it three different
directions if the Outlook is overcast
we're going to play and then we can
split those further down if we want so
if the Outlook is sunny but then it's
also windy if it's windy we're not going
to play if it's not windy we'll play so
we can easily build a nice decision tree
to guess what we would like to do
tomorrow and give us a nice
recommendation for the day so we want to
know if it's a good day to play golf
when it's sunny and windy remember the
original question that came out out
tomorrow's weather report is sunny and
windy you can see by going down the tree
we go Outlook Sunny Outlook windy we're
not going to play golf tomorrow so our
little smart watch pops up and says I'm
sorry tomorrow's not a good day for golf
it's going to be sunny and windy and if
you're a huge golf fan you might go uh
oh it's not a good day to play golf we
can go in and watch a golf game at home
so we'll sit in front of the TV instead
of being out playing golf in the wind
now that we looked at our decision tree
let's look at the third one of our
algorithms we're investigating support
Vector machine support Vector machine is
a widely used classification algorithm
the ideas support Vector machine is
simple the algorithm creates a
separation line which divides the
classes in the best possible manner for
example dog or cat disease or no disease
suppose we have a labeled sample data
which tells height and weight of males
and females a new data point arrives and
we want to know whether it's going to be
a male or a female so we start by
drawing a line we draw decision lines
but if we consider decision line one
then we will classify the individual as
a male and if we consider decision line
two then it will be a female so you can
see this person kind of lies in the
middle of the two groups so it's a
little confusing trying to figure out
which line they should be under we need
to know which line divides the classes
correctly but how the goal is to choose
a hyperplane and that is one of the key
words they use when we talk about
support Vector machines choose a
hyperplane with the greatest possible
margin between the decision line and the
nearest Point within the training set so
you can see here we have our support
Vector we have the two nearest points to
it and we draw a line between those two
points and the distance margin is the
distance between the hyperplane and the
nearest data point from either set so we
actually have a value and it should be
equal the distance between the two
points that we're comparing it to when
we draw the hyperplanes we observe that
line one has a maximum distance so we
observe that line 1 has a max from
distance margins so we'll classify the
new data point correctly and our result
on this one is going to be that the new
data point is Mel one of the reasons we
call it a hyperplane versus a line is
that a lot of times we're not looking at
just weight and height we might be
looking at 36 different features or
dimensions and so when we cut it with a
hyper plane it's more of a
three-dimensional cut in the data
multi-dimensional it cuts the data a
certain way and each plane continues to
cut it down until we get the best fit or
match let's understand this with the
help of an example problem statement I
always start with a problem statement
when you're going to put some code
together we're going to do some coding
now classifying muffin and cupcake
recipes using support Vector machines so
the cupcake versus the muffin let's have
a look at our data set and we have the
different recipes here we have a muffin
recipe that has so much flour I'm not
sure what measurement 55 is in but it
has 55 maybe it's ounces but a certain
amount of flour certain amount of milk
sugar butter egg baking powder vanilla
and salt and So based on these
measurements we want to guess whether
we're making a muffin or a cupcake and
you can see in this one we don't have
just two features we don't just have
height and weight as we did before
between the male and female in here we
have a number of features in fact in
this we're looking at eight different
features to guess whether it's a muffin
or a cupcake
what's the difference between a muffin
and a cupcake turns out muffins have
more flour while cupcakes have more
butter and sugar so basically the
cupcakes a little bit more of a dessert
where the muffins a little bit more of a
fancy bread but how do we do that in
Python how do we code that to go through
recipes and figure out what the recipe
is and I really just want to say
cupcakes versus muffins like some big
professional wrestling thing before we
started in our cupcakes versus muffins
we are going to be working in Python
there's many versions of python many
different editors that is one of the
strengths and weaknesses of python is it
just has so much stuff attached to it
it's one of the more popular data
science programming packages you can use
in this case we're going to go ahead and
use anaconda in Jupiter nopa the
Anaconda Navigator has all kinds of fun
tools once you're into the Anaconda
Navigator you can change environments I
actually have a number of environments
on here we'll be using python36
environment so this is in Python version
three six although it doesn't matter too
much which version you use I usually try
to stay with the 3x because they're
current unless you have a project that's
very specifically in version 2x 2 7 I
think is usually what most people use in
the version two and then once we're in
our Jupiter notebook editor I can go up
and create a new file and we'll just
jump in here
in this case we're doing svm muffin
versus Cupcake and then let's start with
our packages for data analysis
and we almost always use a couple
there's a few very standard packages we
use
we use import oops import import
numpy
that's for number python leaves they
denote it as NP that's very comma
that's very common
and then we're going to import pandas as
PD
and numpy deals with number arrays
there's a lot of cool things you can do
with the numpy setup as far as
multiplying all the values in an array
in an empty array data array pandas I
can't remember if we're using it
actually in this data set I think we do
as an import it makes a nice data frame
and the difference between a data frame
and a numpy array is it a data frame
it's more like your Excel spreadsheet
you have columns you have indexes so you
have different ways of referencing it
easily viewing it and there's additional
features you can run on a data frame and
pandas kind of sits on numpy so that you
need them both in there
and then finally we're working with the
support Vector machine so from SK learn
we're going to use the sklearn model
import svm support Vector machine
and then as a data scientist you should
always try to visualize your data some
data obviously is too complicated or
doesn't make any sense to the human but
if it's possible it's good to take a
second look at it so that you can
actually see what you're doing now for
that we're going to use two packages
we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pi plot as PLT again very
common
and we're going to import Seaborn as SNS
and we'll go ahead and set the font
scale in the SNS right in our import
line that's what this semicolon followed
by a line of data we're going to set the
SNS and these are great because the the
Seaborn sits on top of matplot Library
just like pandas hits on numpy so it
adds a lot more features and uses and
control we're obviously not going to get
into matplot library and Seabourn it'd
be its own tutorial we're really just
focusing on the svm the support Vector
machine from sklearn and since we're in
Jupiter notebook we have to add a
special line in here for our matplot
library and that's your percentage sign
or Amber sign matplot library in line
now if you're doing this in just a
straight code Project A lot of times I
use like notepad plus plus and I'll run
it from there you don't have to have
that line in there because it'll just
pop up as its own window on your
computer depending on how your computer
set
because we're writing this in the
Jupiter notebook as a browser setup this
tells it to display all of our Graphics
right below on the page so that's what
that line is for remember the first time
I ran this I didn't know that and I had
to go look that up years ago that was
quite a headache so matplot Library
inline is just because we're running
this on the web setup and we can go
ahead and run this make sure all our
modules are in they're all imported
which is great if you don't have them
import you'll need to go ahead and pip
use the PIP or however you do it there's
a lot of other install packages out
there although pip is the most common
and you have to make sure these are all
installed on your python setup the next
step of course is we got to look at the
data you can't run a model for
predicting data if you don't have actual
data so to do that let me go ahead and
open this up and take a look and we have
our cupcakes versus muffins and it's a
CSV file or dot CSV meaning that it's
comma separated variable
I'm just going to open it up in a nice
uh spreadsheet for me and you can see up
here we have the type we have muffin
muffin muffin cupcake cupcake cupcake
and then it's broken up into flour milk
sugar butter egg baking powder vanilla
and salt
so we can do is we can go ahead and look
at this data also in our python
let us create a variable recipes equals
we're going to use our pandas module
dot read
CSV remember as a comma separated
variable
and the file name happened to be
cupcakes versus muffins oops I got
double brackets there
there we go cupcakes versus muffins
because the program I loaded or the the
place I saved this particular Python
program is in the same folder we get by
with just the file name but remember if
you're storing it in a different
location you have to also put down the
full path on there
and then because we're in pandas we're
going to go ahead and you can actually
in line you can do this but let me do
the full print and you can just type in
recipes dot head
in the Jupiter notebook but if you're
running in code in a different script
you'd need to go ahead and type out the
whole print recipes dot head
and Panda's nose is that's going to do
the first five lines of data and if we
flip back on over to the spreadsheet
where we opened up our CSV file
uh you can see where it starts on line
two this one calls it zero and then two
three four five six is going to match go
and close that out because we don't need
that anymore and it always starts at
zero these are it automatically indexes
it since we didn't tell it to use an
index in here so that's the index number
for the left hand side and it
automatically took the top row as labels
so pandas
using it to read a CSV is just really
slick and fast one of the reasons we
love our pandas not just because they're
cute and cuddly teddy bears
and let's go ahead and plot our data and
I'm not going to plot all of it I'm just
going to plot the sugar and flour
now obviously you can see where they get
really complicated if we have tons of
different features and so you'll break
them up and maybe look at just two of
them at a time to see how they connect
and to plot them we're going to go ahead
and use Seaborn
so that's our SNS and the command for
that is
sns.lmplot and then the two different
variables I'm going to plot is flour and
sugar
data equals recipes
the Hue equals type and this is a lot of
fun because it knows that this is pandas
coming in so this is one of the powerful
things about pandas mixed with Seabourn
in doing
graphing
and then we're going to use a palette
set one there's a lot of different sets
in there you can go look them up for
Seabourn or do a regular regular equals
false so we're not really trying to fit
anything and it's a scatter kws
a lot of these settings you can look up
in Seabourn half of these you could
probably leave off when you run them
somebody played with this and found out
that these were the best settings for
doing a Seabourn plot
now let's go ahead and run that
and because it does it in line it just
puts it right on the page
and you can see right here that just
based on sugar and flour alone there's a
definite split
and we use these models because you can
actually look at it and say hey if I
drew a line right between the middle of
the blue dots and the red dots we'd be
able to do an svm and a hyperplane right
there in the middle
then the next step is to format or pre
process our data
and we're going to break that up into
two parts
we need to type
label and remember we're going to decide
whether it's a muffin or a cupcake well
a computer doesn't know muffin or
cupcake at no zero and one
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a type label
and from this we'll create a numpy array
and P where
and this is where we can do some logic
we take our recipes from our Panda and
wherever a type equals muffin is going
to be zero and then if it doesn't equal
muffin which is cupcakes it's going to
be one so we create our type label
this is the answer so when we're doing
our training model remember we have to
have a training data this is what we're
going to train it with is that it's zero
or one it's a muffin or it's not
and then we're going to create our
recipe
features
and if you remember correctly from right
up here the First Column is type
so we really don't need the type column
because that's our muffin or cupcake and
in pandas we can easily sort that out
we take our value recipes
dot columns that's a panda's function
built into pandas
we've got values converting them to
values so it's just the column titles
going across the top and we don't want
the first one so what we do is it always
starts at zero we want one
colon till the end
and then
we want to go ahead and make this a list
and this converts it to a list of
strings
and then we can go ahead and just take a
look and see we're looking at for the
features make sure it looks right
let me go ahead and run that
and I forgot the S on recipes so we'll
go ahead and add the s in there and then
run that and we can see we have flour
milk sugar butter egg and baking powder
vanilla and salt and that matches what
we have up here right where we printed
out everything but the type so we have
our features and we have our label
Now the recipe features is just the
titles of the columns we actually need
the ingredients
and at this point we have a couple
options one we could run it over all the
ingredients
and when you're dealing this usually you
do but for our example we want to limit
it so you can easily see what's going on
because if we did all the ingredients
we have you know that's what
um seven eight different hyper planes
that would be built into it we only want
to look at one so you can see what the
svm is doing
and so we'll take our recipes and we'll
do just flour and sugar
again you can replace that with your
recipe features and do all of them but
we're going to do just flour and sugar
and we're going to convert that to
values we don't need to make a list out
of it because it's not string values
these are actual
values on there and we can go ahead and
just print
ingredients and you can see what that
looks like
and so we have just another flour and
sugar just the two sets of plots
and just for fun let's go ahead and take
this over here and take our recipe
features
and so if we decided to use all the
recipe features
you'll see that it makes a nice column
of different data so it just strips out
all the labels and everything we just
have just the values but because we want
to be able to view this easily in a plot
later on we'll go ahead and take that
and just do flour and sugar
and we'll run that and you'll see it's
just the two columns
so the next step is to go ahead and fit
our model
we'll go ahead and just call it model
and it's a svm we're using a package
called SVC
in this case we're going to go ahead and
set the kernel equals linear so it's
using a specific setup on there and if
we go to the reference on their website
for the svm
you'll see that there's about there's
eight of them here three of them are for
regression
three or four classification the SVC
support Vector classification is
probably one of the most commonly used
and then there's also one for detecting
outliers and another one that has to do
with something a bit more specific on
the model but SVC and SBR are the two
most commonly used standing for support
vector classifier and support Vector
regression remember regression is an
actual value a float value or whatever
you're trying to work on and SBC is a
classifier so it's a yes no true false
but for this we want to know zero one
muffin cupcake
if we go ahead and create our model and
once we have our model created we're
going to do model dot fit and this is
very common especially in the SK learn
all their models are followed with the
fit command
and what we put into the fit what we're
training with it is we're putting in the
ingredients which in this case we
limited to just flour and sugar
and the type label is it a muffin or
cupcake
now in more complicated data science
series you'd want to split into we won't
get into that today we split it into uh
training data and test data and they
even do something where they split it
into thirds where a third is used for
whether you switch between which one's
training and test there's all kinds of
things go into that it gets very
complicated when you get to the higher
end not overly complicated just an extra
step which we're not going to do today
because this is a very simple set of
data
and let's go ahead and run this and now
we have our model fit
and I got an error here so let me fix
that real quick it's Capital SBC it
turns out
I did it lower case
support vector
classifier there we go let's go ahead
and run that
and you'll see it comes up with all this
information that it prints out
automatically these are the defaults of
the model you notice that we change the
kernel to linear and there's our kernel
linear on the printout and there's other
different settings you can mess with
we're going to just to leave that alone
for right now for this we don't really
need to mess with any of those
next
dig a little bit into our newly trained
model
and we're going to do this so we can
show you on a graph
and let's go ahead and get the
separating
so we're going to say we're going to use
a W for our variable on here
we're going to do model dot coefficient
underscore zero so what the heck is that
again we're digging into the model so
we've already got a prediction and a
train this is a math behind it that
we're looking at right now
and so
the W is going to represent two
different coefficients and if you
remember we had y equals MX plus C so
these coefficients are connected to that
but in two-dimensional it's a plane
we don't want to spend too much time on
this because you can get lost in the
confusion of the math so if you're a
math whiz this is great you can go
through here and you'll see that we have
a equals minus W of 0 over W of one
remember there's two different values
there and that's basically the slope
that we're generating
and then we're going to build an XX what
is XX we're going to set it up to a
numpy array there's our NP dot line
space so we're creating a line
of values between 30 and 60. so it just
creates a set of numbers for x
and then if you remember correctly we
have
our formula y equals the slope times x
plus The Intercept well to make this
work we can do this as y y equals the
slope times each value in that array
that's the neat thing about numpy so
when I do a times XX which is a whole
lumpy array of values it multiplies a
across all of them
and then it takes those same values and
we subtract the model intercept that's
your uh where we had MX plus C so that'd
be the C from the formula y equals MX
plus c
and that's where all these numbers come
from a little bit confusing because it's
digging out of these different arrays
and then we want to do is we're going to
take this and we're going to go ahead
and plot it
so plot the parallels to separating
hyperplane that pass through the support
vectors and so we're going to create b
equals a model support vectors pulling
our support vectors out there here's our
YY which we now know is a set of data we
have we're going to create YY down
equals a times XX plus B1 minus a times
B 0 and then model support Vector B is
going to be set that to a new value the
minus one set up and YY up equals a
times XX plus B1 minus a times b0
and we can go ahead and just run this to
load these variables up if you want to
know understand a little bit more of
what's going on you can see if we print
YY let me just run that you can see it's
an array this is a line it's going to
have in this case between 30 and 60 so
it's going to be 30 variables in here
and the same thing with YY up YY down
and we'll plot those in just a minute on
the graph so you can see what those look
like
just go ahead and delete that out of
here
and run that so it loads up the
variables nice clean slate
I'm just going to copy this from before
remember this our
sns.rcboard plot LM plot flower sugar
and I'll just go ahead and run that real
quick so you can see remember what that
looks like it's just a straight graph on
there
and then one of the neat things is
because Seaborn sits on top of Pi plot
we can do the pi plot for the line going
through and that is simply PLT Dot Plot
and that's our XX
and YY are two corresponding values x y
and then somebody played with this to
figure out that the line width equals 2
and the color black would look nice
so let's go ahead and run this whole
thing with the pi plot on there and you
can see when we do this it's just doing
flour and sugar on here
corresponding line between the sugar and
the flower and the muffin versus Cupcake
and then we generated the support
vectors the YY down and y y out so let's
take a look and see what that looks like
so we'll do our PL plot
and again this is all against XX or our
x value but this time we have YY
down
and let's do something a little fun with
this
we can put in a k Dash Dash
that just tells it to mimic it you can
see how easy it is to see based just on
sugar and flour which one's a muffin or
a cupcake
let's go ahead and create a function
to predict
muffin or cupcake
I've got my recipes I pulled off the um
internet and I want to see the
difference between a
muffin or a cupcake and so we need a
function to push that through and create
a function with Def
and let's call it muffin or cupcake and
remember we're just doing flour and
sugar today we're not doing all the
ingredients and that actually is a
pretty good split you really don't need
all the ingredients to know it's flour
and sugar
and let's go ahead and do an if else
statement so if model predict
is of flour and sugar equals zero so we
take our model and we do it run a
predict that's very common in SK learn
we have a DOT predict you put the data
in and it's going to return a value in
this case if it equals zero then print
you're looking at a muffin recipe
else if it's not zero that means it's
one then you're looking at a cupcake
recipe
that's pretty straightforward for
function or def for definition def is
how you do that in Python
and of course we're going to create a
function you should run something in it
and so let's run a cupcake and we're
going to send it values 50 and 20 a
muffin or a cupcake I don't know what it
is
and let's run this and just see what it
gives us and it says oh it's a muffin
you're looking at a muffin recipe so it
very easily predicts whether we're
looking at a muffin or a cupcake recipe
let's plot this so there we go plot this
on the graph so we can see where that
actually looks like
and I'm just going to copy and paste it
from below where we're plotting all the
points in there
so this is nothing different than we did
before if I run it you'll see it has all
the points and the lines on there and
what we want to do is we want to add
another point
and we'll do PLT plot
remember correctly we did for our test
we did 50
. and then somebody went in here and
decided we'll do y o for yellow or it's
kind of an orangish yellow color is
going to come out marker size nine those
are settings you can play with somebody
else played with them to come up with
the right setup so it looks good and you
can see there it is graphed clearly a
muffin
in this case in cupcakes versus muffins
the muffin has won and if you'd like to
do your own muffin cupcake Contender
series you certainly can send a note
down below and the team at simply learn
will send you over the data they use for
the muffin and cupcake and that's true
of any of the data we didn't actually
run a plot on it earlier we had men
versus women you can also request that
information to run it on your data setup
so you can test that out
so to go back over our setup we went
ahead for our support Vector machine
code we did a predict 40 Parts flower 20
Parts sugar I think it was different
than the one we did whether it's a
muffin or a cupcake hence we have built
a classifier using svm which is able to
classify if a recipe is of a cupcake or
a muffin which wraps up our cupcake
versus muffin today in our second
tutorial we're going to cover k-means
and linear regression along with going
over the quiz questions we had during
our first tutorial
what's in it for you we're going to
cover clustering what is clustering K
means clustering which is one of the
most common used clustering tools out
there including a flow chart to
understand k-means clustering and how it
functions and then we'll do an actual
python live demo on clustering of cars
based on Brands then we're going to
cover logistic regression what is
logistic regression logistic regression
curve and sigmoid function and then
we'll do another python code demo to
classify a tumor as malignant or B9
based on features and let's start with
clustering suppose we have a pile of
books of different genres now we divide
them into different groups like fiction
horror education and as we can see from
this young lady she definitely is into
heavy you can just tell by those
eyes and the maple Canadian leaf on her
shirt but we have fiction horror and
education we want to go ahead and divide
our books up well organizing objects
into groups based on similarity is
clustering and in this case as we're
looking at the books we're talking about
clustering things with known categories
but you can also use it to explore data
so you might not know the categories you
just know that you need to divide it up
in some way to conquer the data and to
organize it better but in this case
we're going to be looking at clustering
in specific categories and let's just
take a deeper look at that we're going
to use K means clustering K means
clustering is probably the most commonly
used clustering tool in the machine
learning library k-me's clustering is an
example of unsupervised learning if you
remember from our previous thing it is
used when you have unlabeled data so we
don't know the answer yet we have a
bunch of data that we want to Cluster to
different groups to find clusters in the
data based on feature similarity so
we've introduced a couple terms here
we've already talked about unsupervised
learning and unlabeled data so we don't
know the answer yet we're just going to
group stuff together and see if we can
find an answer of how things connect
we've also in a introduced feature
similarity features being different
features of the data now with books we
can easily see fiction and horror and
history books but a lot of times with
data some of that information isn't so
easy to see right when we first look at
it and so k-means is one of those tools
where we can start finding things that
connect that match with each other
suppose we have these data points and
want to assign them into a cluster now
when I look at these data points I would
probably group them into two clusters
just by looking at them I'd say two of
these group of data kind of come
together but in K means we pick K
clusters and assign random centroids to
clusters where the K clusters represents
two different clusters we pick K
clusters inside random centroids to the
Clusters then we compute distance from
objects to the centroids now we form new
clusters based on minimum distances and
calculate the centroids so we figure out
what the best distance is for the
centroid then we move the centroid and
recalculate those senses repeat previous
two steps iteratively till the cluster
centroid stop changing their positions
and become Static repeat previous two
steps iteratively to the cluster
centroid stop changing and the positions
become Static once the Clusters become
Static then K means clustering algorithm
is said to be converged and there's
another term we see throughout machine
learning is converged that means
whatever math we're using to figure out
the answer has come to a solution or
it's converged on an answer shall we see
the flowchart to understand make a
little bit more sense by putting it into
a nice easy step-by-step so we start we
choose K we'll look at the elbow method
in just a moment we assign random
centroids to clusters and sometimes you
pick the centroids because you might
look at the data in a graph and say oh
these are probably the central points
then we compute the distance from the
objects to the centroids we take that
and we form new clusters based on
minimum distance and calculate their
centroids then we compute the distance
from object to the new centroids and
then we go back and repeat those last
two steps we calculate the distances so
as we're doing it brings into the new
centroid and then we move the centroid
around and we figure out what the best
which objects are closest to each
centroid so the objects can switch from
one centroid to the other the centroids
are moved around and we continue that
until it is converged
let's see an example of this suppose we
have this data set of seven individuals
and their score on two topics A and B so
here's our subject in this case
referring to the person taking the test
and then we have subject a where we see
what they've scored on their first
subject and we have subject B and we can
see what they score on the second
subject now let's take two farthest
apart points as initials cluster
centroids remember we talked about
selecting them randomly or we can also
just put them in different points and
pick the furthest one apart so they move
together either one works okay depending
on what kind of data you're working on
and what you know about it so we took
the two furthest points one and one and
five and seven and now let's take the
two farthest apart points as initial
cluster centroids each point is then
assigned to the closest cluster with
respect to the distance from the
centroids so we take each one of these
points in there we measure that distance
and you can see that if we measured each
of those distances and you'd use the a
Pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you know the X and the
Y and you can figure out the diagonal
line from that or you just take a ruler
and put it on your monitor that'd be
kind of silly but it would work if
you're just eyeballing it you can see
how they naturally come together in
certain areas now we again calculate the
centroids of each cluster so cluster one
and then cluster two and we look at each
individual dot there's one two three
we're in one cluster the centroid then
moves over it becomes 1.8 comma 2.3 so
remember it was at one and one well the
very center of the data we're looking at
would put it at the one point roughly 2
2 but 1.8 and 2.3 and the second one if
we wanted to make the overall mean
Vector the average Vector of all the
different distances to that centroid we
come up with four comma 1 and 5 4. so
we've now moved the centroids We compare
each individual's distance to its own
cluster mean and to that of the opposite
cluster and we find we can build a nice
chart on here that the as we move that
centroid around we now have a new
different kind of clustering of groups
and using euclidean distance between the
points and the mean we get the same
formula you see as new formulas coming
up so we have our individual dots
distance to the mean centrate of the
cluster and distance to the mean
centroid of the cluster only individual
3 is nearer to the mean of the opposite
cluster cluster 2 then its own cluster
one and you can see here in the diagram
where we've kind of circled that one in
the middle so when we've moved the
cluster the centroids of the Clusters
over one of the points shifted to the
other cluster because it's closer to
that group of individuals thus
individual 3 is relocated to Cluster 2
resulting in a new Partition and we
regenerate all those numbers of how
close they are to the different clusters
for the new clusters we will find the
actual cluster centroids so now we move
the centroids over and you can see that
we've now formed two very distinct
clusters on here on comparing the
distance of each individual's distance
to its own cluster mean and to that of
the opposite cluster we find that the
data points are stable hence we have our
final clusters now if you remember I
brought up a concept earlier k mean on
the k-means algorithm choosing the right
value of K will help in less number of
iterations and to find the appropriate
number of clusters in a data set we use
the elbow method and within sum of
squares WSS is defined as the sum of the
squared distance between each member of
the cluster in its centroid and so you
see we've done here is we have the
number of clusters and as you do the
same K means algorithm over the
different clusters and you calculate
what that centroid looks like and you
find the optimal you can actually find
the optimal number of clusters using the
elbow the graph is called as the elbow
method and on this we guessed at 2 just
by looking at the data but as you can
see the slope you actually just look for
right there where the elbow is and the
slope and you have a clear answer that
we want two different to start with k
means equals two a lot of times people
end up Computing k-means equals two
three four five until they find the
value which fits on the elbow joint
sometimes you can just look at the data
and if you're really good with that
specific domain remember domain I
mentioned that last time you'll know
that that where to pick those numbers
and where to start guessing at with that
K value
so let's take this and we're going to
use a use case using K means clustering
to Cluster cars into Brands using
parameters such as horsepower cubic
inches make year Etc so we're going to
use the data set cars data having
information about three brands of cars
Toyota Honda and Nissan we'll go back to
my favorite tool the Anaconda Navigator
with the Jupiter notebook and let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupyter
notebook and in our jupyter notebook I'm
going to go ahead and just paste the
basic code that we usually start a lot
of these off with we're not going to go
too much into this code because we've
already discussed numpy we've already
discussed matplot library and pandas
that'll be being the number array pandas
being the pandas data frame and matplot
for the graphing and don't forget since
if you're using the Jupiter notebook you
do need the matplot library in line so
that it plots everything on the screen
if you're using a different python
editor then you probably don't need that
because it'll have a pop-up window on
your computer and we'll go ahead and run
this just to load our libraries and our
setup into here the next step is of
course to look at our data which I've
already opened up in a spreadsheet and
you can see here we have the miles per
gallon cylinders cubic inches horsepower
weight pounds how heavy it is time it
takes to get to 60. my card is probably
on this one at about 80 or 90. what year
it is so this is you can actually see
this is kind of older cars and then the
brand Toyota Honda Nissan so the
different cars are coming from all the
way from 1971 if we scroll down to the
80s we have between the 70s and 80s the
number of cars that they've put out and
let's uh we come back here we're going
to do importing the data so we'll go
ahead and do data set equals and we'll
use pandas to read this in and it's uh
from a CSV file remember you can always
post this in the comments and request
the data files for these either in the
comments here on the YouTube video or go
to simplylearn.com and request that the
car CSV I put it in the same folder as
the code that I've stored so my python
code is stored in the same folder so I
don't have to put the full path if you
store them in different folders you do
have to change this and double check
your name variables and we'll go ahead
and run this and we've chosen data set
arbitrarily because it's a data set
we're importing and we've now imported
our cars CSV into the data set
as you know you have to prep the data so
we're going to create the X data this is
the one that we're going to try to
figure out what's going on with and then
there's a number of ways to do this but
we'll do it in a simple Loop so you can
actually see what's going on so we'll do
for i n x dot columns so we're going to
go through each of the columns and a lot
of times it's important I'll make lists
of the columns and do this because I
might remove certain columns or there
might be columns that I want to be
processed differently but for this we
can go ahead and take X of I and we want
to go fill in a and that's a pandas
command but the question is what are we
going to fill the missing data with we
definitely don't want to just put in a
number that doesn't actually mean
something and so one of the tricks you
can do with this is we can take X of I
and in addition to that we want to go
ahead and turn this into an integer
because a lot of these are integers so
we'll go ahead and keep it integers and
let me add the bracket here a lot of
editors will do this they'll think that
you're closing one bracket make sure you
get that second bracket in there if it's
a double bracket that's always something
that happens regularly so once we have
our integer of X of Y this is going to
fill in any missing data with the
average and I was so busy closing one
set of brackets I forgot that the mean
is also has brackets in there for the
pandas so we can see here we're going to
fill in all the data with the average
value for that column so if there's
missing data it's in the average of the
data it does have then once we've done
that we'll go ahead and loop through it
again
and just check and see to make sure
everything is filled in correctly and it
will print and then we take X is null
and this returns a set of the null
Valley or the how many lines are null
and we'll just sum that up to see what
that looks like and so when I run this
and so with the X what we want to do is
we want to remove the last column
because it had the models that's what
we're trying to see if we can cluster
these things and figure out the models
there is so many different ways to sort
the X out for one we could take the X
and we could go data set our variable
we're using and use the I location one
of the features that's in pandas
and we could take that and then take all
the rows and all but the last column of
the data set and at this time we could
do values we just convert it to values
so that's one way to do this and if I
let me just put this down here and print
X
capital x we chose and I run this you
can see it's just the values we could
also take out the values and it's not
going to return anything because there's
no values connected to it what I like to
do with this is instead of doing the I
location which does integers more common
is to come in here and we have our data
set and we're going to do data set dot
or dataset dot columns and remember that
lists all the columns so if I come in
here
let me just Mark that as red and I print
data set dot columns
you can see that I have my index here I
have my MPG cylinders everything
including the brand which we don't want
so the way to get rid of the brand would
be to do data Columns of Everything But
the last one minus one so now if I print
this you'll see the brand disappears
and so I can actually just take data set
columns minus one
and I'll put it right in here for the
columns we're going to look at
and let's unmark this
and unmark this
and now if I do an x dot head I have a
new data frame and you can see right
here we have all the different columns
except for the brand at the end of the
year
and it turns out when you start playing
with the data set you're going to get an
error later on and it'll say cannot
convert string to float value and that's
because if for some reason these things
the way they recorded them must have
been recorded as strings so we have a
neat feature in here on pandas to
convert and it is simply convert objects
and for this we're going to do convert
oops convert underscore
numeric numeric equals true and yes I
did have to go look that up I don't have
it memorized the convert numeric in
there if I'm working with a lot of these
things I remember them but um depending
on where I'm at what I'm doing I usually
have to look it up and we run that oops
I must have missed something in here let
me double check my spelling and when I
double check my spelling you'll see I
missed the first underscore in the
convert objects when I run this it now
has everything converted
into a numeric value because that's what
we're going to be working with is
numeric values down here
and the next part is that we need to go
through the data and eliminate null
values most people when they're doing
small amounts you're working with small
data pools discover afterwards that they
have a null value and they have to go
back and do this so you know be aware
whenever we're formatting this data
things are going to pop up and sometimes
you go backwards to fix it and that's
fine that's just part of exploring the
data and understanding what you have
and I should have done this earlier but
let me go ahead and increase the size of
my window one notch
there we go easier to see
so we'll do 4i in working with x dot
columns we'll page through all the
columns and we want to take
X of I we're going to change that we're
going to alter it and so with this we
want to go ahead and fill in X of I
pandas has the fill in a
and that just fills in any non-existent
missing data
I'll put my brackets up and there's a
lot of different ways to fill this data
if you have a really large data set some
people just void out that data because
they and then look at it later in a
separate exploration of data one of the
tricks we can do is we can take our
column and we can find the means
and the means is in other are quotation
marks so we take the columns we're going
to fill in the non-existing one with the
means the problem is that returns a
decimal float so some of these aren't
decimals certainly let me be a little
careful of doing this but for this
example we're just going to fill it in
with the integer version of this keeps
it on par with the other data that isn't
a decimal point
and then what we also want to do is we
want to double check
a lot of times you do this first part
first to double check that you do the
fill and then you do it again just to
make sure you did it right so we're
going to go through and test for missing
data
and one of the ways you can do that is
simply go in here
and take our X of I column so it's going
to go through the x of I column it says
is null so it's going to return any any
place there's a null value it actually
goes through all the rows of each column
is null and then we want to go ahead and
sum that so we take that we add the sum
value and these are all pandas so is
null is a panda command and so is sum
and if we go through that we go ahead
and run it
and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns have
zero null values so we've now tested and
double checked and our data is nice and
clean we have no null values everything
is now a number value we turned it into
numeric and we've removed the last
column in our data
and at this point we're actually going
to start using the elbow method to find
the optimal number of clusters so we're
now actually getting into the sklearn
part the K means clustering on here
well I guess we'll go ahead and zoom it
up one more Notch so you can see what
I'm typing in here
and then from sklearn I'm going to R or
sklearn
cluster
I'm going to import k
means
I always forget to capitalize the K and
the M when I do this so it's capital K
capital M K means
and we'll go and create a array wcss
equals let me get an empty array if you
remember from the elbow method from our
slide
within the sums of squares WSS is
defined as the sum of squared distance
between each member of the cluster and
its centroid so we're looking at that
change in differences as far as a
squared distance and we're going to run
this over a number of K mean values
in fact let's go for I in range we'll do
11 of them
bringing 0 of 11.
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to create the actual we'll
do it all lower case
and so we're going to create this object
from the K mean so we just imported
and the variable that we want to put
into this is in
clusters and we're going to set that
equals to I that's the most important
one because we're looking at how
increasing the number of clusters
changes our answer there are a lot of
settings to the K means
our guys in the back did a great job
just kind of playing with some of them
the most common ones that you see in a
lot of stuff is how you would knit your
k-means so we have K means plus plus
this is just a tool to let the model
itself be smart how it picks its
centroids to start with its initial
centroids we only want to iterate no
more than 300 times we have a Max
iteration we put in there
we have a the infinite the random State
equals zero you really don't need to
worry too much about these when you're
first learning this as you start digging
in deeper you start finding that these
are shortcuts that will speed up the
process
as far as the setup but the big one that
we're working with is the in clusters
equals I so we're going to literally
train our K means 11 times we're going
to do this process 11 times and if
you're working with big data you know
the first thing you do is you run a
small sample of the data so you can test
all your stuff on it and you can already
see the problem that if I'm going to
iterate through a terabyte of data 11
times and then the k-means itself is
iterating through the data multiple
times that's a heck of a process
so you got to be a little careful with
this a lot of times though you can find
your elbow using the elbow method find
your optimal number on a sample of data
especially if you're working with larger
data sources
so we want to go ahead and take our
k-means and we're just going to fit it
if you're looking at any of the SK learn
very common that you fit your model if
you remember correctly our variable
we're using is the capital x and once we
fit this value we go back to the array
we made and we want to go and just
depend that value on the end
and it's not the actual fit we're
pinning in there it's when it generates
it it generates the value you're looking
for is inertia so K means dot inertia
will pull that specific value out that
we need
and let's get a visual on this we'll do
our PLT plot and what we're plotting
here
is first the x-axis which is range 0 11.
so that will generate a nice little plot
there and the wcss for our y-axis
it's always nice to give our plot a
title
and let's see we'll just give it the
elbow method for the title and let's get
some labels so let's go ahead and do PLT
X label
and what we'll do we'll do number of
clusters for that and PLT y label
and for that we can do oops
wcss since that's what we're doing on
the plot on there and finally we want to
go ahead and display our graph which is
simply PLT dot oops
dot show there we go and because we have
it set to inline it will appear in line
hopefully I didn't make a type error on
there
and you can see we get a very nice graph
you can see a very nice elbow joint
there at 2 and again right around three
and four and then after that there's not
very much
now as a data scientist if I was looking
at this I would do either three or four
and I'd actually try both of them to see
what the output looked like and they've
already tried this in the back so we're
just going to use three as a setup on
here and let's go ahead and see what
that looks like when we actually use
this to show the different kinds of cars
and so let's go ahead and apply the
k-means to the car's data set and
basically we're going to copy the code
that we looped through up above where K
means equals K means number of clusters
and we're just going to set the number
of clusters to three
since that's what we're going to look
for and you can do three and four on
this and graph them just to see how they
come up differently be kind of curious
to look at that but for this we're just
going to set it to three go ahead and
create our own variable y k means for
our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops I double equal there 2K means but
we're not going to do a fit we're going
to do a fit predict is the setup you
want to use and when you're using
untrained models you'll see a slightly
different because usually you see fit
and then you see just the predict but we
want to both fit and predict the k-means
on this and that's fit underscore
predict and then our capital x is the
data we're working with
and before we plot this data we're going
to do a little pandas trick we're going
to take our x value and we're going to
set X as Matrix so we're converting this
into a nice rows and columns kind of set
up but we want the we're going to have
columns equals none so it's just going
to be a matrix of data in here
and let's go ahead and run that
a little warning you'll see those
warnings pop up because things are
always being updated so there's like
minor changes in the versions and future
versions instead of Matrix now that's
more common to set it dot values instead
of doing as Matrix but Mass Matrix works
just fine for right now and you'll only
update that later on but let's go ahead
and dive in and plot this and see what
that looks like
and before we dive into plotting this
data I always like to take a look and
see what I am plotting so let's take a
look at y k means I'm just going to
print that out down here
and we see we have an array of answers
we have 2 1 0 2 1 2 so it's clustering
these different rows of data based on
the three different spaces it thinks
it's going to be
and then let's go ahead and print X and
see what we have for x and we'll see
that X is an array it's a matrix so we
have our different values in the array
and what we're going to do it's very
hard to plot all the different values in
the array so we're only going to be
looking at the first two or position
zero and one
and if you were doing a full
presentation in front of the board
meeting you might actually do a little
different than and dig a little deeper
into the different aspects because this
is all the different columns we looked
at but when we look at columns one and
two for this to make it easy so let's go
ahead and clear this data out of here
and let's bring up our plot and we're
going to do a scatter plot here so PLT
scatter
and
this looks a little complicated so let's
explain what's going on with this we're
going to take the X values
and we're only interested in y of K
means equals zero the first cluster okay
and then we're going to take value 0 for
the X axes and then we're going to do
the same thing here we're only
interested in K means equals zero but
we're going to take this second column
so we're looking at the first two
columns in our answer or in the data
and then the guys in the back played
with this a little bit to make it pretty
and they discovered that it looks good
if it's a size equals 100 that's the
size of the dots we're going to use red
for this one and when they were looking
at the data and what came out it was
definitely the Toyota on this we're just
going to go ahead and label it Toyota
again that's something you'd really have
to explore in here as far as playing
with those numbers and see what looks
good we'll go ahead and hit enter in
there and I'm just going to paste in the
next two lines which is the next two
cars
and this is our Nissa and Honda and
you'll see with our scatter plot we're
now looking at where y underscore K
means equals one
and we want the zero column and y k
means equals two again we're looking at
just the first two columns 0 and 1 and
each of these rows then corresponds to
Nissan and Honda
I'll go ahead and hit enter on there and
finally let's take a look and put the
centroids on there again we're going to
do a scatter plot
and on the centroids you can just pull
that from our K means the model we
created dot cluster centers and we're
going to just do
all of them in the first number and all
of them and the second number which is 0
1 because you always start with zero and
one
and then they were playing with the size
and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow and we'll label
them it's always good to have some good
labels centroids
and then we do want to do a title PLT
title
and pop up there PLT title so you always
make want to make your graphs look
pretty and we'll call it clusters of car
make
and one of the features of the plot
library is you can add a
Legend it'll automatically bring in it
since we've already labeled the
different aspects of the legend with
Toyota Nissan and Honda
and finally we want to go ahead and show
so we can actually see it and remember
it's in line so if you're using a
different editor that's not the jupyter
notebook you'll get a pop-up of this
and you should have a nice set of
clusters here so we can look at this and
we have a clusters of Honda and green
Toyota and red Nissan and purple and you
can see where they put the centroids to
separate them
now when we're looking at this we can
also plot a lot of other different data
on here as far because we only looked at
the first two columns this is just
column one and two or zero one as as you
label them in computer scripting but you
can see here we have a nice clusters of
car making we were able to pull out the
data and you can see how just these two
columns form very distinct clusters of
data
so if you were exploring new data you
might take a look and say well what
makes these different almost going in
reverse you start looking at the data
and pulling apart the columns to find
out why is the first group set up the
way it is maybe you're doing loans and
you want to go well why is this group
not defaulting on the loans and why is
the last group defaulting on their loans
and why is the middle group fifty
percent defaulting on their bank loans
and you start finding ways to manipulate
the data and pull out the answers you
want
foreign so now that you've seen how to
use K mean for clustering let's move on
to the next topic
now let's look into logistic regression
the logistic regression algorithm is the
simplest classification algorithm used
for binary or multi-classification
problems and we can see we have our
little girl from Canada who's into
horror books is back that's actually
really scary when you think about that
with those big
in the previous tutorial we learned
about linear regression dependent and
independent variables so to brush up y
equals MX plus C very basic algebraic
function of Y and X the dependent
variable is the target class variable we
are going to predict
the independent variables X1 all the way
up to X in are the features or
attributes we're going to use to predict
the target class we know what a linear
regression looks like but using the
graph we cannot divide the outcome into
categories it is really hard to
categorize 1.5
3.6 9.8 for example a linear regression
graph can tell us that with increase in
number of hours studied the marks of a
student will increase but it will not
tell us whether the student will pass or
not in such cases where we need the
output as categorical value we will use
logistic regression and for that we're
going to use the sigmoid function so you
can see here we have our marks 0 to 100
number of hours studied that's going to
be what they're comparing it to in this
example and we usually form a line that
says y equals MX plus C and when we use
the sigmoid function we have P equals 1
over 1 plus e to the minus y it
generates a sigmoid curve curve and so
you can see right here when you take the
Ln which is the natural logarithm I
always thought it should be in L not Ln
that's just the inverse of e or e to the
minus y and so we do this we get Ln of p
over 1 minus P equals m times X plus C
that's the sigmoid curve function we're
looking for
we can zoom in on the function and
you'll see that the function as it
derives goes to 1 or to zero depending
on what your x value is and the
probability if it's greater than 0.5 the
value is automatically rounded off to 1
indicating that the student will pass so
if they're doing a certain amount of
studying they will probably pass then
you have a threshold value at the 0.5 it
automatically puts that right in the
middle usually and your probability if
it's less than 0.5 the value rendered
off to zero indicating the student will
fail so if they're not studying very
hard they're probably going to fail this
of course is ignoring the outliers or
that one student is just a natural
genius and doesn't need any studying to
memorize everything that's not me
unfortunately I have to study hard to
learn new stuff
problem statement to classify whether a
tumor is malignant or B9 and this is
actually one of my favorite data sets to
play with because it has so many
features and when you look at them you
really are hard to understand you can't
just look at them and know the answer so
it gives you a chance to kind of dive
into what data looks like when you
aren't able to understand the specific
domain of the data but I also want you
to remind you that in the domain of
medicine if I told you that my
probability was really good at
classified things that say 90 or 95
percent and I'm classifying whether
you're going to have a malignant or a
benign tumor I'm guessing that you're
going to go get it tested anyways so you
got to remember the domain we're working
with so why would you want to do that if
you know you're just going to go get a
biopsy because you know it's that
serious this is like an all or nothing
just referencing the domain it's
important it might help the doctor know
where to look just by understanding what
kind of tumor it is so it might help
them or Aid them in something they
missed from before so let's go ahead and
dive into the code and I'll come back to
the domain part of it in just a minute
so use case and we're going to do our
normal Imports here where we're
importing numpy pandas Seaborn the
matplat library and we're going to do
matplot library in line since I'm going
to switch over to Anaconda so let's go
ahead and flip over there and get this
started
so I've opened up a new window in my
anaconda Jupiter notebook
and by the way Jupiter notebook you
don't have to use Anaconda for the
Jupiter notebook I just love the
interface and all the tools that
Anaconda brings so we got our import
numpy as in P for our numpy number array
we have our pandas PD we're going to
bring in Seaborn to help us with the
graphs as SNS so many really nice Tools
in both Seabourn and matplot library and
we'll do our matplot library.pi plot as
PLT and then of course we want to let it
know to do it in line and let's go and
just run that so it's all set up
and we're just going to call our data
data
creative today equals PD and this
happens to be in a CSV file
so we'll use a PD dot read underscore
CSV and I happen to name the file or
renamed it data for P2 dot CSV you can
of course write in the comments below
the YouTube and request for the data set
itself or go to the simply learn website
and we'll be happy to supply that for
you
and let's just open up the data before
we go any further and let's just see
what it looks like in a spreadsheet
so when I pop it open in a local
spreadsheet and this is just a CSV file
comma separated variables we have an ID
so I guess the categorizes for reference
or what id which test was done the
diagnosis M for malignant B for B9 so
there's two different options on there
and that's what we're going to try to
predict is the m and b and test it and
then we have like the radius mean or
average the texture average perimeter
mean area mean smoothness I don't know
about you but unless you're a doctor in
the field most of stuff I mean you can
guess what concave means just by the
term concave if I really wouldn't know
what that means and the measurements are
taking so they have all kinds of stuff
like how smooth it is the Symmetry and
these are all float values we just page
through them real quick and you'll see
there's I believe 36 if I remember
correctly in this one
so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at the different growth the
tumorous growth
so back in our data and I put this in
the same folder as a code so I saved
this code in that folder obviously if
you have it in a different location you
want to put the full path in there and
we'll just do uh pandas
first five lines of data with the
data.head
and we run that we can see that we have
pretty much what we just looked at we
have an ID we have a diagnosis
if we go all the way across you'll see
all the different columns coming across
displayed nicely for our data
and while we're exploring the data our
Seaborn which we referenced as S and S
makes it very easy to go in here and do
a joint plot you'll notice a very
similar to because it is sitting on top
of the plot Library so the joint plot
does a lot of work for us and we're just
going to look at the first two columns
that we're interested in the radius mean
and the texture mean we'll just look at
those two columns
and data equals data so that tells it
which two columns we're plotting and
then we're going to use the data that we
pulled in let's just run that
and it generates a really nice graph on
here
and there's all kinds of cool things on
this graph to look at I mean we have the
texture mean and the radius mean
obviously the axes you can also see
and one of the cool things on here is
you can also see the histogram they show
that for the radius mean whereas the
most commonest radius mean come up and
where the most common texture is that's
when we're looking at the tech the on
each growth that's average texture and
on each radius it's average radius on
there it gets a little confusing because
we're talking about the individual
objects average and then we can also
look over here and see the the histogram
showing us the median or how common each
measurement is and that's only two
columns so let's dig a little deeper
into Seabourn they also have a heat map
and if you're not familiar with heat
Maps a heat map just means it's in color
that's all that means heat map I guess
the original ones were plotting heat
density on something and so ever since
then it's just called a heat map and
we're going to take our data and get our
corresponding numbers to put that into
the heat map and that's simply data dot
c-o-r-r for that that's a pandas
expression let's remember we're working
in a pandas data frame so that's one of
the Cool Tools in pandas for our data
and this is pull that information into a
heat map and see what that looks like
and you'll see that we're now looking at
all the different features we have our
ID we have our texture we have our area
our compactness concave points and if
you look down the middle of this chart
diagonal going from the upper left to
bottom right
it's all white that's because when you
compare texture to texture they're
identical so they're a hundred percent
or in this case a perfect one in their
correspondence and you'll see that when
you look at say area or right below it
it has almost a black on there when you
compare it to texture so these have
almost no corresponding data They Don't
Really form a linear graph or something
that you can look at and say how
connected they are they're very
scattered data this is really just a
really nice craft to get a quick look at
your data doesn't so much change what
you do but it changes verifying so when
you get an answer or something like that
or you start looking at some of these
individual pieces you might go hey that
doesn't match according to showing our
heat map this should not correlate with
each other and if it is you're going to
have to start asking well why what's
going on what else is coming in there
but it does show some really cool
information on here I mean we can see
from the ID
there's no real one feature that just
says if you go across the top line that
lights up there's no one feature that
says hey if the area is a certain size
then it's going to be B9 or malignant it
says there's some that sort of add up
and that's a big hint in the data that
we're trying to ID this whether it's
malignant or B9 that's a big hint to us
as data scientists to go okay we can't
solve this with any one feature it's
going to be something that includes all
the features or many of the different
features to come up with the solution
for it and while we're exploring the
data let's explore one more area and
let's look at data dot is null we want
to check for null values in our data if
you remember from earlier in this
tutorial we did it a little differently
where we added stuff up and sum them up
you can actually with pandas do it
really quickly data.is null and Summit
and it's going to go across all the
columns so when I run this
you're going to see all the columns come
up with no no data
so we've just just to rehash these last
few steps
we've done a lot of exploration we have
looked at the first two columns
and seeing how they plot with the
Seaborn with a joint plot which shows
both the histogram and the data plotted
on the X Y coordinates and obviously you
can do that more in detail
with different columns and see how they
plot together
and then we took and did the Seabourn
heat map the
sns.heat map of the data and you can see
right here where it did a nice job
showing us some bright spots where stuff
correlates with each other and forms a
very nice combination or points of
scattering points and you can also see
areas that don't
and then finally we went ahead and
checked the data is the data null value
do we have any missing data in there
very important step because it'll crash
later on
if you forget to do this step it will
remind you when you get that nice error
code that says null values okay so not a
big deal if you miss it but it's no fun
having to go back when you're when
you're in a huge process and you've
missed this step and now you're 10 steps
later and you gotta go remember where
you were pulling the data in
so we need to go ahead and pull out our
X and our y so we just put that down
here and we'll set the x equal to and
there's a lot of different options here
certainly we could do x equals all the
columns except for the first two because
if you remember the first two is the ID
in the diagnosis so that certainly would
be an option
but we're going to do is we're actually
going to focus on the worst the worst
radius the worst texture parameter area
smoothness compactness and so on one of
the reasons to start dividing your data
up when you're looking at this
information
is sometimes the data will be the same
data coming in so if I have two
measurements coming into my model it
might overweigh them it might overpower
the other measurements because it's
measure it's basically taking that
information in twice that's a little bit
past the scope of this tutorial I want
you to take away from this though is
that we are dividing the data up into
pieces and our team in the back went
ahead and said hey let's just look at
the worst so I'm going to create a an
array and you'll see this array radius
worst texture worst perimeter worst
we've just taken the worst of the worst
and I'm just going to put that in my X
so this x is still a panda's data frame
but it's just those columns and our y if
you remember correctly is going to be
oops hold on one second it's not X it's
data there we go so x equals data and
then it's a list of the different
columns the worst of the worst and if
we're going to take that then we have to
have our answer for our Y for the stuff
we know and if you remember correctly
we're just going to be looking at
the diagnosis that's all we care about
is what is it diagnosed is it B9 or
malignant and since it's a single column
we can just do diagnosis oh I forgot to
put the brackets or the there we go okay
so it's just diagnosis on there and we
can also real quickly do like x dot head
if you want to see what that looks like
and Y dot head
and run this
and you'll see it only does the last one
I forgot about that if you don't do
print you can see that the the Y dot
head is just Mmm because the first ones
are all malignant and if I run this the
x dot head is just the first five values
of radius worst texture worst parameter
worst area worst and so on
I'll go ahead and take that out
so moving down to the next step we've
built our two data sets our answer and
then the features we want to look at
in data science it's very important to
test your model
so we do that by splitting the data
and from sklearn model selection we're
going to import train test split so
we're going to split it into two groups
there are so many ways to do this I
noticed in one of the more modern ways
to actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups so you have
all kinds and there's reasons for that
which is past the scope of this and for
this particular example is it necessary
for this we're just going to split it
into two groups one to train our data
and one to test our data and the sklearn
dot model selection we have train test
split you could write your own quick
code to do this we just randomly divide
the data up into two groups but they do
it for us nicely
and we actually can almost we can
actually do it in one statement with
this where we're going to generate four
variables capital x train capital X test
so we have our training data we're going
to use to fit the model and then we need
something to test it and then we have
our y train so we're going to trade the
answer and then we have our test so this
is the stuff we want to see how good it
did on our model
and we'll go ahead and take our train
test split that we just imported
and we're going to do X and our y our
two different data that's going in for
our split
and then the guys in the back came up
and wanted us to go ahead and use a test
size equals 0.3 that's test underscore
size random State it's always nice to
kind of switch a random State around but
not that important what this means is
that the test size is we're going to
take 30 percent of the data and we're
going to put that into our test
variables our y test and our X test and
we're going to do 70 into the X train
and the Y train so we're going to use 70
of the data to train our model and
thirty percent to test it let's go ahead
and run that and load those up so now we
have all our stuff split up and all our
data ready to go and now we get to the
actual Logistics part we're actually
going to do our create our model so
let's go ahead and bring that in from
sklearn we're going to bring in our
linear model and we're going to import
logistic regression that's the actual
model we're using and this will call it
log model
it's the real model and let's just set
this equal to our logistic regression
that we just imported
so now we have a variable log model set
to that class for us to use
and with most the models in the sklearn
we just need to go ahead and fix it fit
and do a fit on there and we use our X
train that we separated out with our y
train now let's go ahead and run this so
once we've run this we'll have a model
that fits this data that 70 percent of
our training data
uh and of course the princess out that
tells us all the different variables
that you can set on there there's a lot
of different choices you can make but
for word deal we're just going to let
all the defaults sit we don't really
need to mess with those on this
particular example and there's nothing
in here that really stands out as super
important until you start fine-tuning it
but for what we're doing the basics will
work just fine and then let's we need to
go ahead and test out our model is it
working so let's create a variable y
predict and this is going to be equal to
our log model
and we want to do a predict again very
standard format for the SK learn library
is taking your model and doing a predict
on it and we're going to test why
predict against the Y test so we want to
know what the model thinks it's going to
be that's what our y predict is and with
that we want the capital x x test so we
have our train set and our test set and
now we're going to do our y predict and
let's go ahead and run that
and if we print
y predict
let me go ahead and run that you'll see
it comes up and it presents and I prints
a nice array of B and M for B9 and
malignant
for all the different test data we put
in there
so it does pretty good we're not sure
exactly how good it does but we can see
that it actually works and it's
functional was very easy to create
you'll always discover with our data
science that as you explore this you
spend a significant amount of time
prepping your data and making sure your
data coming in is good there's a saying
good data in good answers out bad data
in bad answers out that's only half the
thing that's only half of it selecting
your models becomes the next part as far
as how good your models are and then of
course fine-tuning it depending on what
model you're using
so we come in here we want to know how
good this came out so we have our y
predict here log model dot predict X
test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the
sklearn.metrix we're going to import
classification report and that just
reports how good our model is doing and
then we're going to feed it the model
data and let's just print this out
and we'll take our classification report
and we're going to put into there
our test our actual data so this is what
we actually know is true and our
prediction what our model predicted for
that date on the test side
let's run that and see what that does
so we pull that up you'll see that we
have a Precision for B9 and malignant B
and M
and we have a Precision of 93 and 91 a
total of 92 so it's kind of the average
between these two 92 there's all kinds
of different information on here your F1
score
your recall your support coming through
on this
and for this I'll go ahead and just flip
back to our slides that they put
together for describing it and so here
we're going to look at the Precision
using the classification report and you
see this is the same printout I had up
above some of my numbers might be
different because it does randomly pick
out which data we're using so this model
is able to predict the type of tumor
with 91 percent accuracy so we look back
here let's we will see where we have B9
and malignant it actually is 92 coming
up here but we're looking at about a 92
91 percent precision and remember I
reminded you about domains and we're
talking about the domain of a medical
domain with a very catastrophic outcome
you know at 91 or 92 percent Precision
you're still going to go in there and
have somebody do a biopsy on it very
different than if you're investing money
and there's a 92 percent chance you're
going to earn 10 percent and eight
percent chance you're going to lose
eight percent you're probably going to
bet the money because at that odds it's
pretty good that you'll make some money
and in the long run you do that in
enough you definitely will make money
and also with this domain I've actually
seen them use this to identify different
forms of cancer that's one of the things
that they're starting to use these
models for because then it helps the
doctor know what to investigate so that
wraps up this section we're finally
we're going to go in there and let's
discuss the answer to the quiz asked in
machine learning tutorial part one
can you tell what's happening in the
following cases grouping documents into
different categories based on the topic
and content of each document this is an
example of clustering where k-means
clustering can be used to group the
documents by topics using bag of words
approach so if you've gotten in there
that you're looking for clustering and
hopefully you had at least one or two
examples like k-means that are used for
clustering different things then give
yourself a two thumbs up B identifying
handwritten digits and images correctly
this is an example of classification the
traditional approach to solving this
would be to extract digit dependent
features like curvature of different
digits Etc and then use a classifier
like sbm to distinguish between images
again if you got the fact that it's a
classification example give yourself a
thumb up and if you're able to go hey
let's use svm or another model for this
give yourself those two thumbs up on it
C behavior of a website indicating that
the site is not working as designed this
is an example of anomaly detection in
this case the algorithm learns what is
normal and what is not normal usually by
observing the logs or the website give
yourself a thumbs up if you got that one
and just for a bonus can you think of
another example of anomaly detection one
of the ones I use it for my own business
is detecting anomalies in stock markets
stock markets are very fickled and they
behave very radical so finding those
erratic areas and then finding ways to
track down why they're erratic was
something released in social media was
something released you can see we're
knowing where that anomaly is can help
you to figure out what the answer is to
it in another area D predicting salary
of an individual based on his or her
years of experience this is an example
of regression this problem can be
mathematically defined as a function
between independent years of experience
and dependent variables salary of an
individual
and if you guess that this was a
regression model give yourself a thumbs
up and if you're able to remember that
it is between independent and dependent
variables and that terms give yourself
two thumbs up
summary so to wrap it up we went over
what is K means and we went through also
the chart of choosing your elbow method
and assigning a random centroid to the
Clusters Computing the distance and then
going in there and figuring out what the
minimum centroids is and Computing the
distance and going through that Loop
until it gets the perfect centroid and
we looked into the elbow method to
choose K based on running our clusters
across a number of variables and finding
the best location for that we did a nice
example of clustering cars with k-means
even though we only looked at the first
two columns to make it simple and easy
to graph we can easily extrapolate that
and look at all the different columns
and see how they all fit together and we
looked at what is a logistic regression
we discussed the sigmoid function what
is logistic regression and then we went
into an example of classifying tumors
with Logistics
I hope you enjoyed part two of machine
learning thank you for joining us today
for more information visit
www.simplylearn.com again my name is
Richard kirschner a member of the simply
learned team get certified get ahead if
you have any questions or comments feel
free to write those down below the
YouTube video or visit us at
simplylearn.com we'll be happy to supply
you with the data sets or other
information as requested
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
today we're going to cover the K nearest
neighbors that referred to as k n n and
KN is really a fundamental place to
start in the machine learning it's the
basis of a lot of other things and just
the logic behind it is easy to
understand and Incorporated in other
forms of machine learning so today
what's in it for you why do we need k n
n what is k n how do we choose the
factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model Builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output is
that a dog a little kid looking over
there and watching the black cat cross
their path no dear you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although I do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate their
sharpness of the claws how sharp are
their claws and we can evaluate the
length of the ears and we can usually
sort out cats from dogs based on even
those two characteristics now tell me if
it is a cat or a dog an odd question
usually little kids no cats and dogs by
now unless you live a place where
there's not many cats or dogs so if we
look at the sharpness of the claws the
length of the ears and we can see that
the cat has a smaller ears and sharper
claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat sharp claws length of ears and goes
in the cat group because KNN is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using kn n classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is KNN what is the k
n algorithm K nearest neighbors is what
that stands for it's one of the simplest
supervised machine learning algorithms
mostly used for classification so we
want to know is this a dog or is not a
dog is it a cat or not a cat it
classifies a data point based on how its
neighbors are classified KNN stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
we go from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride K and K N is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals
five we'll talk about K in just a minute
a data point is classified by the
majority of votes from its five nearest
neighbors here the unknown point would
be classified as red since four out of
five neighbors are red so how do we
choose K how do we know k equals five I
mean that's was the value we put in
there so we're going to talk about it
how do we choose the factor K and N
algorithm is based on feature similarity
choosing the right value of K is a
process called parameter tuning and is
important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to 3 we're going to look at
the three nearest neighbors we're going
to say this is a square and if we put k
equals to 7 we classify as a triangle
depending on what the other data is
around and you can see as the K changes
depending on where that point is that
drastically changes your answer and we
jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of K you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these facts
factors that's the face you get he's
like oh my gosh you say choose the right
K did I set it right my values in
whatever machine learning tool you're
looking at so that you don't have a huge
bias in One Direction or the other and
in terms of knnn the number of K if you
choose it too low the bias is based on
it's just too noises it's it's right
next to a couple things and it's going
to pick those things and you might get a
skewed answer and if your K is too big
then it's going to take forever to
process so you're going to run into
processing issues and resource issues so
what we do the most common use and
there's other options for choosing K is
to use the square root of n so it is a
total number of values you have you take
the square root of it in most cases you
also if it's an even number so if you're
using uh like in this case squares and
triangles if it's even you want to make
your K value odd that helps it select
better so in other words you're not
going to have a balance between two
different factors that are equal so
usually take the square root of n and if
it's even you add one to it or subtract
one from it and that's where you get the
K value from that is the most common use
and it's pretty solid it works very well
when do we use knnn we can use K N when
data is labeled so you need a label on
it we know we have a group of pictures
with dogs dogs cats cats data is Noise
free and so you can see here when we
have a class and we have like
underweight 140 23 Hello Kitty normal
that's pretty confusing we have a high
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and that would cause an issue data
set is small so we're usually working
with smaller data sets where you might
get into a gig of data if it's really
clean it doesn't have a lot of noise
because K N is a lazy learner I.E it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the k n but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knnn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we can see right here we have two
variables you know true false are either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using k n n so
if we have new data coming in this says
57 kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance D equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus B squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're Computing the third Edge
since we we know the X side and the Y
side let's calculate it to understand
clearly so we have our unknown point and
we placed it there in red and we have
our other points where the data is
scattered around the distance D1 is the
square root of 170 minus 167 squared
plus 57 minus 51 squared which is about
6.7 and distance 2 is about 13 and
distance 3 is about 13.4 similarly we
will calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do and it's actually
pretty quick for a computer and it's not
a really complicated Mass you can just
see how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where X1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest name neighbors
now let's calculate the nearest neighbor
at k equals three and we can see the
three closest neighbors put some at
normal and that's pretty self-evident
when you look at this graph it's pretty
easy to say okay what you know we're
just voting normal normal three votes
for normal this is going to be a normal
weight so majority of neighbors are
pointing towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of knnn positive
integer K is specified along with a new
sample we select the K entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in Python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through I
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight eight columns with a
particular attribute and then the ninth
column which is the outcome is whether
they have diabetes as a data scientist
the first thing you should be looking at
is insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes that's why
they're taking it and that could cause
issue in some of the machine learning
packages but for a very basic setup this
works fine for doing the KNN and the
next thing you notice is it didn't take
very much to open it up I can scroll
down to the bottom of the data there's
768. it's pretty much a small data set
you know at 769 I can easily fit this
into my ram on my computer computer I
can look at it I can manipulate it and
it's not going to really tax just a
regular desktop computer you don't even
need an Enterprise version to run a lot
of this so let's start with importing
all the tools we need and before that of
course we need to discuss what IDE I'm
using certainly can use any particular
editor for python but I like to use for
doing very basic visual stuff the
Anaconda which is great for doing demos
with the Jupiter notebook and just a
quick view of the Anaconda Navigator
which is the new release out there which
is really nice you can see under home I
can choose my application we're going to
be using python36 I have a couple
different versions on this particular
machine if I go under environments I can
create a unique environment for each one
which is nice and there's even a little
button there where you can install
different packages so if I click on that
button and open the terminal I can then
use a simple pip install to install
different packages I'm working with
let's go ahead and go back under home
and we're going to launch our notebook
and I've already you know kind of like
the old cooking shows I've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case I'm going to
open up Chrome because that's my default
that I use and since the script is
pre-done you'll see I have a number of
windows open up at the top the one we're
working in and since we're working on
the KNN predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not let's go and put
that title in there and I'm also going
to go up here and click on Cell actually
we want to go ahead and first insert a
cell below and then I'm going to go back
up to the top cell and I'm going to
change the cell type to markdown that
means this is not going to run this
python it's a markdown language so if I
run this first one it comes up in nice
big letters which is kind of nice remind
us what we're working on and by now you
should be familiar with doing all of our
Imports we're going to import the pandas
as PD import numpy is NP pandas is the
pandas data frame and numpy is a number
array very powerful tools to use in here
so we have our Imports so even brought
in our pandas are numpy our two general
python tools and then you can see over
here we have our train test split by now
you should be familiar with splitting
the data we want to split part of it for
training our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies really large numbers
remember in the data we had like number
of pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take and get up to 256. so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between minus one and one and
then the actual tool this is the K
neighbors classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
Matrix our F1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the SK learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
PD and we'll take a look at the data in
Python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually I like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read CSV that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder I just put in the
same folder where my IPython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick Links of the data set
that is a simple python on command Len
for length we might even let's go ahead
and print that we'll go print and if you
do it on its own line links that data
set in the jupyter notebook it'll
automatically print it but when you're
in most of your different setups you
want to do the print in front of there
and then we want to take a look at the
actual data set and since we're in
pandas we can simply do data set head
and again let's go ahead and add the
print in there if you put a bunch of
these in a row you know the data set one
head data set two head it only prints
out the last one so I usually always
like to keep the print statement in
there but because most projects only use
one data frame pandas data frame doing
it this way it doesn't really matter the
other way works just fine and you can
see when we hit the Run button we have
the 768 lines which we knew and we have
our pregnancies it's automatically given
a label on the left remember the head
only shows the first five lines so we
have zero through four and just a quick
look at the data you can see it matches
what we looked at before we have
pregnancy glucose blood pressure sure
all the way to H and then the outcome on
the end and we're going to do a couple
things in this next step we're going to
create a list of columns where we can't
have zero there's no such thing as zero
skin thickness or zero blood pressure
zero glucose any of those you'd be dead
so not a really good Factor if they
don't if they have a zero in there
because they didn't have the data and
we'll take a look at that because we're
going to start replacing that
information with a couple of different
things and let's see what that looks
like so first we create a nice list as
you can see we have the values talked
about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness and this is a nice way when
you're working with columns is to list
the columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
Panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the N A but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column dot
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do a direct there's also that you
look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the Nan num pnan is
what that stands for is none it doesn't
exist so the first thing we're doing
here is we're replacing the zero with a
numpy none there's no data there that's
what that says that's what this is
saying right here so put the zero in and
we're going to play zeros with no data
so if it's a zero that means a person's
well hopefully not dead hope they just
didn't get the data the next thing we
want to do is we're going to create the
mean which is the integer from the data
set from the column dot mean where we
skip in A's we can do that and that is a
pandas command there the skip n a so
we're going to figure out the mean of
that data set and then we're going to
take that data set column and we're
going to replace all the npnan with the
means why did we do that and we could
have actually just taken this step and
gone right down here and just replace 0
and Skip anything where except you could
actually there's a way to skip zeros and
then just replace all the zeros but in
this case we want to go ahead and do it
this way so you can see that we're
switching this to a non-existent value
then we're going to create the mean well
this is the average person so if we
don't know what it is if they did not
get the data and the data is missing one
of the tricks is you replace it with the
average what is the most common data for
that this way you can still use the rest
of those values to do your computation
and it kind of just brings that
particular value of those missing values
out of the equation let's go ahead and
take this and we'll go ahead and run it
doesn't actually do anything so we're
still preparing our data if you want to
see what that looks like we don't have
anything in the first few lines just not
going to show up but we certainly could
look at a row let's do that let's go
into our data set with the printed data
set and let's pick in this case let's
just do glucose and if I run this this
is going to print all the different
glucose levels going down and we
thankfully don't see anything in here
that looks like missing data at least on
the ones shows you can see I skipped a
bunch in the middle because that's what
it does we have too many lines in
Jupiter notebook it'll skip a few and
and go on to the next in a data set let
me go and remove this and we'll just
zero out that and of course before we do
any processing before proceeding any
further we need to split the data set
into our train and testing data that way
we have something to train it with and
something to test it on and you're going
to notice we did a little something here
with the pandas database code there we
go my drawing tool we've added in this
right here off the data set and what
this says is that the first one in
pandas this is from the PD pandas it's
going to say within the data set we want
to look at the eye location and it is
all rows that's what that says so we're
going to keep all the rows but we're
only looking at zero columns 0 To 8.
Remember column nine here it is right up
here we printed it in here as outcome
well that's not part of the training
data that's part of the answer yes
column nine but it's listed as eight
number eight so zero to eight is nine
columns so 8 is the value and when you
see it in here zero this is actually
zero to seven it doesn't include the
last one and then we go down here to Y
which is our answer and we want just the
last one just column eight and you can
do it this way with this particular
notation and then if you remember we
imported the train test split that's
part of the SK learn right there and we
simply put in our X and our y we're
going to do random State equals zero you
don't have to necessarily seed it that's
a seed number I think the default is one
when you seed it I have to look that up
and then the test size test size is 0.2
that simply means we're going to take 20
percent of the data and put it aside so
that we can test it later that's all
that is and again we're going to run it
not very exciting so far we haven't had
any printout other than to look at the
data but that is a lot of this is
prepping this data once you prep it the
actual lines of code are quick and easy
and we're almost there with the actual
running of our k n n we need to go ahead
and do a scale the data if you remember
correctly we're fitting the data in a
standard Taylor which means instead of
the data being from you know five to
three hundred and three in one column
and the next column is one to six we're
going to set that all so that all the
data is between minus one and one that's
what that standard scalar does keeps it
standardized and we only want to fit the
scalar with the training set but we want
to make sure the testing set is the X
test going in is also transformed so
it's processing it the same so here we
go with our standard scalar we're going
to call it SC underscore X for the
scalar and we're going to import the
standard scalar into this variable and
then our X train equals SC underscore x
dot fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the X train variable and then
our X test we're also going to transform
it so we've trained and transformed the
X train and then the X test isn't part
of that training it isn't part of the of
training the Transformer it just gets
transformed that's all it does and again
we're going to run this and if you look
at this we've now now gone through these
steps all three of them we've taken care
of replacing our zeros for key columns
that shouldn't be zero and we replace
that with the means of those columns
that way that they fit right in with our
data models we've come down here we
split the data so now we have our test
data and our training data and then
we've taken and we've scaled the data so
all of our data going in now no we don't
TR we don't train the Y part the Y train
and Y test that never has to be trained
it's only the data going in that's what
we want to train in there then Define
the model using K neighbor's classifier
and fit the train data in the model so
we do all that data prep and you can see
down here we're only going to have a
couple lines of code where we're
actually building our model and training
it that's one of the cool things about
Python and how far we've come it's such
an exciting time to be in machine
learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick link X of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of Y and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot square root let's do
y train there we go that's actually
supposed to be X train before we do this
let's go ahead and do import math and do
math square root length of Y test and
when I run that we get 12.409 I want to
see show you where this number comes
from we're about to use 12 is an even
number so if you know if you're ever
voting on things remember the neighbors
all vote don't want to have an even
number of neighbors voting so we want to
do something odd and let's just take one
away we'll make it 11. let me delete
this out of here that's one of the
reasons I love Jupiter notebook because
you can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
K neighbors classifier and neighbors
equal 11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for
11. we have an odd number of neighbors P
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion Matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion Matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the F1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion Matrix why
test why predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the Y predicted which would be
your title up here we could do let's
just do pred
predicted across the top and actual
going down actual
it's always hard to write in here actual
that means that this column here down
the middle that's the important column
and it means that our prediction said 94
and prediction in the actual agreed on
94 and 32. this number here the 13 and
the 15 those are what was wrong so you
could have like three different if
you're looking at this across three
different variables instead of just two
you'd end up with the third row down
here in the column going down the middle
so in the first case we have the the and
I believe the zero has a 94 people who
don't have diabetes the prediction said
that 13 of those people did have
diabetes and were at high risk and the
32 that had diabetes it had correct but
our prediction said another 15 out of
that 15 it classified as incorrect so
you can see where that classification
comes in and how that works on the
confusion Matrix then we're going to go
ahead and print the F1 score let me just
run that and you see we get a 0.69 in
our F1 score the F1 takes into account
both sides of the balance of false
positives where if we go ahead and just
do the accuracy account and that's what
most people think of is it looks at just
how many we got right out of how many we
got wrong so a lot of people when you're
a data scientist and you're talking to
other data scientists they're going to
ask you what the F1 score the F score is
if you're talking to the general public
or the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the F1 score but the F1 scores more
telling it lets us know that there's
more false positives than we would like
on here but 82 percent not too bad for a
quick flash look at people's different
statistics and running an sklearn and
running the k n n the K nearest neighbor
on it so we have created a model using
KNN which can predict whether a person
will have diabetes or not or the very
least whether they should go get a
checkup and have their glucose checked
regularly or not the print accuracy
score we got the 0.818 was pretty close
to what we got and we can pretty much
round that off and just say we have an
accuracy of 80 percent tells us it is a
pretty fair fit in the model the
principal component analysis we're going
to cover dimensionality reduction
principal component analysis what is it
important PCA terminologies and you'll
see it abbreviated normally as PCA
principal component analysis PCA
properties PCA example and then we'll
pull up some python code in our jupyter
notebook and have some Hands-On demo on
the PCA and how it's used dimensionality
reduction dimensionality reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company bpacs isomax and they have
the item the tire the axle an order ID a
price number and a quantity in order to
predict the future cells we find out
that using correlation analysis that we
just need three attributes therefore we
have reduced the number of attributes
from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number I don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up why dimensionality
reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means less computation or
training time that can be really
important if you're trying a number of
different models and you're rewriting
them over and over again and even if you
have seven gigabytes of data that can
start taking days to go through all
those different models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing our data
set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just one so when you get rid of that
redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data pool we might not send the company
that bought it why would we want to
store two whole extra columns when we
add it into that pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2D
and 3D plots this is my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting you want to be able
to give them a really good clear and
simplified version you want to reduce it
down to something people can take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in postcribing leads
to better human interpretation that kind
of goes with number four what makes data
easy for plotting you have a better
interpretation we're looking at it
principal component analysis so what is
it uh principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the PCA we
reduce the variables we end up with the
reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because if you look at the end result we
have the different colors all lined up
so what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here let's
say you are asked to take a picture of
some Toddlers and you are deciding which
angle would be the best to take the
picture from so if we come up here we
look at this we say okay this is you
know one angle we get the back of a lot
of heads not many faces so we'll do it
from here we might get the one person up
front smiling a lot of the people in the
class are missing so we have a huge
amount off to the right a blank space
Maybe from up here again we have the
back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it and you
say hey that makes sense it's a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data it's not you really can't do it by
what you think is going to be the best
we need to have some kind of
mathematical formula so it's consistent
and so it makes sense in the back end
one of the projects I worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data set it's
probably one of the most common ones out
there where they have the flower
and they're measuring the stamina in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the width to length ratio we
can divide the width by the length and
you get a single number where you had
two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my Iris
petal example
when we look at the similarity in PCA we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there we can see
these data points based on in this case
just two variables now keep in mind
we're usually talking about 36 40
variables almost all of your business
models usually have about 26 to 27
different variables they're looking at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the X Y
we look down at it and we have our
second idea PC2 and again we're looking
at the x i this X Y this time from a
different direction here for our E's we
can consider that we get two principal
components namely pc1 and PC2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if we look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in PC2 and that's what they're
coming up with what is going to give us
the best look for these data points when
we combine them and we're looking at
them from just a single angle
whereas in PC2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc1 and not the
PC2 as the data points are more spaced
now obviously the back end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable
this gives you an idea though that when
we're talking about this we're talking
about the perspective which would help
in understanding how PCA analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under a PCA
and important terminology is our views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a PCA presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
Dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set and we talked about you'll hear
features Dimensions
um and I was talking about features
there's usually when you're running a
business you're talking 25 26 27
different features minimal and then you
have the principal component new
variables that are constructed as linear
combinations or mixtures of the initial
variables
principle component is very important
it's a combination if you remember my
flower example it would be the width
over the length of the petal as opposed
to putting both width and length in you
just put in the ratio instead which is a
single number versus two separate
numbers projections
the perpendicular distance between the
principal component and the data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those Point how those points fall
onto the line important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense you're not
going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features you're trying to reduce them so
that's just kind of goofy but it is
important to remember that people will
throw weird code out there and just
randomly do stuff instead of really
thinking it through principle components
are orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line when we
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line same
thing with PC2 and we want to make sure
that pc1 does not equal PC2 we don't
want to have the same two principal
points when we do two points
the priority of principal components
decreases as their numbers increase
this is important to understand if
you're going to create
uh one principle
component everything is summarized into
that one component as we go to two
components the priority how much it
holds value decreases as we go down so
if you have five different points each
one of those points is going to have
less value than just the one point which
has everything summarized in it how PCA
works
I said there was more in the back end we
talk about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
Works PCA performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our I Gene
vectors and I Gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the I Gene Vector is like a
translation if we're moving the data
from x equals one to x equals two or
whatever altering it and the I Gene
value is the final value that we
generate
when we talk about standardization the
main aim of this step is to standardize
the range of the attributes so that each
one of them lie within similar
boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have Z equals
the variable values minus the mean over
the standard deviation
The covariance Matrix computation
covariance Matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
The covariance Matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
attribute values the variance is denoted
by VAR and the covariance is denoted by
Cove
on the right we can see the covariance
Matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a Hands-On look at the code
we'll do a display of this so you can
see what we're talking about and what
that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance table for more than two
attributes in a multi-dimensional data
set
this is what I was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature two features we're usually
looking at 25 30 features going on
and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different variables
covariance Matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not
and then we have the Aging values and
the Aging vectors
iodine values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value that are
extracted from the covariance table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables which further lead to
the construction of the principal
components
iodine vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation I Gene
values are the scalars or the magnitude
of the I Gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change the vector B to the B Prime as
denoted on the chart and so we have like
multiple variables how do we calculate
that new variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply a matrix that has
hygiene vectors of the components that
we decide to keep as the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps this becomes really
important as we start looking at the
back end of this and we'll do this in
the demo but one of the more important
steps to understand
and so we have the PCA example consider
Matrix X within rows or observations and
K columns or variables now for this
Matrix we would construct a variable
space with as many dimensions as the
variable
before our Simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the Matrix X
is placed in the K dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principle component is a line
that best accounts for the shape of the
point swarm it represents the maximal
variance Direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set thus a second
principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
PC2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means uh inside our python
scripting
I'm going to use the Anaconda Navigator
and I will be in Python 3.6 for this
example I believe there's even like a
3.9 out
I tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models I use especially with the
neural networks are stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our Jupiter I'm in
Chrome and we go ahead and create a new
python 3.
and for ease of use uh our team in the
back was nice enough to put this
together for me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries the first thing I like to do
whenever I'm looking at any new setup uh
well you know what Let's do let's do the
libraries first we're going to do our
basic libraries which is matplot Library
uh the PLT from the matplot library
pandas our data frame PD numpy our
numbers array NP Seaborn for graphing
SNS that goes with the plot that
actually sits on matplot Library so the
Seaborn sits on there
and then we have our Amber sign because
we're in Jupiter notebook matplot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that but I put
it in there either anyway just because
I'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
and in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set and one of the
reasons the cancer data set is it has
like 36 35 different features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
then we'll go ahead and run this and
look at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set is we have
our data we have our Target our frame
Target names description feature names
and file name
so what we're looking for in all this
is let's take a look at the description
let's go in here and pull up the
description on here
I'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our PCA setup what's important is you
start looking at what the different
attributes are what they mean if you
were in the medical field you'd want to
note all these different things whether
what they're measuring where it's coming
from
you can actually see the actual
different uh measurements are taking
no missing attributes
let me page all the way to the bottom
and you're going to have your data in
this case our Target
and if you dig deep enough to the Target
let's actually do this let's go ahead
and print Target names
real quick here I always like to to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
uh
uh Target
names
run that
and so the target name is is it
malignant or is it B9 so in other words
is this uh dangerous growth or is it
something we don't have to worry about
that's the bottom line with the cancer
in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data and you know what let me go up a
just a notch here for easy of reading
it's hard to get that just right I guess
I'll have to do uh so let's go ahead and
look at our data uh our we're going to
use our pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data columns equals cancer feature
equals feature names so remember up here
we already loaded the the names up of
our of the features in there what is
going to come out of this let me just
see if we can get to that
it's at the top of Target names
um that's just this list of names here
in the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head and you can see
here we have the mean radius the mean
texture mean perimeter
I don't know about you this is a
wonderful data set if you're playing
with it because like many of the data
that most of the data that comes in half
the time we don't even know what we're
looking at we're just handed a bunch of
stuff as a data scientist going what the
heck is this and so this is a good place
to start because this has a number of
different features in there we have no
idea what these feature means or where
they come from we want to just look at
the data and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
PCA side of it as we've noticed before
it's difficult to visualize High
dimensional data we can use PCA to find
the first two principal components and
visualize the data this new
two-dimensional space with a single
scatter plot before we do this we need
to go ahead and scale our data
now
I haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time I almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here in
neural networks that is so important
with PCA visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the PCA but just in
case it's always good to scale it
and then we're going to take our PCA
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with scikit-learn we
instantiate a PCA object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to keep when creating
the PCA object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead I'm
going to run this code
uh so the code for this
is from sklearn decomposition import PCA
PCA equals PCA and components equals two
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
I would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else if you're showing
this to the shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
uh and then the PCA fit we're going to
is going to take the scaled data that we
generated up here and then you can see
we've created our PCA model with in
components equals two
now whenever I use a new tool
I like to go in there and actually see
what I'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the PCA
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different setups you have on there
probably the biggest one to look at
would be well the biggest one is your
components how many components do you
want which you have to put in there
pretty much and then you also might look
at the SVD solver it's on auto right now
but you can override that and do
different things with it it does a
pretty good job as it is
and if we
go down all the way down to
um
there we go to our methods
if you notice we have fit we have fit
transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction it's used to
look at the data again we're in the
describe setup we're fitting the data
we're taking a look at it we've already
looked at our minimum maximum we've
already looked at what's in each quarter
we've done a full description of the
data this is part of describing the data
that's the biggest thing I take away
when I come zooming in here and of
course they have examples of it down
here if you forget
um and the biggest one of course is the
number of components and then uh I mean
the rest you can play with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full randomize there's different things
it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to PCA
transform scaled data
uh so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us uh what's going on here
we've taken 30 features I think I said
36 or something like that but it's 30.
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from we still have 569 data sets I mean
data rows not data sets we still have
569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two features
so let's go ahead and plot these and
take a look and see what's going on
and uh
we're just going to use our PLT figure
we'll set the figure size on here here's
our scatter plot xpca X underscore PCA
of one these are two different
perceptions we're using uh and then
you'll see right here C for color cancer
equals Target and so remember we have
zero we have one
and if I remember correctly zero was
malignant one was B9 uh so everything in
the zero column is going to be one color
and the other color is going to be one
and then we're going to use the plasma
map just kind of telling you what color
it is add some labels first principal
component second principle component
we'll go and run this
and you can see here instead of having a
chart one of those heat maps with 30
different columns in it we can look at
this and say hey this one actually did a
pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when I'm looking at
this that I notice is first
we have a very clear area or it's
clumped together
where it's going to be benign and we
have a huge area it's still clumped
together more spread out where it's
going to be malignant or I think I have
that backwards and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something in
this particular case cancer we would try
to separate I would be exploring how to
separate this middle group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps and we're not going
to have a clear result on it just
because those are the people you want to
go in there and have extra tests or
treat it differently versus going in and
saying just cutting into the can into
the cancers that the body absorbs it and
it dissipates versus uh actively going
in there removing it testing it going
through chemo and all the different
things that's a big difference you know
as far as what's going to happen here in
that middle line where the overlap is
going to be huge that's domain specific
uh going back to the data we can see
here uh clearly by using these two
components we can easily separate these
two classes so the next step is what
does that mean interpreting the
components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes a cost of
not being able to easily understand what
these components represent
I don't know a principle component one
looks represents or second principle the
components correspond to combinations of
original features the components
themselves are stored as an attribute of
the filtered PCA object and so we talk
look at that we can go ahead and do look
at the PCA components this is in our
model we built we've trained it we can
run that and you can see here's the
actual components it's the two
components have each have their own
array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores are using and these
actually give weight to what features
are doing what
so in this numpy Matrix array each row
represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features
what's really neat about this is we can
now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing what this means and so
let me go ahead and just put this down
up there to get it down here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our DF comp data
frame and we do our PCA components
and I want you to notice how easy this
is uh we're going to set our columns
equal to cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's neat about a data frame is when
we get to Seabourn it will pull that
data frame apart in and set it up for us
when we want and so we're just going to
do the CIA the Seabourn heat map of our
data frame composition and we'll use a
plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little color graph
here you can see we have the mean radius
and all the different features along the
bottom on the right we have a scale so
we can see we have the dark colors all
the way to the really light colors which
are what's really shining there this is
like the primary stuff we want to look
at
so this heat map in the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here and we might
notice that the mean radius look how how
on the bottom of the map it is
um on some of this uh so you have some
interesting correlations here that
change the variations on that and what
means what this is more when you get to
uh postscribe you can also use this to
try to guess as what these things mean
what you want to change to get a better
result
regularization in machine learning
so our agenda on this one is fitting the
data understanding linear regression
bias and variance what is overfitting
what is underfitting and those are like
the biggest things right now in data
sciences overfitting and underfitting
what does that mean and what is
regulization and then we'll do a quick
Hands-On demo to take a look at this
so fitting the data let's start with
fitting the data and we talk about what
is data fitting it's a process of
plotting a series of data points and
drawing the best fit line to understand
the relationship between the variables
and this is what we called Data fitting
and you can see here we have a couple of
lines we've drawn on this graph we're
going to go a little deeper on there so
we might have in this case just a two
Dimensions we have an efficiency of the
car and we have the distance traveled in
one thousand kilometers
and so what is data fitting well it's a
linear relationship and a linear
relationship very specifically linear
means line uh the line used to represent
the relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points and the
variables have a linear relationship
linear regression
so let's start with uh how linear
regression Works a linear regression
finds a line that best fits the data
point and gives a relationship between
the two variables
and so you can see here we have the
efficiency of the car versus the
distance traveled and you can see this
nice straight line drawn through there
and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line it now becomes a
plane
it gets a little more complicated with
multiple variables but they all come
down to this linear kind of drawing a
line through your data and finding what
fits the the data the best
and so we can consider an example let's
say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the cells of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream and we're looking at how
warm it is outside which would hopefully
draw a lot of people into the ice cream
store
and suppose we have two lines we're
going to draw L1 and L2 and we're going
to kind of guess which one we think is
the best fit
and which claimed to describe the
relationship between the variables
and so first we find the square of the
distance between the line L1 and each
data point and at them all and find the
mean distance
and I want you to think about that when
we
Square something if it's a negative or
positive number it no longer matters
because a minus 2 squared is 4 2 squared
is 4. so we're removing what side of the
line it's on and we're just looking for
the error in this case the mean distance
of each of the little dotted lines you
see here
this way of calculating the square of
the distance adding them and then taking
the mean is called mean square error or
loss function and we talk about loss how
far off are we that's what we're really
talking about what did we miss and we
have a positive distance and a negative
distance and of course when we Square it
it is neither it just becomes a positive
error
and so we take the mean
square error and a lot of times you'll
see it referred to as MSE if I look into
code and I'm going through my python
code and I see MSE I know that's a mean
squared error and we take all the dotted
lines and we calculated this error and
we add them all together and then we
average it or find the means
and in this case they ran a demo on this
and it was a
1127.27 for our L1 line
now we find the loss function for line
L2 in a similar fashion and we get the
mean square error to be 6397.
and is computed the same way so maybe
you put this line just way outside the
data range and this is the error you get
by analyzing our results we find that
the loss function or the mean square
error is less for L1 than L2 hence L1 is
the best fit line
this process describes a lot of machine
learning processes we're going to keep
guessing and get as close as we can to
find the right answer we have to have
some way to invite to calculate this and
figure out which one's the best and the
mean square error is one of the better
fits to doing for doing this and most
commonly used
we really want to talk about bias and
variance very important terms to know in
machine learning and with linear
regression
so bias bias occurs when an algorithm
has limited flexibility to learn from
data
variance defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific sets of data
let's start with bias and variance you
can see here we have the two different
setups
bias you can think is very generalized
where variance is very specific
uh and so we talk about bias such models
pay very little attention to the
training data and oversimplify the model
therefore the validation error or
prediction error and training error
follow similar trends
and uh with bias if you oversimplify it
so much you're going to miss your local
uh if if you have like a really good fit
you're going to miss it you're you're
going to just kind of guess what the
average is and that's what your answer
is going to be
with variants a model with a high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not generalize
therefore the validation error or
prediction error are far apart from each
other
such models always lead to a high error
on training and test data as a bias does
where variants such models usually
perform very well on training data but
have high error rates on test data and I
want you to think about this
um when we're talking about a bias the
error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of getting
an average we're not really fitting it
close
with variants we're fitting it so close
that the test data does really good it's
going to nail it every time if you're
doing categorical testing that's a car
that's a truck that's a bicycle
but with variants suddenly a
truck has to have certain features and
it may have to be red because you had so
many red pictures so if it has if it's
an 18 wheeler it has to be red if it's
blue then it has to be a bicycle that's
the kind of variance we're talking about
where it picks up on something and it it
cannot get the right answer unless it
gets a very specific data and we see
that so that as you're testing it your
models and you programmed it you got to
look for how I trained it what is coming
out and if it's not if it's not looking
good on either bias or if it's not
looking good on the training or on the
test data then you're bias uh then
you're biasing your data if it really
looks good on the training data then
that's going to be your variance you've
overfitted the data and those are very
important things to know when you are
building your models in regression of
any kind or any kind of setup for
predicting
so in dark games if all the data Fawn a
particular pointer this can be
considered as a biased throw and the
player aims for the particular score
for variance if all the darts fall in
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer then this can be
considered as a varied throw and the
player aims for various scores
again the bias sums everything up in one
point kind of averages it together where
the variance really looks for the
individual predictions coming out
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting when we talk about
overfitting it's a scenario where the
machine learning model tries to learn
from the details along with the noise
and the data tries to fit each data
point on the curve you can see that
if you plug in your coordinates you're
just going to get the whatever is fitted
every point on the data stream there's
no average there's no two points that
might have that you know y might have
two different answers because uh if the
wind blows a certain way
um and your efficiency of your car maybe
you have a headwind so your car might
alter how efficient it is as it goes and
so there's going to be this variance on
here and this says no you can't have any
variance what's you know the this is
it's going to be exactly this there
can't be any you can't be the same speed
or the same car and have a slightly
different efficiency
so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the prediction
so you'll get like a really high error
on here
and so uh reasons for overfitting data
used for training is not cleaned and
contains noise garbage values in it you
can spend so much time cleaning your
data and it's so important it's so
important that if you have if you have
some kind of something wrong with the
data coming in it needs to be addressed
whether it's the source of the data
maybe they use in medical different
measuring tools
so you now have to adjust for data that
came in from hospital a versus Hospital
b or even off of machine a and machine B
that's testing something and those those
numbers are coming in wrong
the model has a high variance again wind
is a good example I was talking about
that with the car you may have 100 tests
but because the wind's blowing it's all
over the place
size of training data used is not enough
so a small amount of data is going to
also cause this problem you only have a
few points and you try to plot
everything
the model is too complex this comes up a
lot
we put too many pieces together and how
they interact can't even be tracked and
so you have to go back break it up and
find out actually what correlates and
what doesn't
so what is underfitting a scenario where
machine learning models can neither
learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict or classify a new data point
and you can see here we have our
efficiency of our car and our line drawn
and it's just going to be way off for
both the training and the predicting
data
as a model doesn't fully learn the
patterns it accepts every new data point
during the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern uh we just kind of accept
everything
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage and values
again under fitting and overfitting same
issue you got to clean your data
the model has a high bias
we've seen this in all kinds of things
from
the mod the most common is the driving
cars to facial identification or
whatever it is the model itself when
they build it might have a bias towards
one thing and this would be an
underfitted model would have that bias
because it's averaged it out so if you
have five people from India and 10
people from
Africa and 20 people from the U.S you've
created a bias because it's looking at
the 20 people and you only have a small
amount of data to work with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size I was just
talking about
so we have a model with a high bias we
have size of training data used it's not
enough the model is too simple
again this is one straight line through
all the data when it needs has a slight
shift to it for other reasons
what is a good fit
a linear curve that best fits the data
is neither overfitting or underfitting
models but is just right
and of course we have the nice examples
here where we have overfitting lines
going up and down every point is trying
to be include glueded under fitting
the line really is off from where the
data is and then a good fit is got to
get rid of that minimize that error
coming through regularization is taking
the guesswork out you're looking at this
graph and you're going oh which one is
that really over fit or is that under
fit that was pretty hard to tell
so we talk about regularization
regularization techniques are used to
calibrate the linear regression models
and to minimize the adjusted loss
function and prevent overfitting or
underfitting
so what that means in this case we're
going to go ahead and take a look at a
couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which we'll start with a linear model
we'll look at the Ridge regularization
and the lasso regularization
and these models are just like just like
we did the MLP the multi-layered
positron in the SK learn module you
could bring in the ridge module and you
can bring in the lasso module
so when we talk about
um Ridge regression it modifies the
overfitted or underfitted models by
adding the penalty equivalent to the sum
of the squares or the magnitude of the
coefficients
and so we have a cost function equals
loss equals Lambda times the sum of W
squared or the absolute value of w
depending on how you're doing it now
remember we talked about error whether
we either Square it or we absolute value
it because that removes a plus or minus
sign on there and there's reasons to do
it either way but is more common to
square the value
and then we have our uh um in this case
the Lambda is going to be the penalty
for the errors we've thrown in a Greek
character for you just to confuse
everybody and W is the slope of the
curve of the line
so uh we're going to look at this and
we're going to draw a line this is going
to be like a linear regression model so
if you had in sklearn you could import
just a standard linear regression model
uh it would plot this line across
whatever data we're working on
and we look at this and of course we're
just extrapolating this I know they use
some specific data but we don't want to
get into the actual domain and so for a
linear regression line let's consider
two points that are on the line
and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equals zero considering the two points
on the line we'll go ahead and do Lambda
equals one let's head our W is going to
be 1.4
and then the cost function equals 0 plus
1 times 1.4 squared which equals 1.96
so really don't get caught up too much
in the math on this other than
understanding that this is something
that's very easy for a computer to
calculate and if you ever see the loss
plus the plus the Lambda times W the sum
is W squared
and then let's say we have a ridge
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it and we do the
calculations on the data
and for the ridge regression let's
assume a loss equals 0.3 squared plus
0.2 squared equals 0.13 so when they put
all the calculations through of the two
points we end up at the point O 0.62
so we've now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model
and the ridge regression model plots a
little differently than the standard
linear regression model
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and I find this true on a lot of data I
work with I'll end up using either the
ridge regression model or the lasso Mars
regression model for fitting especially
dealing with a lot of like stock markets
daily
setup they come out slightly better you
get a slightly better fit
and so we have our lasso we just talked
about lasso coming in here
and the cost function equals instead of
doing a squared we're just going to do
the absolute value and so if you
remember this is where Ridge regression
changes where's my Ridge regression
model we're squaring the value here
and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here and so the
loss of this of the squared individuals
um and here is our
Lambda symbol again penalty for errors
and W equals the slope of the Curve
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and this is like I said I use these two
models a lot The Ridge and this is
important this is this is kind of the
meat of the matter
how do you know which one to use some of
it is you just do it a bunch of times
and then you figure it out Ridge
regularization is useful when we have
many variables with relatively smaller
data samples the model does not
encourage convergence towards zero but
is likely to make them closer to zero
and prevent overfitting
the Lasser regularization model is
preferred when we are fitting a linear
model with fewer variables
so in the LA in the iris thing we had
four or five variables as we measure the
different Leaf pieces uh you might be
doing the measurements on the cancer
project which has 36 different variables
so as we get down to the IRS with four
variables lasso lar will probably work
pretty good where you might use the
ridge regularization with more model
with if you have something significantly
larger and it encourages the
coefficients of the variables to go
towards zero because of the shape of the
constraint which is an absolute value
and with any of this we want to go ahead
and uh do a demo in last one Ridge
regression so let's take a look and see
what that looks like in our code and
bring up our Jupiter notebook
we'll start with our Imports pandas is
PD import numpy is NP import matplot
Library as PLT SK learn we're going to
import our data sets this is kind of
more generic
we usually just import one data set
instead of all of them but you know
quick and dirty when you're putting some
of these together
we have our sklearn model selection
we're going to import our train test
split for splitting our data up and then
we'll bring in our linear regression
model
and we'll go ahead and run these just to
load them up and then load our data set
we're just talking about that you could
just have imported the load Boston and
Boston data set in there instead of
loading all the data sets
um
and then once we've loaded our data set
we want to go ahead and take a look at
that data and see what we got here
let me just go and pop that down there
and go ahead and run it
and so we've gone ahead and taken our
Boston data we're going to load we put
it into our pandas data frame
um the Boston data set and then the
Boston columns we want to see what's
going on with them we have our Target we
have the house price uh Etc and so our x
equals Boston
um
I location
now remember in pandas the new updates
to pandas they want I location if you're
going to pull data we used to be able to
leave this off but it does something
different it creates a slice versus a
direct setup so make sure using that I
location and the I the output so this is
all just bringing our data together
and we can see here if we do we print
the Boston
Panda's head we can see here all of our
different
aspects we're looking for
and if you're following the X and the Y
the x is everything
except for the last column
where Y is uh all the that's what this
means all the roads except for the last
column and then Y is all the rows but
just the last column so Y is our house
price and the x is the crimesean
industry Chas Knox and all these other
different statistics they've collected
for house sales in Boston
foreign
there we go oops control
ah
so we'll go ahead and split our data X
train and our X test y train y test
equals the train test split which we
imported
and we have our Boston you could have
easily used the X and Y on here as
opposed to Boston I location
and we'll create our test size we're
going to take 25 percent of the data and
put it in as a test
uh and then we'll go ahead and run this
uh
need an extra drink there uh so we have
our training test and then of course the
print the train data shape
I love doing this kind of thing whenever
I'm working with this data print out the
shape make sure your everything looks
correct uh so that we have 127 by 13 and
127 by one 379 by 13 they should match
and if they're if the the data sets are
not quite matching then you know
something's wrong and you're going to
get all those errors I don't know how
many times I've gone through here and
it's dropped a row on one of them and
not on the other or something weird has
happened when I'm cleaning the data this
is pretty straightforward and simple
because the data comes in a nice
pre-package is all clean for you
so let's go ahead and apply apply the
multiple linear regression model
and uh we'll call this lreg l-reg linear
regression and we're going to go ahead
and fit that linear regression model to
X train and Y train
then we'll generate the prediction on
the test set so here's our L reg y
predict
with our X test going into the
prediction
and let's calculate that mean square
error MSE I told you you'll see MSC used
a lot people use it in variables and
things like that it's pretty common and
we get our mean squared error equals
this is just the basic formula we've
already been talking about what's the
difference squared
and then we look for the average of that
we'll go ahead and just run this
and you can see when we get through the
end of this we have our mean square
error on test
we have our total and then we have each
column coming down
and at this point unless you really know
the data you're working with it's not
going to mean a whole lot so if it's in
your domain you might be know what
you're looking at when you see these
kinds of numbers coming up but if it's
not it's just a bunch of numbers and
that's okay
at least that's okay for this demo and
then we're going to go ahead and plot
these so we can see what's going on
and this is always kind of fun it's
always nice to have a nice visual of
what you're looking at and you can see
here
um
when we plot the coefficient scores on
here
and we the guys in the back did a great
job putting some pretty colors together
making it look nice and setting up the
columns
you can see here uh your nox has like
just a huge coefficient
when I look at a table like this I look
for what has very little
um
different coefficients they're not using
a huge change and what has huge changes
and that Flags you for all kinds of
things as you're working with the data
but it depends so much on the domain
you're working with
these are great things though as just a
quick look to see what's going on with
your data and what you're looking for
and of course once we look at this now
our motive is to reduce the coefficient
score so now we want to take these and
and bring them down as much as we can
and for that we're going to work with
the ridge regression on here
so let's start by going and we're going
to import our Ridge model
the red regression from the sklearn
library or the scikit
and we're going to go ahead and train
the model so here's our Ridge R equals
Alpha equals one and I mentioned that
earlier
when I work with the ridge model you'll
see Alpha equals one if you said Alpha
equal to zero that's the standard linear
regression model so you have Alpha
equals one two three four and you
usually use one two or three four in a
standard integer on there and we'll go
ahead and fit the ridge model on there
with our X train and our y train data
generate a prediction for that for our X
test
and we'll calculate the mean square
error
just like we did before this should all
look familiar
and we'll go ahead and print that out
and we'll look at the ridge coefficients
for our data and see what that looks
like
now if I jump up and down between these
two
you'll get a headache
you'll still see the Knox value let's
just look at the knocks because that was
the biggest value it's a minus nine here
and if we go back up here the nox value
is a minus 18. so right off the bat I'm
seeing a huge change
um in the biggest coefficient there
uh so if we're going to do that nice
setup we want to go ahead and just print
it and see what that looks like
here we go and we've set up our plot
subplots and again the team put together
some nice colors so it makes it look
good we're doing an X bar based on the
columns
and our L regress coefficients color
equals color X spine bottom and so forth
uh so just puts together a nice little
graph
and you're starting to see uh one this
when you compare this if you put on the
same graph as this one up here this is
up here -18 this is at minus nine and so
this graph is half the size of the graph
above the same thing with these values
here
they might look the same but they're
actually all almost half the value on
here
and then finally you can do the same
thing for the lasso regression
this would all look very similar as far
as what we worked on before
and I'm just going ahead and print that
on here and run it
and again let's go up to Knox look where
Knox is it's all the way down to zero
and if we look at our next biggest
coefficient it's minus 0.8 and really
here's our 22.73 let me go up here
um
16.7
and we go up here and we look at the
same number 16.69
and so we look at this if I was running
this and doing a working on a project
with this I would look at these numbers
I start with the 16.69 come down here
and compare it to
16.78 69 is better than 7 8 so from the
very beginning we might start looking at
this first model for overall predicting
but there's other factors involved we
might know that uh the Knox value is
Central and the other ones aren't quite
as good and so we might start looking at
just certain setups like what is our
what is this particular coefficient
because it might have a certain meaning
to us and so forth and so you look at
all those different items in there again
but the bottom dollar is our first model
did better than our other two models our
mean square error on the test set
um
continues to come down on this we're
going to cover reinforcement learning
today and what's in it for you we'll
start with why reinforcement learning
we'll look at what is reinforcement
learning
we'll see what the different kinds of
learning strategies are that are being
used today in computer models under
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement
we'll cover important terms specific to
reinforcement learning we'll talk about
markov's decision process and we'll take
a look at a reinforcement learning
example well we'll teach a tic-tac-toe
how to play why reinforcement learning
training a machine learning model
requires a lot of data which might not
always be available to us further the
data provided might not be reliable
learning from a small subset of actions
will not help expand the vast realm of
solutions that may work for a particular
problem
and you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and you'll start
asking questions like if I'm taking one
step forward and left what happens if I
pick up a 50 pound object how does that
change how a robot would walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until it's actually
tried out learning from a small subset
of actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
and we'll see here it learned how to
walk this is going to slow the growth
that technology is capable of machines
need to learn to perform actions by
themselves and not just learn off humans
and you see the objective climb a
mountain a real interesting point here
is that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment and we can
adjust for it and kind of explore and
play with it
most of the models the non-reinforcement
models in computer machine learning
aren't able to do that very well there's
a couple of them that can be used or
integrated to see how it goes is what
we're talking about with reinforcement
learning so what is reinforcement
learning
reinforcement learning is a sub-branch
of machine learning that trains the
model to return an Optimum solution for
a problem by taking a sequence of
decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another
the robot is given a scenario must
arrive at a solution by itself the robot
can take different paths to reach the
destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each path it might even come up
with a unique solution all by itself
and that's really important as we're
looking for Unique Solutions we want the
best solution but you can't find it
unless you try it so we're looking at
our different systems or different model
we have supervised versus unsupervised
versus reinforcement learning and with
the supervised learning that is probably
the most controlled environment we have
a lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks there's all kinds of
things in between decision trees the
data provided is labeled data with
output values specified and this is
important because we talk about
supervised learning you already know the
answer for all this information you
already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so your supervised
learning you already know that the
outcome for tomorrow for you know going
back a week you're looking at stock you
can already have like the graph of what
the next day looks like so you have an
answer for it
and you have labeled data which is used
you have an external supervision and
solves Problems by mapping labeled input
to known output
so very controlled
unsupervised learning and the answer to
provide learning is really interesting
because it's now taking part in many
other models they start with an you can
actually insert an unsupervised learning
model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning as part of the
system which is really cool
data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions used to solve
association with clustering problems
unlabeled data is used no supervision
solves Problems by understanding
patterns and discovering output
uh so you can look at this and you can
think some of these things go with each
other they belong together so it's
looking for what connects in different
ways and there's a lot of different
algorithms that look at this when you
start getting into those there's some
really cool images that come up of what
unsupervised learning is how it can pick
out say the area of a donut one model
will see the area of the donut and the
other one will divide it into three
sections based on its location versus
what's next to it so there's a lot of
stuff that goes in with unsupervised
learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest industry
in today's market in machine learning or
growing Market is very it's very infant
stage as far as how it works and what
it's going to be capable of the machine
learns from its environment using
rewards and errors used to solve reward
based problems no predefined data is
used no supervision follows Trail and
error problem solving approach so again
we have a random at first you start with
a random I try this it works and this is
my reward doesn't work very well maybe
or maybe it doesn't even get you where
you're trying to get it to do and you
get your reward back and then it looks
at that and says well let's try
something else and it starts to play
with these different things finding the
best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement model
and this has become pretty standardized
over the last few years so these are
really good to know we have the agent
agent is the model that is being trained
via reinforcement learning so this is
your actual entity that has however
you're doing it with using a neural
network or a
Q table or whatever combination thereof
this is the actual agent that you're
using this is the model
and you have your environment the
training situation that the model must
optimize to is called its environment
and you can see here I guess we have a
robot who's trying to get a chest full
of gyms or whatever and that's the
output and then you have your action
this is all possible steps that can be
taken by the model and it picks one
action and you can see here that's
picked three different routes to get to
the chest of diamonds and gems
we have a state the current position
condition returned by the model
and you could look at this if you're
playing like a video game this is the
screen you're looking at so when you go
back here the environment is a whole
game board so if you're playing one of
those Mobius games
you might have the whole game board
going on but then you have your current
position where are you on that game
board what's around that what's around
you if you were talking about a robot
the environment might be moving around
the yard where it is in the yard and
what it can see what input it has in
that location that would be the current
position condition returned by the model
and then the reward to help the model
move in the right direction it is
rewarded points are given to it to
appraise some kind of action so yeah you
did good or if didn't do as good trying
to maximize the reward and have the best
reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time it acts as
a mapping between action and present
State this is part of the model what is
your action that you're you're going to
take what's the policy you're using to
have an output from your agent one of
the reasons they separate policy as its
own entity
is that you usually have a prediction
of a different options and then the
policy well how am I going to pick the
best based on those predictions I'm
going to guess at different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work
so it's a little tricky but the policy
thing is actually pretty cool how it
works let's go ahead and take a look at
a reinforcement learning example and
just in looking at this we're going to
take a look consider what a dog that we
want to train so the dog would be like
the agent so you have your your puppy or
whatever and then your environment is
going to be the whole house or whatever
it is or where you're training them and
then you have an action we want to teach
the dog to fetch
so action equals fetching and then we
have a little biscuit so we can get the
dog to perform various actions by
offering incentives such as a dog
biscuit as a reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence will follow every
command and might even learn new actions
like begging by itself so yeah you know
so we started off with fetching it goes
oh I get a biscuit for that it tries
something else you get a handshake or
begging or something like that and goes
oh this is also reward based and so it
kind of explores things to find out what
will bring it is biscuit
and that's very much like how reinforced
model goes is it looks for different
rewards how do I find can I try
different things and find a reward that
works
the dog I also will want to run around
and play and explore its environment uh
this quality of models called
exploration so there's a little
Randomness going on in Exploration
it explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process
is a reinforcement learning policy used
to map a current state to an action
where the agent continuously interacts
with the environment to produce new
Solutions and receive rewards and you'll
see here's all of our different
vocabulary we just went over we have a
reward our state our agent our
environment interaction and so even
though the environment kind of contains
everything
that you really when you're actually
writing the program your environment's
going to put out a reward and state that
goes into the agent
uh the agent then looks at this state or
it looks at the reward usually um first
and it says okay I got rewarded for
whatever I just did or it didn't get
rewarded
and then looks at the state and then it
comes back and if you remember from
policy the policy comes in and then we
have a reward the policy is that part
that's connected at the bottom
and so it looks at that policy and it
says hey what's a good action that will
probably be similar to what I did or
sometimes are completely random but
what's a good action that's going to
bring me a different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces as they go
is pretty important in most of the
models today and so a lot of them
actually have templates based on this
you can pull in and start using
um pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works you can
see your environment sends it says hey
this is what the agent did this if
you're a character in a game this
happened and it shoots out a reward in a
state the agent looks at the reward
looks at the new state and then takes a
little guess and says I'm going to try
this action and then that action goes
back into the environment it affects the
environment the environment then changes
depending on what the action was and
then it has a new state and a new reward
that goes back to the agent so in the
diagram shown we need to find the
shortest path between node A and D each
path has a reward associated with it and
the path with a maximum reward is what
we want to choose
the node ABCD denote the nodes to travel
from node A to B is an action reward is
the cost of each path and policy is each
path taken
and you can see here a can go to B
or a can go to C right off the bat or it
can go right to D and if explored all
three of these you would find that a
going to D was a zero reward a going to
C and D would generate a different
reward
or you could go a c b d there's a lot of
options here and so when we start
looking at this diagram you start to
realize
that even though today's reinforced
learning models do really good at
finding an answer they end up trying
almost all the different directions you
see and so they take up a lot of work uh
or a lot of processing time for
reinforcement learning they're right now
in their infant stage and they're really
good at solving simple problems and
we'll take a look at one of those in
just a minute in a tic-tac-toe game but
you can see here once it's gone through
these and it's explored it's going to
find the ACD is the best reward it gets
a full 30 points for it so let's go
ahead and take a look at a reinforcement
learning
demo
in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a tic tac
toe game you'll be playing this game
Against the Machine learning model
and we'll go ahead we're doing it in
Python so let's go ahead and go through
my always not always I actually have a
lot of python tools let's go through
Anaconda which will open up a Jupiter
notebook seems like a lot of steps but
it's worth it to keep all my stuff
separate and it's also has a nice
display when you're in the jupyter
notebook for doing python
so here's our Anaconda Navigator I open
up the notebook which is going to take
me to a web page and I've gone in here
and created a new python folder in this
case I've already done it and enabled it
to change the name to Tic-tac-toe and
then for this example we're going to go
ahead and
import a couple things we're going to
import numpy as NP we'll go ahead and
import pickle numpy of course is our
number array and then pickle is just a
nice way sometimes for
storing different information different
states that we're going to go through on
here
uh and so we're going to create a class
called State we're going to start with
that
and there's a lot of lines of code to
this class that we're going to put in
here don't let that scare you too much
there's not as much here it looks like
there's going to be a lie here but there
really is just a lot of setup going on
in the in our class State and so we have
up here we're going to initialize it
um
we have our board
it's a Tic Tac Toe board so we're only
dealing with nine spots on the board we
have player one player two
is end we'll create a board hash uh
we'll look at that in just a minute
we're just going to store some
information in there symbol of player
equals one
so there's a few things going on as far
as the initialization and then something
simple we're just going to get the hash
of the board we can get the information
from the board on there which is columns
and rows we want to know when a winner
occurs so if you get three in a row
that's what this whole section here is
for let me go ahead and
scroll up a little bit and you can get a
copy of this code if you send a note
over to Simply learn we'll send you over
this particular file and you can play
with it yourself and see how it's put
together I don't want to spend a huge
amount of time on this because this is
just some real General python coding
uh but you can see here we're just going
through all the rows and you add them
together and if it equals three three in
a row the same thing with columns
diagonal so you gotta check the diagonal
that's what all this stuff does here is
it just goes through the different areas
actually let me go ahead and put
um and then it comes down here and we do
our sum and it says true
minus three just says did somebody win
or is it a tie so you got to add up all
the numbers on there anyway just in case
they're all filled up
and next we also need to know available
positions these are ones that don't no
one's ever used before this way when you
try something or the computer tries
something it's not going to give it an
illegal move that's what the available
positions is doing then we want to
update our state
and so you have your position going in
we're just sending in the position that
you just chose and you'll see there's a
little user interface we put in there we
can pick the row and column in there
and again
I mean this is a lot of code uh so
really it's kind of a thing you'd want
to go through and play with a little bit
and just read through it get a copy of
it a great way to understand how this
works and here is a given reward
um so we're going to give a reward
results equals self winner this is one
of the hearts of what's going on here is
we have a result self.winner
so if there's a winner then we have a
result if the result equals one here's
our feedback
uh if it doesn't equal one then it gets
a zero so it only gets a reward in this
particular case if it wins
and that's important to know because
different
systems of reinforced learning
do rewarding a lot differently depending
on what you're trying to do this is a
very simple example with a three by
three board imagine if you're playing a
video game certainly you only have so
many actions but your environment is
huge you have a lot going on in the
environment and suddenly a reward system
like this is going to be just is going
to have to change a little bit it's
going to have to have different rewards
and different setup and there's all
kinds of advanced ways to do that as far
as weighing you add weights to it and so
they can add the weights up depending on
where the reward comes in so it might be
that you actually get a reward in this
case you get the reward at the end of
the game
and I'm spending just a little bit of
time on this this is an important thing
to note but there's different ways to
add up those rewards it might have like
if you take a certain path
um the first reward is going to be
weighed a little bit less than the last
reward because the last reward is
actually winning the game or scoring or
whatever it is so this reward system
gets really complicated on some of the
more advanced setups
in this case though
you can see right here that they give a
a 0.1 and a 0.5 reward
just for getting picking the right value
and something that's actually valid
instead of picking an invalid value so
rewards again that's like key it's huge
how do you feed the rewards back in
um then we have a board reset that's
pretty straightforward it just goes back
and resets the board to the beginning
because it's going to try out all these
different things whilst learning it's
going to do it by trial and error so you
have to keep resetting it and then of
course there's the play we want to go
ahead and play rounds equals 100 depends
on what you want to do on here you can
set this different you obviously set
that to higher level but this is just
going to go through and you'll see in
here that we have player one and player
two
this isn't this is a computer playing
itself uh one of the more powerful ways
to learn to play a game or even learn
something that isn't a game is to have
two of these models
that are basically trying to beat each
other and so they always they keep
finding exploring new things this one
works for this one so this one tries new
things it beats this we've seen this in
chess I think was a big one where they
had the two players in chess with
reinforcement learning uh it was one of
the ways they train one of the top
computer chess playing algorithms
uh so this is just what this is it's
going to choose an action it's going to
try something and the more it try stuff
um the more we're going to record the
hash we actually have a board hash where
the self get the hash set up on here
where it stores all the information
and then once you get to a win one of
them wins it gets the reward uh then we
go back and reset and try again and then
kind of the fun part we actually get
down here is uh we're going to play with
a human so we'll get a chance to come in
here and see what that looks like when
you put your own information in and then
it just comes in here and does the same
thing it did above it gives it a reward
for its things or sees if it wins or
ties
looks at available positions all that
final fun stuff and then finally we want
to show the board so it's going to print
the board out each time
really as an integration is not that
exciting what's exciting in here is one
looking at this reward system whoops
Play One More up the reward system is
really the heart of this how do you
reward the different uh setup and the
other one is when it's playing it's got
to take an action
and so what it chooses for an action is
also the heart of reinforcement learning
how do we choose that action and those
are really key to right now where
reinforcement learning is
um in
today's technology is uh figuring this
out
how do we reward it and how do we guess
the next best action so we have our
environment and you can see the
environment is we're going to be or the
state which is kind of like what's going
on we're going to return the state
depending on what happens
we want to go ahead and create our agent
and this place our player so each one is
let me go and grab that and so we look
at a class player
um
this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what how is this
player figuring out how to maneuver
around the board and then the board of
course returns a state uh that it can
look at and a reward uh so we want to
take a look at this we have a name
self-state this is class player and we
say class player we're not talking about
a human player we're talking about just
a uh the computer players and this is
kind of interesting so remember I told
you depending on what you're doing
there's going to be a Decay gamma
explore rate uh
these are what I'm talking about is how
do we train it
um
as you try different moves it gets to
the end the first move is important but
it's not as important as the last one
and so you could say that the last one
has the heaviest weight and then as you
as you get there the first one let's see
the first move gives you a five reward
the second gives you a two reward and
the third one gives you a 10 reward
because that's the final ending you got
it the 10 is going to count more than
the first step
uh and here's our we're going to you
know get the board information coming in
and then choose an action this was the
second part that I was talking about
that was so important uh so once you
have your training going on
we have to do a little Randomness and
you can see right here is our NP random
uh uniform so it's picking out a random
number
take a random action this is going to
just pick which row and which column it
is and so choosing the action this one
you can see we're just doing random
States Choice length of positions action
position
and then it skips in there and takes a
look at the board for p in positions and
you get it's actually storing the
different boards each time you go
through so it has a record of what it
did so it can properly weigh the values
and this simply just depends a hash
State what's the last date pinned it to
the uh to our states on here here's our
feedback
rewards the reward comes in and it's
going to take a look at this and say is
it none what is the reward and is that
formula remember I was telling you about
up here
that was important because it has
Decay gamma times the reward this is
where
as it goes through each step and this is
really important this is this is kind of
the heart of this of what I was talking
about earlier you have step one
and this might have a reward of two you
have step two which probably should have
done ABC this has a step three step four
and so on until you get to step in
and this might have a reward of 10. uh
so reward at 10
we're going to add that but we're not
adding let's say this one right here
let's say this reward here before 10 was
um let's say it's also 10. it just makes
the the
so we had 10 and 10.
we had 10 this is 10 and 10 in whatever
it is but it's time it's 0.9 so instead
of putting a full 10 here
we only do nine that's uh 0.9 times
10.
and so this formula as far as the Decay
times the reward minus the cell State
value
it basically adds in it says here's one
or here's two I'm sorry I should have
done this ABC would have been easier so
the first move goes in here and it puts
2 in here
then we have ourself
setup on here you can see how this gets
pretty complicated in the math but this
is really the key is how do we train our
states and we want the the final State
the when to get the most points if you
win you get most points and the first
step gets the least amount of points so
you're really training this almost in
Reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now I need to
sum up my rewards and I want to sum them
up going in reverse and I want to find
the answer in Reverse kind of an
interesting uh play on the mind when
you're trying to figure this stuff out
and of course we want to go ahead and
reset the board down here and save the
policy load policy
these are the different things that are
going in between the agent and the state
to figure out what's going on let's go
ahead and load that up and then finally
we want to go ahead and create a human
player
and the human player is going to be a
little different
in that you choose an action row and
column here's your action if action is
if action in positions meaning positions
that are available
uh you return the action
if not it just keeps asking you until
you get the action that actually works
and then we're going to go ahead and
append to the hash state which we don't
need to worry about because it Returns
the action up here
and feed forward uh again this is
because it's a human
um at the end of the game bat propagate
and update State values this part isn't
being done because it's not programming
uh the model the model is getting its
own rewards so we've gone ahead and
loaded this in here so here's all our
pieces and the first thing we want to do
is set up a P1 player one P2 player two
and then we're going to send our players
to our state so now it has P1 P2 and
it's going to play and it's going to
play 50
000 rounds now we can probably do a lot
less than this and it's not going to get
the full results in fact you know what
uh let's go ahead and just do five
just to play with it because I want to
show you something here
oops somewhere in there I forgot to load
something
to run this run
oops forgot a reference there for the
board rows and columns three by three
there's actually in the state it
references that we just tack it on on
the end it was supposed to be at the
beginning
so now I've only set this up with
um
see where we go in here I've only set
this up to train
five times
and the reason I did that is we're going
to uh
come in and actually play it and then
I'm going to change that and we can see
how it differs on there
we go did you make it through a run and
we're going to go ahead and save the
policy
um so now we have our player one and our
player two policy
the way we set it up it has two separate
policies loaded up in there
and then we're going to come in here and
we're going to do player one is going to
be the computer experience rate zero
load policy one human player human and
we're going to go ahead and play this
now remember I only went through it um
just one round of training in fact
minimal training and so it puts an X
there and I'm going to go ahead and do
row 0 column one
you can see this is very uh basic on
here and so I put in my zero and then
I'm going to go 0 block it zero zero
and you can see right here let me win uh
just like that I was able to win zero
two and human wins
so I only trained it five times we're
gonna run this again and this time
instead of five let's do five thousand
or fifty thousand I think that's what
the guys in the back had
and this takes a while to train it
this is where reinforcement learning
really falls apart look how simple this
game is we're talking about a three by
three set of columns
and so for me to train it on this I
could do a q table which would take
which would go much quicker you could
build a quick cue table with almost all
the different options on there and uh
you would probably get a the same result
much quicker we're just using this as an
example so when we look at reinforcement
learning you need to be very careful
what you apply it to it sounds like a
good deal until you do like a large
neural network where you're doing you
set the neural network to a learning
increment of one so every time it goes
through it learns
and then you do your actions you pick
from the learning setup and you actually
try actions on the learning setup until
you get the what you think is going to
be the best action
so you actually feed what you think is
right back through the neural network
there's a whole layer there which is
really fun to play with
and then it has an output well think of
all those processes I mean that is just
a huge amount of work it's going to do
let's go ahead and Skip ahead here and
give it a moment it's going to take a a
minute or two to go ahead and run
foreign
now to train it we went ahead and let it
run and it took a while this this took
um I got a pretty powerful processor and
it took about five minutes plus to run
it
and we'll go ahead and uh
run our player setup on here oops it
brought in the last whoops I brought in
the last round so give me just a moment
to re do the policy save there we go I
forgot to save the policy back in there
and then go ahead and run our player
again
so we've saved the policy then we want
to go ahead and load the policy for P1
as a computer
and we can see the computer's gone in
the bottom right corner I'm going to go
ahead and go 1 1 which is the center
and it's gone right up the top and if
you have ever played tic-tac-toe you
know the computer has me but we'll go
ahead and play it out row zero
column two
there it is and then it's gone here and
so I'm going to go ahead and go row 0 1
2 no 0 1 there we go and column 0.
that's where I want it
oh and it says okay you your action
there we go boom uh so you can see here
we've got a didn't catch the win on this
it said tie
um kind of funny they didn't catch the
win on there
but if we play this a bunch of times
you'll find it's going to win more and
more the more we train it the more the
reinforcement happens
this lengthy training process is really
the stopper on reinforcement learning as
this changes reinforcement learning will
be one of the more powerful packages
evolving over the next decade or two in
fact I would even go as far as to say it
is the most important machine learning
tool in artificial intelligence tool out
there as it learns not only a simple
tic-tac-toe board but we start learning
environments and the environment would
be like in language if you're
translating a language or something from
one language to the other so much of it
is lost if you don't know the context
it's in what's the environments it's in
and so being able to attach environment
and context and all those things
together is going to require
reinforcement learning to do
so again if you want to get a copy of
the Tic Tac Toe board it's kind of fun
to play with run it you can test it out
you can do you know test it for
different uh values you can switch from
P1 computer
where we loaded the policy one to load
the policy two and just see how it
varies there's all kinds of things you
can do on there so what is Q learning Q
learning is reinforcement learning
policy which will fill the next best
action given a current state it chooses
this action at random and aims to
maximize the reward and so you can see
here's our standard reinforcement
learning graph by now if you're doing
any reinforcement learning
you should be familiar with this where
you have your agent your agent takes an
action the action affects the
environment and then the environment
sends back the reward or the feedback
and the state it's the new state the
agent's in where is it at on the chess
board where is it at in the video game
um if you're robots out there picking
trash up off the side of the road where
is it at on the road consider an ad
recommendation system usually when you
look up a product online
you get ads which will suggest the same
product over and over again
using Q learning we can make an ad
recommendation system which will suggest
related products to our previous
purchase the reward will be if user
clicks on the suggested product
and again you can see you might have a
lot of products on your web
advertisement or your pages but it's
still not a float number it's still a
set number and that's something to be
aware of when you're using Q learning
and you can see here that if you have a
hundred people clicking on ads and you
click on one of the ads it might go in
there and say okay this person clicked
on this ad when we talk about States
we're usually not with when you're using
a q table you're not usually talking
about float variables you're talking
about true false and we'll take a closer
look at that in a second
and episodes when an agent ends up in a
terminating State and can't take a new
action
this might be if you're playing a video
game your character stepped in and is
now dead or whatever
Q values used to determine how good an
action a taken at a particular State s
is q a of s and temporal difference a
formula used to find the Q value by
using the value of the current state and
action and previous date in action and
very I mean there's bellman's equation
which basically is the equation that
kind of uh covers what we just looked at
in all those different terms the Bellman
equation is used to determine the values
of a particular State and deduce how
good it is to be in take that state the
optimal the optimal state will give us
the highest optimal value
Factor influencing Q values the current
state and action that's your essay so
your current state in your action
uh then you have your previous date in
action which is your S I guess Prime I'm
not sure how they how they reference
that S Prime a prime so this is what
happened before then you have a reward
for Action so you have your R reward and
you have your maximum expected future
reward
and you can see there's also a learning
rate put in there and a discount rate so
we're looking at these just like any
other model we don't want to have an
absolute
final value on here we don't want it to
if you do absolute values instead of
taking smaller steps you don't really
have that approach to the solution you
just have a jump and then pretty soon if
you jump one solution out that's what's
going to be the new solution whichever
one jumps up really high first kind of
ruining the whole idea of doing a random
selection and I'll go into the random
selection in just a second steps in Q
learning
step one create an initial Q table with
all values initialized to zero again
we're looking at 0 1 so are you you know
here's our action we start we're an idle
we took a wrong action we took a correct
action in int and then we have our
actions fetching sitting and running of
course we're just using the dog example
and choose an action and perform it
update values in the table and of course
when we're choosing an action we're
going to kind of do something random and
just randomly pick one so you start out
and you sit and you have then uh then
depending on that
action you took you can now update the
value for sitting after you start from
start to sitting
get the value of the reward and
calculate the value the value Q value
using the Bellman equation
and so now we attach a reward to sitting
and we attach all those rewards we
continue the same until the table is
filled with or an episode ends
and my membership is going to come back
to the random side of this and there's a
few different formulas I use for the
random
setup to pick it I usually let whatever
Q model I'm using do their standard one
because someone's usually gone and done
the math for the optimal spread but you
can look at this if I have running has a
reward of 10 sitting as a reward of
seven fetching has a reward of five
just kind of without doing like a a
means using the bell curve for the means
value and like I said there's some math
you can put in there to pick so that
you're more likely so that running has
even a higher chance but even if you're
just going to do an average on this
you could do an average a random number
by adding them all together so you get
10 plus 7 plus 5 is 22 you do 0 to 22
and or 0 to 21 but 1 to 22. one to five
would be fetching uh and so forth you
know the last 10. so you can just look
at this as what percentage are you going
to go for that particular option
and then that gets your random setup in
there and then as you slowly increment
these up you see that if you're idle
where's one here we go sitting at the
end if you're at the end of wherever
you're at sitting gets a reward of one
where's the good one on here oh wrong
action running for a wrong action gets
almost no reward so that becomes very
very less likely to happen but it still
might happen it still might have a
percentage of coming up and that's where
the random programming and Q learning
comes in the below table gives us an
idea of how many times an action has
been taken and how positively correct
action or negatively wrong action it is
going to affect the next state so let's
go ahead and dive in and pull up a
little piece of code and see what this
looks like
in Python
uh in this demo we'll use cute learning
to find the shortest path between two
given points if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
to do it in the
just because it's really easy to see and
it's a nice demo and so here's my
anaconda this one I'm actually using uh
python 36 environment that I set up in
here and we'll go ahead and launch the
Jupiter Notebook on this
and once we're in our Jupiter notebook
which has the kernel loaded with python3
we'll go ahead and create a new Python 3
folder in here
and we'll call this Q
learning
and to start this demo
let's go ahead and import our numpy
array we'll just run that so it's
imported and like a lot of these model
programs when you're building them you
spend a lot of time putting it all
together
um
and then you end up with this really
short answer at the end
and we'll we'll take a look at that as
we come into it so we go ahead and start
with our location to State uh so we have
L1 L2 these are our nine locations one
to nine
and then of course the state is going to
be zero one two three four it's just a
mapping of our location to a integer on
there and then we have our actions our
actions are simply moving from
one location
to another so I can go to I can go to
location zero I can go to location one
two three four five six seven eight uh
so these are my actions I can choose
these are the locations of our state
and if you remember earlier I mentioned
uh that the limitation is that you you
don't want to put in a continually
growing table because you can actually
create a dynamic queue table where you
continually add in new values as they
arise
because
if you have float values this just
becomes infinite and then your memory
and your computer is gone or you know
does it's not going to work
at the same time you might think well
that kind of really limits the the cue
learning setup
but there are ways to use it in
conjunction with other systems and so
you might look at
well I do
um I've been doing some work in stock
and one of the questions that comes out
is to buy or sell the stock and the
state coming in might be you might take
a concrete we call buckets
um where anything that you predict is
going to return more than a certain
amount of money
the error for that stock that you've had
in the past you put those in buckets and
suddenly you start putting creating
these buckets you realize you do have a
limited amount of information coming in
you no longer have a float number you
now have bucket one two three and four
and then you can take those buckets put
them through a cue learning table and
come up with the best action which stock
should I buy it's like gambling stock is
pretty much gambling if you're doing day
trading you're not doing long term
investments and so you can start looking
at it like that a lot of the current
feeds say that the best algorithms used
for day Traders are you doing it on your
own is really to ask the question do I
want to trade the stock yes or no and
now you have it in a q learning table
and now you can take it to that next
level and you can see where that can be
a really powerful tool at the end of
doing a basic linear regression model or
something
what is the best investment and you
start getting the best board on there
and so if we're going to have rewards
these rewards we just create
it says if basically if you're this
should match our Q table because it's
going to be you have your state and you
have your action across the top if you
remember from the dog and so we have
whatever state we're in going down and
then the next action and what the reward
is for it
and of course if you were actually doing
a something more connected your reward
would be based on the actual environment
it's in and then we want to go ahead and
create a state to location so we can map
the indexes
so just like we defined our rewards
we're going to go ahead and do state to
location
and you can see here it's a dictionary
setup for location State and location to
state with items
and we also need to
um
Define what we want for learning rates
you remember we had our two different
rates as far as like learning from the
past and learning from the current so
we'll go ahead and set those to 0.75 in
the alpha set to 0.9 and we'll see that
when we do the formula
and of course any of this code sent a
note to our simply learned team they'll
get you a copy of this code on here
let's go ahead and pull
there we go
on the new next two sections
um
since we're going to keep it short and
sweet
here we go so let's go ahead and create
our agent so our agent is going to have
our initialization where we send it all
the information we'll Define our self
gamma equals gamma we could have just
set the gamma rate down here instead of
submitting it
it's kind of nice to keep them separate
because you can play with these numbers
on our self Alpha
then we have our location State we'll
set that in here we have our choice of
actions we're going to go ahead and just
embed the rewards right into the agent
so obviously this would be coming from
somewhere else instead of from
self-generated and then a self-state to
location equals our state to location
dictionary
and we go ahead and create a q learning
table and I went ahead and just set the
Q learning table up to
zero to zero what what the setup is
location to State how many of them are
there
and this just creates an array of zero
to zero setup on there
and then the big part is the training we
have our rewards new equals a copy of
self.rewards
ending State equals the self-location
state in location so this is whatever we
end up at rewards new equals ending
State plus ending State equals 999 just
kind of goes
to a dead end
and we start going through iterations
and we'll go ahead let's do this
uh so this we're going to come back and
we're going to call call it on here let
me just erase that
switch it to an arrow
there we go uh so what we're doing is
we're going to send in here to train it
we're going to say hey I want to iterate
through this a thousand times
and see what happens now this part would
actually be instead of iterating you
might have your external environment and
they're going back and forth and you
iterate through outside of here but just
for ease of use our agent is going to
come in here and iterate through this
sometimes I'll put this iteration in
here and I'll have it call the
environment and say hey this is what I
did what's the next state and the
environment does its thing right in here
as I iterate through it
and then we want to go ahead and pick a
random state to start with that's what's
going on here you have to start
somewhere
and then you have your playable actions
we're going to start with just an empty
thing for playable actions and we'll
fill that up
so that's what choices I have
and so we're going to iterate through
the rewards Matrix to get the states
directly reachable from the randomly
chosen current state assign those states
to a list named playable actions
and so you can see here we have range
nine I usually use length of whatever
I'm looking at which is our locations or
States as they are we have a reward so
we want to look at the current the
rewards uh the new reward
is our is in our chart here of rewards
underscore new uh current state
um plus J J being what is the next state
we want to try
and so we go ahead and do our playable
actions and we append J
and so we're doing is we're randomly
trying different things in here to see
what's going to generate a better reward
and then of course we go ahead and
choose our next state so we have our
random Choice playable actions and if
you remember I mentioned on this let me
just go ahead and oops let's do a free
form
when we were talking about the next
state
this right here just as a random
selection instead of a random selection
you might do something where whatever
the best selection is which might be
option three
here and then so you can see that it
might use a bell curve and then option
two over here might have a bell curve
like this oops
and we start looking at these averages
and these spreads or we can just add
them all together and pick the one that
kind of goes in all of those
so those are some of the options we have
in here we just go with the random
Choice that's usually where you start
play with it
and then we have our rewards section
down here
and so we want to go ahead and find well
in this case the temporal difference so
you have your rewards new plus the self
gamma and this is the formula we were
looking at this is bellman's equation
here so we have our current value our
learning rate our discount rate involved
in there the reward system coming in for
that and we can add it all together this
is of course our maximum expected future
setup in here so this is all of our our
bellman's equation that we're looking at
here
and then we come up in here and we
update our queue table that's all this
is on this one that's right here we have
self-q current state next date and we
add in our Alpha because we don't want
to we don't want to train all of it at
once in case there's slight differences
coming in there we want to slowly
approach the answer and then we have our
route equals the start location
and next location equals start location
so we're just incrementing we took a
step forward
and then finally remember I was telling
you how we're going to do all this and
just have some simple thing at the end
or just generates a simple path we're
going to go ahead and get the optimal
route we want to find the best route in
here and so we've created a definition
for the optimal route down here
let me just scroll down for that
and we get the optimal route we go ahead
and put the information in including the
queue table self start location in
location next location route q and it
says while next location is not equal to
in location so while we can still go
our start location equals self-location
to State start location so we already
have our best value for the start
location
the next state looks at the queue table
and says hey what's the next one with
the best value and then the next
location we go ahead and pull that in
and we just append it that's what's
going on down here
and then our start location equals the
next location and we just go through all
the steps and we'll go ahead and run
this
and now that we have our Q table our Q
agent loaded we're going to go ahead and
take our Q agent load them up with our
Alpha Gamma that we set up above along
with the location step action reward
state to location
and
our goal is to plot a course between L9
and L1
and we're going to go through a hundred
a thousand iterations on here and so
when I run that it runs pretty quick why
is this so fast
if you've been running neural networks
and you've been doing all these other
models you sit here and wait a long time
well we're a very small amount of data
these are all integers these aren't
float values there's not it the math is
not heavy on the on the processing end
and this is where Q tables are so
powerful if you have a small amount of
information coming in you very quickly
get an answer off of this even though we
went through it a thousand times to
train it and you'll see here we have
l985 two and one and that's based on our
reward table we had set up on there and
this is the shortest path going between
these different setups in here
and if you remember on our reward table
you can see that if you start here you
can go to here there's places you can't
go that's how this reward table was set
up so I can only go to certain places
so kind of a little maze set up in there
and you can play with it this is really
fun setup to play with and you can see
how you can take this whole code and you
can like I was saying earlier you can
embed it into another setup and model
and predictions where you put things
into buckets and you're trying to guess
the best investment the best course of
action as long as you can take that
course into action and
reduce it down to a yes no or if you're
using text you can use a one hot encoder
which word is next there's all kinds of
things you can do with a Q table
depending on just how much information
you're putting in there so that wraps up
our demo in this demo we've found the
shortest distance between two paths
based on whatever rules or state rewards
we have to get from point A to point B
and what available actions there are
hello and welcome to this tutorial on
deep learning my name is Mohan and in
the next mark one line of course I
through what is deep learning and into
tensorflow environment to show you an
example of deep learning now there are
several applications of deep learning
really very interesting and Innovative
applications and one of them is
identifying the geographic location
based on a picture and how does this
work the way it works is pretty much we
train an artificial neural network with
millions of images which are tagged
their geolocation is stacked and then
when we feed a new picture it will be
able to identify the geolocation of this
new image for example you have all these
images specially with maybe some
significant monuments or
significant locations and you train with
millions of such images and then when
you feed another image it need not be
exactly one of those that you have
claimed it can be completely different
that is the whole idea of training it
will be able to recognize for example
that this is a picture from Paris
because it is able to recognize the
Eiffel Tower so the way it works
internally if we have to look a little
bit under the hood as these images are
nothing but this is digital information
in the form of pixels so each image
could be a certain size it can be 256 by
256 pixel kind of a resolution and then
each pixel is either having a certain
grade of color and all that is fed into
the neural network and it then gets
trained in and it's able to based on
these pixels pixel information it is
able to get trained and able to
recognize the features and extract the
features and thereby it is able to
identify these images and the location
of these images and then when you feed a
new image it kind of based on the
training it will be able to figure out
way this image is from so that's the way
a little bit under the hood how it works
so what are we going to do in this
tutorial we will see what is deep
learning and what do we need for deep
learning and one of the main components
of deep learning is neural networks we
will see what is neural network what is
a perceptron and how to implement logic
gates like and or Draw and so on using
perceptrons the different types of
neural networks and then applications of
deep learning and we will also see how
neural networks works so how do we do
the training of neural networks
and at the end we will end up with a
small demo code which will take you
through in tensorflow now in order to
implement deep learning Port there are
multiple libraries or development
environments that are available and
tensorflow is one of them so the focus
at the end of this would be on how to
use tensorflow to write a piece of code
using python as a programming language
and we will take up an example which is
a very common one which is like the
hello world of deep learning the
handwriting number recognition which is
a mnist commonly known as MNS database
so we will take a look at Ms database
and how we can train a neural network to
recognize handwritten numbers so that's
what you will see in this particular
video so let's get started what is deep
learning deep learning is like a subset
of what is known as a high level concept
called artificial intelligence you must
be already familiar must have heard
about this term artificial intelligence
so artificial intelligence is like the
high level concept if you will and in
order to implement artificial
intelligence applications we use what is
known as machine learning and within
machine learning a subset of machine
learning is deep learning machine
learning is a little bit more generic
concept and deep learning is one type of
machine learning if you will and we will
see a little later in maybe the
following slides a little bit more in
detail how deep learning is different
from traditional machine learning but to
start with we can mention here that deep
learning uses one of the differentiators
between deep learning and traditional
machine learning is that deep learning
uses neural networks and we will talk
about what are neural networks and how
we can Implement neural networks and so
on and so forth as a part of this
it's a little deeper into deep learning
deep learning primarily involves working
with complicated unstructured data
compared to traditional machine learning
where we normally use structured data in
deep learning the data would be
primarily images or Voice or maybe text
file so and it is large amount of data
as well and deep learning can handle
complex operations it involves complex
operations and the other difference
between traditional machine learning and
deep learning is that the feature
extraction happens pretty much
automatically in traditional machine
learning feature engineering is done
manually the data scientists we data
scientists have to do feature
engineering feature extraction but in
deep learning that happens automatically
and of course deep learning for large
amounts of data complicated unstructured
data deep learning gives very good
performance now as I mentioned one of
the secret
sources of deep learning is neural
networks let's see what neural networks
is neural networks is based on our
biological neurons the whole concept of
deep learning and artificial
intelligence is based on human brain and
human brain consists of billions of tiny
stuff called neurons and this is how a
biological neuron looks and this is how
an artificial neuron look so neural
networks is like a simulation of our
human brain human brain has billions of
biological neurons and we are trying to
simulate the human brain using
artificial neurons this is how a
biological neuron looks it has dendrites
and the corresponding component with an
artificial neural network is or an
artificial neuron are the inputs they
receive the input through dendrites and
then there is the cell nucleus which is
basically the processing unit in a way
so in artificial neuron also there is a
piece which is an equivalent of this
cell nucleus and based on the weights
and biases we will see what exactly
weights and biases are as we move the
input gets processed and that results in
an output in a biological neuron the
output is sent through a synapse and in
an artificial neuron there is an
equivalent of that in the form of an
output and biological neurons are also
interconnected so there are billions of
neurons which are interconnected in the
same way artificial neurons are also
interconnected so this output of this
neuron will be fed as an input to
another neuron and so on now in neural
network one of the very basic units is a
perceptron so what is the perceptron a
perceptron can be considered as one of
the fundamental units of neural networks
it can consist at least one neuron but
sometimes it can be more than one neuron
but you can create a perceptron with a
single neuron and it can be used to
perform certain functions it can be used
as a basic binary classifier it can be
trained to do some basic binary
classification and this is how a basic
perceptron looks like and this is
nothing but a neuron you have inputs X1
X2 X 2 X N and there is a summation
function and then there is what is known
as an activation function and based on
this input what is known as the weighted
sum the activation function either gets
gives an output like a zero or a one so
we say the neuron is either activated or
not so that's the way it works so you
get the inputs these inputs are each of
the inputs are multiplied by a weight
and there is a bias that gets added and
that whole thing is is fed to an
activation function and then that
results in an output and if the output
is correct it is accepted it is wrong if
there is an error then that error is fed
back and the neuron then adjusts the
weights and biases to give a new output
and so on and so forth so that's what is
known as the training process of a
neuron or a neural network this is a
concept called perceptron learning so
perceptron learning is again one of the
very basic learning processes the way it
works is somewhat like this so you have
all these inputs like X1 to xn and each
of these inputs is multiplied by a
weight and then that sum this is the
formula or the equation so that's sum w
i x i Sigma of that which is the sum of
all these product of X and W is added up
and then a bias is added to that the
bias is not dependent on the input word
or the input values but the bias is
common for one neuron however the bias
value keeps changing during the training
process once the training is completed
the values of these weights W1 W2 and so
on and the value of the bias gets fixed
so that is basically the whole training
process and that is what is known as the
perceptron training so the weights and
biases keep changing till you get the
accurate output and the summation is of
course passed through the activation
function as you see here this wixi
summation plus b is passed through
activation function and then the neuron
gets either fired or not and based on
that there will be an output that output
is compared with the actual or expected
value which is also known as labeled
information so this is the process of
supervised learning so the output is
already known and that is compared and
thereby we know if there is an error or
not and if there is an error there is
fed back and the weights and biases are
updated accordingly till the error is
reduced to the minimum so this iterative
process is known as perceptron learning
or perceptron learning Rule and this
error needs to be minimized so till the
error is minimized this iteratively the
weights and biases keep changing and
that is what is the training process so
the whole idea is to update the weights
and the bias of the perceptron till the
error is minimized the error need not be
zero error may not ever reach 0 but the
idea is to keep changing these weights
and bias so that the error is minimum
the minimum possible that it can have so
this whole process is an iterative
process and this is the iteration
continue are still either the error is 0
which is unlikely situation or it is the
minimum possible Within These given
conditions now in 1943 two scientists
Warren McCullough and Walter Pitts came
up with an experiment where they were
able to implement the logical functions
like and or and nor using neurons and
that was a significant breakthrough in a
sense so they were able to come up with
the most common logical Gates they were
able to implement some of the most
common logical Gates which could take
two inputs Like A and B and then give a
corresponding result so for example in
case of an and gate A and B and then the
output is a b in case of an or gate it
is a plus b and so on and so forth and
they were able to do this using a single
layer perceptron now now most of these
Gates it was possible to use single
layer perceptron except for XR and we
will see why that is in a little bit so
this is how an and gate works the inputs
A and B the output should be fired or
the neuron should be fired only when
both the inputs are one so if you have
zero zero the output should be zero for
zero one it is again 0 1 0 again 0 and 1
1 the output should be 1. so how do we
implement this with a neuron so it was
found that by changing the values of
Weights it is possible to achieve this
logic so for example if we have equal
weights like 0.7 0.7 and then if we take
the sum of the weighted products so for
example 0.7 into 0 and then 0.7 into 0
will give you 0 and so on and so forth
and in the last case when both the
inputs are one you get a value which is
greater than one which is the threshold
so only in the this case the neuron gets
activated and the output is there is an
output in all the other cases there is
no output because the threshold value is
one so this is implementation of an and
gate using a single perceptron or a
single neuron similarly an or gate in
order to implement an or gate in case of
an or gate the output will be 1 if
either of these inputs is one so for
example 0 1 will result in 1 or rather
in all the cases it is 1 except for zero
zero so how do we implement this using a
perceptron once again if you have a
perceptron with weights for example 1.2
now if you see here if in the first case
when both are 0 the output is 0 in the
second case when it is 0 and 1 1.2 into
0 is 0 and then 1.2 into 1 is 1 and in
the second case similarly the output is
1.2 in this last case when both the
inputs are 1 the output is 2.4 so during
the training process these weights will
keep changing and then at one point
where the weights are equal to W1 is
equal to 1.2 and W2 is equal to 1.2 the
system learns that it gives the correct
output so that is implementation of or
gate using a single neuron or a single
layer Etc now xor gate this was one of
the challenging ones they tried to
implement an xor gate with a single
level perceptron but it was not possible
and therefore in order to implement an
xor so this was like a roadblock in the
progress of neural network however
subsequently they realize that this can
be implemented and xor gate can be
implemented using a multi-level
perceptron or MLP so in this case there
are two layers instead of a single layer
and this is how you can Implement an xor
gate so you will see that X1 and X2 are
the inputs and there is a hidden layer
and that's why it is denoted as h3nh 4
and then you take the output of that and
feed it to the output at o5 and provide
a threshold here so we will see here
that this is the numerical calculation
so the weights are in this case for X1
it is 20 and minus 20 and once again 20
n minus 20. so these inputs are fed into
H3 and H4 so you'll see here for H3 the
input is 0 1 1 1 and for H4 it is 1 0 1
1 and if you now look at the output
final output where the threshold is
taken as 1 if we use a sigmoid with a
threshold one you will see that in these
two cases it is 0 and in the last two
cases it is one so this is a
implementation of xor in case of x r
only when one of the inputs is one you
will get an output so that is what we
are seeing here if we have either both
the inputs are 1 or both the inputs are
0 then the output should be zero so that
is what is an exclusive or gate so it is
exclusive because only one of the inputs
should be one and then only you'll get
an output of 1 which is Satisfied by
this condition so this is a special
implementation xor gate is a special
implementation of perceptron now that we
got a good idea about perceptron let's
take a look at what is the neural
network so we have seen what is a
perceptron we have seen what is a neuron
so we will see what exactly is a neural
network so neural network is nothing but
a network of these neurons and they are
different types of neural networks there
are about five of them these are
artificial neural network convolutional
neural network then recursive neural
network or recurrent neural network deep
neural network and deep belief Network
so and each of these types of neural
networks have a special you know they
can solve special kind of problems for
example can evolutional neural networks
are very good at performing image
processing and image recognition and so
on whereas R and N are very good for
speech recognition and also text
analysis and so on so each type has some
special characteristics and they can
they are good at performing certain
special kind of tasks what are some of
the applications of deep learning deep
learning is today used extensively in
gaming you must have heard about alphago
which is a game created by a startup
called deepmind which got acquired by
Google and alphago is an AI which
defeated the human world champion lease
it all in this game of Go so gaming is
an area where deep learning is being
extensively used and a lot of research
happens in the area of gaming as well in
addition to that nowadays there are
neural networks or special type call
generative adversarial networks which
can be used for synthesizing either
images or music or text and so on and
they can be used to compose music so the
neural network can be trained to compose
a certain kind of music and autonomous
cars you must be familiar with Google
Google's self-driving car and today a
lot of Automotive companies are
investing in this space and deep
learning is a core component of this
autonomous cars the cars are trained to
recognize for example the road the lane
markings on the road signals any objects
that are in front any obstruction and so
on and so forth so all this involves
deep learning so that's another major
application and robots we have seen
several robots including Sophia you may
be familiar with Sophia who was given a
citizenship by Saudi Arabia and there
are several such robots which are very
human-like and the underlying technology
in many of these robots is deep learning
medical Diagnostics and Healthcare is
another major area where deep learning
is being used and within Healthcare
Diagnostics again there are multiple
areas where deep learning and image
recognition image processing can be used
for example for cancer detection as you
may be aware if cancer is detected early
on it can be cured and one of the
challenges is in the availability of
Specialists who can diagnose cancer
using these diagnostic images and
various scans and and so on and so forth
so the idea is to train neural network
to perform some of these activities so
that the load on the cancer specialist
doctors or oncologists comes down and
there is a lot of research Happening
Here and there are already quite a few
applications that are claimed to be
performing better than human beings in
this space can be lung cancer it can be
breast cancer and so on and so forth so
Healthcare is a major area where deep
learning is being applied let's take a
look at the inner working of a neural
network so how does an artificial neural
network let's say identify can we train
a neural network to identify the shapes
like squares and circles and triangles
when these images are fed so this is how
it works any image is nothing but it is
a digital information of the pixels so
in this particular case let's say this
is an image of 28 by 28 pixel and this
is an image of a square there is a
certain way in which the pixels are lit
up and so these pixels have a certain
value maybe from 0 to 256 and 0
indicates that it is black or it is dark
and 256 indicates it is completely it is
white or litter so that is like an
indication or a measure of the how the
pixels are lit up and so this is an
image is let's say consisting of
information of 784 pixels so all the
information what is inside this image
can be kind of compressed into this 784
pixels the way each of these pixels is
lit up provides information about what
exactly is the image so we can train
neural networks to use that information
and identify the images so let's take a
look how this works so each neuron the
value if it is close to 1 that means it
is white whereas if it is close to 0
that means it is black now this is a an
animation of how the assaulting works so
these pixels one of the ways of doing it
is we can flatten this image and take
this complete 784 pixels and feed that
as input to our neural network the
neural network can consist of probably
several layers there can be a few hidden
layers and then there is an input layer
and an output layer now the input layer
take the 784 pixels as input the values
of each of these pixels and then you get
an output which can be of three types or
three classes one can be a square a
circle or a triangle now during the
training process there will be initially
obviously you feed this image and it
will probably say it's a circle or it
will say it's a triangle so as a part of
the training process we then send that
error back and the weights and the
biases of these neurons are adjusted
till it correctly identifies that this
is square that is the whole training
mechanism that happens out here
now let's take a look at a circle same
way so you feed these 784 pixels there
is a certain pattern in which the pixels
are lit up and the neural network is
trained to identify that pattern
and during the training process once
again it would probably initially
identify it incorrectly saying this is a
square or a triangle and then that error
is fed back and the weights and biases
are adjusted finally till it finally
gets the image correct
so that is the training process so now
we will take a look at same way a
triangle
so now if you feed another image which
is consisting of triangle so this is the
training process now we have trained our
neural network to classify these images
into a triangle or a circle and a square
so now this neural network can identify
these three types of objects now if you
feed another image and it will be able
to identify whether it's a square or a
triangle or a circle now what is
important to be observed is that when
you feed a new image it is not necessary
that the image or the the triangle is
exactly in this position now the neural
network actually
identifies the patterns so even if the
triangle is let's say positioned here
not exactly in the middle but maybe at
the corner or in the side it would still
identify that it is a triangle and that
is the whole idea behind pattern
recognition so how does this training
process sources of work this is a quick
view of how the training process works
so we have seen that a neuron consists
of inputs it receives inputs and then
there is a weighted sum which is nothing
but this x i w i summation of that plus
the bias and this is then fed to the
activation function and that in turn
gives us a output now during the
training process initially obviously
when you feed these images when you send
maybe a square it will identify it as a
triangle and when you maybe feed a
triangle it will identify as a square
and so on so that error information is
fed back and initially these weights can
be random maybe all of them have zero
values and then it will slowly keep
changing so the as a part of the
training process the values of these
weights W1 W2 up to WN keep changing in
such a way that towards the end of the
training process it should be able to
identify these images correctly so till
then the weights are adjusted and that
is known as the training process so and
these weights are numeric values it
could be 0.5
0.25.35 and so on it could be positive
or it could be negative and the value
that is coming here is the pixel value
as we have seen it can be anything
between 0 to 1 you can scale it between
0 to 1 or 0 to 256 whichever way 0 being
a black and 256 being white and then all
the other colors in between so that is
the input so these are numerical values
this multiplication or the product w i x
i is a numerical value and the bias is
also numerical value we need to keep in
mind that the bias is fixed for a neuron
it doesn't change with the inputs
whereas the weights are one per input so
that is one important point to be noted
so but the bias also keeps changing
initially it will again have a random
value but as a part of the training
process the weights the values of the
weights W1 W to WN and the the value of
B will change and ultimately once the
training process is complete these
values are fixed for this particular
neuron W1 W2 up to WN and plus the value
of the B is also fixed for this
particular neuron and in this way there
will be multiple neurons and each there
may be multiple levels of neurons here
and that's the way the training process
works so this is another example of
multi-layer so there are two hidden
layers in between and then you have the
input layer values coming from the input
layer then it goes through multiple
layers hidden layers and then there is
an output layer and as you can see there
are weights and biases for each of these
neurons in each layer and all of them
gets keeps changing during the cleaning
process and at the end of the training
process all these weights have a certain
value and that is a trained model and
those values will be fixed once the
training is completed alright then there
is something known as activation
function neural networks consists of one
of the components in neural networks is
activation function and every neuron has
an activation function and there are
different types of activation functions
that are used it could be a relu it
could be sigmoid and so on and so forth
and the activation function is what
decides whether a neuron should be fired
or not so whether the output should be 0
or 1 is decided by the activation
function and the activation function in
turn takes the input which is the
weighted sum remember we talked about w
i x i plus b that weighted sum is fed as
a input to the activation function and
then the output can be either a zero or
a one and there are different types of
activation functions which are covered
in an earlier video you might want to
watch all right so as a part of the
training process we feed the inputs the
label data or the training data and then
it gives an output which is the
predicted output by the network which we
indicate as y hat and then there is a
labeled data because we for supervised
learning we already know what should be
the output so that is the actual output
and in the initial process before the
training is complete obviously there
will be error so that is measured by
what is known as a cost function so the
difference between the predicted output
and the actual output is the error and
the cost function can be defined in
different ways there are different types
of cost functions so in this case it is
like the average of the squares of the
error so and then all the errors are
added which can sometimes be called as
sum of squares sum of square errors or
SSC and that is then fed as a feedback
in what is known as backward propagation
or back propagation and that helps in
the network adjusting the weights and
biases and so the weights and biases get
updated till this value the error value
or the cost function is minimum now
there is a optimization technique which
is used here called gradient descent
optimization and this algorithm Works in
a way that the error which is the cost
function needs to be minimized so
there's a lot of mathematics that goes
behind us for example they find the
local minimum the global Minima using
differentiation and so on and so forth
but the idea is this so as a training
process as the as the part of training
the whole idea is to bring down the
error which is like let's say this is
the function the cost function at
certain levels it is very high the cost
value of the cost function the output of
the cost function is very high so the
weights have to be adjusted in such a
way and also the bias of course that the
cost function is minimized so there is
this optimization technique called
gradient descent that is used and this
is known as the learning rate now
gradient descent you need to specify
what should be the learning rate and the
learning rate should be optimal because
if you have a very high learning rate
then the optimization will not converge
because at some point it will cross over
to the side on the other hand if you
have very low learning rate then it
might take forever to convert so you
need to come up with the optimum value
of the learning rate and once that is
done using the gradient descent
optimization the error function is
reduced and that's like the end of the
training process all right so this is
another view of gradient descent so this
is how it looks this is your cost
function the output of the cost function
and that has to be minimized using
gradient descent algorithm and these are
like the parameters and weight could be
one of them so initially we start with
certain random values so cost will be
high and then the weights keep changing
and in such a way that the cost function
needs to come down and at some point it
may reach the minimum value and then it
may increase so that is where the
gradient descent algorithm decides that
okay it has reached the minimum value
and it will kind of try to stay here
this is known as the global Minima now
sometimes these curves may not be just
for explanation purpose this has been
drawn in a nice way but sometimes these
curves can be pretty erratic there can
be some local Minima here and then there
is a peak and then and so on so the
whole idea of gradient descent
optimization is to identify the global
Minima and to find the weights and the
bias at that particular point so that's
what is gradient descent and then this
is another example so you can have these
multiple local Minima so as you can see
at this point when it is coming down it
may appear like this is a minimum value
but then it is not this is actually the
global minimum value and the gradient is
an algorithm will make an effort to
reach this level and not get stuck at
this point so the algorithm is already
there and it knows how to identify this
Global minimum and that's what it does
during the training process now in order
to implement deep learning there are
multiple platforms and languages that
are available but the most common
platform nowadays is tensorflow and so
that's the reason we have uh this
tutorial we created this tutorial for
tensorflow so we will take you through a
quick demo of how to write a tensorflow
code using Python and tensorflow is an
open source platform created by Google
so let's just take a look at the details
of tensorflow long and so this is a
library a python Library so you can use
python or any other languages it's also
supported in other languages like Java
and R and so on but python is the most
common language that is used so it is a
library for developing deep learning
applications especially using neural
networks and it consists of primarily
two parts if you will so one is the
tensors and then the other is the graphs
or the flow that's the way the name
that's the reason for this kind of a
name called tensorflow so what are
tensor sensors are like
multi-dimensional arrays if you will
that's one way of looking at it so
usually you have a one-dimensional array
so first of all you can have what is
known as a scalar which means a number
and then you have a one-dimensional
array something like this which means
this is like a set of numbers so that is
a one-dimension array then you can have
a two dimensional array which is like a
matrix
and beyond that sometimes it gets
difficult so this is a three-dimensional
array but tensorflow can handle many
more Dimensions so it can have
multi-dimensional arrays that is the
strength of tensorflow and which makes
computation deep learning computation
much faster and that's the reason why
tensorflow is used for developing deep
learning applications so tensorflow is a
deep learning tool and this is the way
it works so the data basically flows in
the form of tensors and the way the
programming works as well is that you
first create a graph of how to execute
it and then you actually execute that
particular graph in the form of what is
known as a session we will see this in
the tensorflow code as we move forward
so all the data is managed or
manipulated in tensors and then the
processing happens using this graphs
there are certain terms called like for
example ranks of a 10 answer the rank of
a tensor is like a dimensional
dimensionality in a way so for example
if it is scalar so there is just a
number just a one number the rank is
supposed to be 0 and then it can be a
one-dimensional vector in which case the
rank is supposed to be 1 and then you
can have a two dimensional Vector
typically like a matrix then in that
case we say the rank is 2 and then if it
is a three-dimensional array then rank
is three and so on so it can have more
than three as well so it is possible
that you can store multi-dimensional
arrays in the form of tensors so what
are some of the properties of tensorflow
I think today it is one of the most
popular platform tensorflow is the most
popular deep learning platform or
Library it is open source so developed
by Google developed and maintained by
Google but it is open source one of the
most important things about tensorflow
is that it can run on CPUs as well as
gpus GPU is a graphical Processing Unit
just like CPU Central Processing Unit
now in earlier days GPU was used for
primarily for graphics and that's how
the name has come and one of the reasons
is that it cannot perform generic
activities very efficiently like CPU but
it can perform iterative actions or
computations extremely fast and much
faster than a CPU so they are really
good for computational activities and in
deep learning there is a lot of
iterative computation that happens so in
the form of matrix multiplication and so
on so gpus are very well suited for this
kind of computation and tensorflow
supports both GPU as well as CPU and
there's a certain way of writing code in
tensorflow we will see as we go into the
core and of course tensorflow can be
used for traditional machine learning as
well but then that would be an Overkill
but just for understanding it may be a
good idea to start writing code for a
normal machine learning use case so that
you get a hang of how tensorflow code
works and then you can move into neural
networks so that is just a suggestion
but if you're already familiar with how
tensorflow works then probably yeah you
can go straight into the neural networks
part so in this tutorial we will take
the use case of recognizing handwritten
digits this is like a hello world of
deep learning and this is a nice little
MNS database is a nice little database
that has images of handwritten digits
nicely formatted because very often in
deep learning and neural networks we end
up spending a lot of time in preparing
the data for training and with MNS
database we can avoid that you already
have the data in the right format which
can be directly used for training and
mnist also offers a bunch of built-in
utility functions that we can straight
away use and call those functions
without worrying about writing our own
functions and that's one of the reasons
why MNS database is very popular for
training purposes initially when people
want to learn about deep learning and
tensorflow this is the database that is
used and it has a collection of 70 000
handwritten digits
a large part of them are for training
then you have tests just like in any
machine learning process and then you
have validation and all of them are
labeled so you have the images and their
label and these images they look
somewhat like this so they are
handwritten images collected from a lot
of individuals people have these are
samples written by human beings they
have handwritten these numbers these
numbers going from zero to nine so
people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is MNS
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our tensorflow is we
will feed this data especially the
training data along with the label
information and the data is basically
these images are stored in the form of
the pixel information as we have seen in
one of the previous slides all the
images are nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called softmax
and for Simplicity what we will do is we
will flatten these pixels so instead of
taking them in a two dimensional
arrangement we just flatten them out so
for example it starts from here it is a
28 by 28 so there are 7484 pixels so
pixel number one starts here it goes all
the way up to 28 then 29 starts there
and goes up to 56 and so on and the
pixel number 784 is here so we take all
these pixels flatten them out and feed
them like one single line into our
neural network and this is a what is
known as a soft Max layer what it does
is once it is trained it will be able to
identify what digit this is so there are
in this output layer there are 10
neurons each signifying a digit and at
any given point of time when you feed an
image only one of these 10 neurons gets
activated
so for example if this is strained
properly and if you feed a number nine
like this then this particular neuron
gets activated so you get an output from
this neuron let me just use a pen or a
laser to show you here okay so you're
feeding the number nine let's say this
has been trained and now if you're
feeding a number nine this will get
activated now let's say you feed one to
the trained Network then this neuron
will get activated if you feed two this
neuron will get activated and so on I
hope you get the idea so this is one
type of a neural network or an
activation function known as soft Max
layer so that's what we will be using
here this is one of the simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding so this is
how the code would look we will go into
our lab environment in the cloud and we
will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
let me run you through briefly here and
then we will go into the Jupiter
notebook where the actual code is and we
will run that as well so as a first step
first of all we are using python here
and that's why the syntax of the
language is Python and the first step is
to import the tensorflow library so and
we do this by using this line of code
saying import tensorflow as TF TF is
just for convenience so you can name
give any name and once you do this TF is
tensorflow is available as an object in
the name of TF and then you can run its
methods and accesses its attributes and
so on and so forth and MNS database is
actually an integral part of tensorflow
and that's again another reason why we
as a first step we always use this
example mnist database example so you
just simply import mnist database as
well using this line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
let me just use pen to show what exactly
it is so when you do this one hot true
what happens is each label is stored in
the form of an array of of 10 digits and
let's say the number is 8 okay so in
this case all the remaining values there
will be a bunch of zeros so this is like
array at position zero this is at
position one position two and so on and
so forth let's say this is position
seven then this is position eight that
will be 1 because our input is 8 and
again position 9 will be zero okay so
one hot encoding this one hot encoding
true will kind of load the data in such
a way that the labels are in such a way
that only one of the digits has a value
of one and that indicates So based on
which digit is one we know what is the
label so in this case the eighth
position is one therefore we know this
sample data the value is eight similarly
if you have a 2 here let's say then the
labeled information will be somewhat
like this so you have your labels so you
have this as 0 the 0th position the
first position is also zero the second
position is one because this indicates
number two and then you have third as
zero and so on okay so that is the
significance of this one hot true all
right and then we can check how the data
is uh looking by displaying the the data
and as I mentioned earlier this is
pretty much in the form of digital form
like numbers so all these are like pixel
values so you will not really see an
image in this format but there is a way
to visualize that image I will show you
in a bit and this tells you how many
images are there in each set so they're
training there are 55 000 images in
training and in the test set there are
10 000 and then validation there are
five thousand so all together there are
70 000 images all right so let's move on
and we can view the actual image by
using the matplot flip library and this
is how you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in
grayscale so the cmap is what tells in
what way we want to view it and what are
the maximum values and the minimum
values of the pixel value so these are
the Max and minimum values so of the
pixel values so maximum is 1 because
this is a scaled value so one means it
is white and 0 means it is black and in
between is it can be anywhere in between
black and white and the way to train the
model that is a certain way in which you
write your tensorflow code and the first
step is to create some placeholders and
then you create a model in this case we
will use the softmax model one of the
simplest ones and placeholders are
primarily to get the data from outside
into the neural network so this is a
very common mechanism that is used and
then of course you will have variables
which are your remember these are your
weights and biases so for in our case
there are 10 neurons and each neuron
actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also resists all the
700 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are this is a matrix of 784 values for
each of the neurons and so it is like a
10 by 784 Matrix which because there are
10 neurons and similarly there are
biases now remember I mentioned biases
only one per neuron so it is not one per
input unlike the weights so therefore
there are only 10 biases because there
are only 10 neurons in this case so that
is what we are creating a variable for
biases so this is something little new
in tensorflow you will see unlike our
regular programming languages where
everything is a variable here the
variables can be of three different
types you have placeholders which are
primarily used for feeding data you have
variables which can change during the
course of computation and then a third
type which is not shown here are
constant so these are like fixed numbers
all right so in a regular programming
language you may have everything has
variables or at the most variables and
constants but in tensorflow you have
three different types placeholders
variables and constants and then you
create what is known as a graph so
tensorflow programming consists of
graphs and tensors as I mentioned
earlier so this can be considered
ultimately as a tensor and then the
graph tells how to execute the whole
implementation so that the execution is
stored in the form of a graph and in
this case what we are doing is we are
doing a multiplication TF you remember
this TF was created as a tensorflow
object here one more level one more so
TF is available here now tensorflow has
what is known as a matrix multiplication
or maximal function so that is what is
being used here in this case so we are
using the matrix multiplication of
tensorflow so that you multiply your
input values x with W right this is what
we were doing x w plus b you're just
adding B and this is in very similar to
one of the earlier slides where we saw
Sigma x i w i so that's what we are
doing here matrix multiplication is
multiplying all the input values with
the corresponding weights and then
adding the bias so that is the graph we
created and then we need to Define what
is our loss function and what is our
Optimizer so in this case is we again
use the tensorflows apis so TF dot NN
softmax cross entropy with Logics is the
API that we will use and reduce mean is
what is like the mechanism whereby which
says that you reduce the error and
Optimizer for doing detection of the
error what Optimizer are we using so we
are using gradient descent Optimizer we
discussed about this in couple of slides
earlier and for that you need to specify
the learning rate you remember we saw
that there was a slide somewhat like
this and then you define what should be
the learning rate how fast you need to
come down that is the learning rate and
this again needs to be tested and tried
and to find out the optimum level of
this learning rate it shouldn't be very
high in which case it will not converge
or shouldn't be very low because it will
in that case it will take very long so
you define the optimizer and then you
call the method minimize for that
Optimizer and that will kick start the
training process and so far we've been
creating the graph and in order to
actually execute that graph we create
what is known as a session and then we
run that session and once the training
is completed we specify how many times
how many iterations we wanted to run so
for example in this case we are saying
Thousand Steps so that is a exit
strategy in a way so you specify the
exit condition so training will run for
thousand iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques shown here
so let us get into the code quickly and
see how it works so this is our Cloud
environment now you can install
tensorflow on your local machine as well
I'm showing this demo on our existing
Cloud but you can also install all
tensorflow on your local machine and
there is a separate video on how to set
up your tensorflow environment you can
watch that if you want to install your
local environment or you can go for
other any cloud service like for example
Google Cloud Amazon or Cloud Labs any of
these you can use and run and try the
code okay so it has got started
with the login
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial code
and this is our tensorflow environment
and so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
Code walkthrough uh in the slides as
well now you will see the actual code in
action so the first thing we need to do
is import tensorflow and then we will
import the data and we need to adjust
the data in such a way that the
one hot is encoding is set to True one
hot encoding right as I explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately and if we
just check what is the type of the data
so you can see that this is a data sets
python data sets and if we
check the number of images the way it
looks so this is how it looks it is an
array of type float32
similarly
the number if you want to see what is
the number of
cleaning images there are 55 000 and
there are test images 10 000 and then
validation images 5000. now let's take a
quick look at the data itself
visualization so we will use
um matplotlib for this
and if we take a look at the shape now
shape gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or or the arrays if you will so
in this case the training data set if we
see the size of the training data set
using the method shape it says there are
55 000 and 50 000 by 784 so remember the
784 is nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into
28 so that is equal to 784 so that's
what it is showing now we can take just
one image and just see what is the the
first image and see what is the shape so
again size obviously it is only 784
similarly you can look at the image
itself the data of the first image
itself so this is how it it shows a
large part of it will probably be zeros
because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is blank so that's why you
will mostly see Zero say that it is
black or white but then there are these
values are so the values are actually
they are scaled so their values are
between 0 and 1. okay so this is what
you're seeing so certain locations there
are some values and then other locations
there are zeros
so that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image if you
want to view it this is how you view it
so you create like do this reshape and
matplotlab has this
feature to show you these images so we
will actually use the function called I
am show and then if you pass this
parameters appropriately you will be
able to see the different images now I
can change the values in this position
so which image we are looking at right
so we can say
if I want to see what is there in maybe
right so
5000 has three similarly you can just
say five what is in five
five as eight
what is in 50.
again H so basically by the way if
you're wondering uh how I am executing
this code shift enter in case you are
not familiar with jupyter notebooks
shift enter is how you execute each cell
individual cell and if you want to
execute the entire program you can go
here and say run all
so that is how
this score gets executed and here again
we can check what is the maximum value
and what is the minimum value of this
pixel values as I mentioned this is it
is scaled so therefore it is between the
values lie between 1 and 0. now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create one
placeholder and we create two variables
which is for the weights and biases
these two variables are actually
matrices so each variable has 784 by 10
chill values okay so one for this 10 is
for each neuron there are 10 neurons and
784 is for the pixel values inputs that
are given which is 28 into 28. and the
biases as I mentioned one for each
neuron so there will be 10 biases they
are stored in a variable by the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of X into W and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize the
error so let me just execute I think
this code is executed then we Define
what is our the Y value is basically the
label value so this is another
placeholder we had X as one placeholder
and white underscore true as a second
placeholder and this will have values in
the form of uh 10 digit 10 digit arrays
and since we set one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the label for that particular
number all right then we have cross
entropy which is nothing but the loss
loss function and we have the optimizer
we have chosen gradient descent as our
Optimizer that the training process
itself so the training process is
nothing but to minimize the cross
entropy which is again nothing but the
loss function so we Define all of this
in the form of a graph so the up to here
remember what we have done is we have
not exactly executed any tensorflow code
till now we are just preparing the graph
the execution plan that's how the
tensorflow code works so the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from how we
normally do programming so even with
people with programming experience may
find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs quite a bit
of practice so you may want to view this
video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow because the way
tensorflow programming is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who let's say
have done maybe spark programming to
some extent will be able to easily
understand this but even in spark the
the programming the code it's self is
pretty straightforward behind the scenes
the execution happens slightly
differently but in tensorflow even the
code has to be written in a completely
different way so the code doesn't get
executed in the same way as you have
written so that that's something you
need to understand and a little bit of
practices needed for this so so far what
we have done up to here is creating the
variables and feeding the variables and
or rather not feeding but setting up the
variables and the graph that's all
defining maybe the what kind of a
network you want to use for example we
want to use a soft Max and so on so you
have created the variables how to load
the data loaded the data viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tensorflow now
the next step is the execution in
tensorflow so the first step for doing
any execution intense the flow is to
initialize the variable so anytime you
have any variables defined in your code
you have to run this piece of code
always so you need to basically create
what is known as a node for initializing
so this is a node you still are not yet
executing anything here you just created
a node for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code in tensorflow and in
order to execute the code what you will
need is a session tensorflow session so
TF dot session will give you a session
and there are a couple of different ways
in which you can do this but one of the
most common methods of doing this is
with what is known as a with Loop so you
have a width TF dot session as says and
with the colon here and this is like a
block starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and this session is valid till this
block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this with block this
is known as a width block so with TF dot
session as says you say SAS Dot run in
it now says dot run will execute a node
that is specified here so for example
here we are saying says dot run says is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying TF dot
session so an instance of the session
gets created and we are calling that SAS
and then we run
a node within that one of the nodes in
the graph so one of the nodes here is
init so we say run that particular node
and that is when the initialization of
the variables happens now what this does
is if you have any variables in your
code in our case we have W is a variable
and B is a variable so any variables
that we created you have to run this
code you have to run the initialization
of these variables otherwise you will
get an error okay so that is the that's
what this is doing then V within this
with block we specify a for Loop and we
are saying we want the system to iterate
for thousand steps and perform the
training
that's what this for Loop does run
training for thousand iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching the data or these images
remember there are about 50 000 images
but it cannot get all the images in one
shot because it will take up a lot of
memory and performance issues will be
there so this is a very common way of
Performing deep learning training you
always do in batches so we have maybe 50
000 images but you always do it in
batches of 100 or maybe 500 depending on
the size of your system and so on and so
forth so in this case we are saying okay
get me 100 images at a time and get me
only the training images remember we use
only the training data for training
purpose and then we use test data for
test purpose you must be familiar with
machine learning so you must be aware of
this but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and You observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next batch
right so this is the advantage of using
MNS database because they have provided
some very nice helper functions which
are readily available otherwise this
activity itself we would have had to
write a piece of code to fetch this data
in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using MNS database and that's why we
use this for the initial learning phase
okay so when we say fetch what it will
do is it will fetch the images into X
and the labels into Y and then you use
this batch of 100 images and you run the
training so SAS dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the new
Network and thereby all the W's and B's
get updated till it reaches thousand
iterations in this case the exit
criteria is thousand but you can also
specify probably accuracy rate or
something like that for the as an exit
criteria so here it is it just says that
okay this particular image was wrongly
predicted so you need to update your
weights and biases that's the feedback
given to each neuron and that is run for
1000 iterations and typically by the end
of this thousand iterations the model
would have learned to recognize these
handwritten images obviously it will not
be 100 accurate okay so once that is
done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done you then
test the accuracy of these models by
using the test data set right so this is
what we are trying to do here the code
may appear a little complicated because
if you're seeing this for the first time
you need to understand uh the various
methods of tensorflow and so on but it
is basically comparing the output with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you are trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not TF dot equal right and
how many of them are correct and so on
and so forth and based on that the
accuracy is calculated as well so this
is the accuracy and that is what we are
trying to see how accurate the model is
in predicting these numbers or these
digits okay so let us run this this
entire thing is in one cell so we will
have to just run it in one shot it may
take a little while let us see and uh
not bad so it has finished the thousand
iterations and what we see here as an
output is the accuracy so we see that
the accuracy of this model is around 91
percent okay now which is pretty good
for such a short exercise within such a
short time we got 90 percent accuracy
however in real life this is probably
not sufficient so there are other ways
in to increase the accuracy we will see
probably in some of the later tutorials
how to improve this accuracy how to
change maybe the hyper parameters like
number of neurons or number of layers
and so on and so forth and so that this
accuracy can be increased Beyond 90
percent hello and welcome to the
tensorflow object detection API tutorial
in this video I will walk you through
the tensorflow code to perform object
detection in a video so let's get
started this part is basically you're
importing all the libraries we need a
lot of these libraries for example numpy
we need image i o date time and fill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some parts for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and a
few more Imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if I run this code once
again it will go away all right and then
here onwards we do the model preparation
what we're going to do is we are going
to use an existing neural network model
so we are not going to chain a new one
because that will will take a long time
and it needs a lot of computation
resources and so on and it is really not
required there are already models that
have been trained and in this case it is
the SSD with mobile net that's the model
that we are going to use and this model
is trained to detect objects and it is
readily available as open source so we
can actually use this and if you want to
use other models there are a few more
models available so you can click on
this link here and let me just take you
there there are a few more models but we
have chosen this particular one because
this is faster it may not be very
accurate but that is one of the faster
models but on this link you will see a
lot of other models that are readily
available these are trained models some
of them would take a little longer but
they may be more accurate and so on so
you can probably play around with these
other models okay so we will be using
that model so this piece of code this
line is basically importing that model
and this is also known as a frozen model
the term we use is frozen model so we
import download and import that and then
we will actually use that model in our
code right so these two cells we have
downloaded and import the model and then
once it is available locally we will
then load this into our program all
right so we are loading this into memory
and the the you need to perform a couple
of additional steps which is basically
we need to to map the numbers to text as
you may be aware when we actually build
the model and when we run predictions
the model will not give a text the
output of the model is usually a number
so we need to map that to a text so for
example if the network predicts that the
output is 5 we know that 5 means it is
an airplane things like that so this
mapping is done in this next cell all
right so let's keep moving and then we
have a helper code which will basically
load the data or load the images and
transform into lump IRS this is also
used in doing object detection in images
so we are actually going to reuse
because video is nothing but it consists
of frames which in turn are images so we
are going to pretty much use reuse the
same code which we use for doing object
detection in images so this is where the
actual detection starts so here this is
the path for where the images are stored
so this is once again we are reusing the
code which we wrote for detecting
objects in an image so this is the path
where the images were stored and this is
the extension and this was done for
about two or three images so we will
continue to use this and we go down I'll
skip this section so this is the cell
where we are actually loading the video
and converting it into frames and then
using frame by frame we are detecting
the objects in the image so in this code
what we are doing basically is there are
a few lines of code what they do is
basically once they find an object a box
will be drawn around those each of those
objects and the input file the name of
the input video file is traffic it is
the extension is MP4 and we have this
video reader it's a excellent object
which is basically part of this class
called image i o so we can read and
write videos using that and the video
that we are going to use is traffic dot
MP4 you can use any mp4 file but in our
case I picked up video which has like
cars so let me just show you so this is
in this object detection folder I have
this mp4 file I'll just quickly predict
this video it's a little slow yeah okay
so here we go this is the video it's a
short one relatively small video so that
for this particular demo and what it
will do is once we run our code it will
detect each of these cars and it will
annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video I
think I have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and you know actually we will be reading
a video file but then we will be
analyzing it frame by frame and we will
be reading them at 10 frames per second
that is the rate we are mentioning here
and analyzing it and then annotating and
then writing it back so you will see
that we will have a video file named
something like this traffic underscore
annotated and we will see the annotated
video so let's go back and run through
this piece of code and then we will come
back and see the annotated video this
might take a little while so I will
pause the video after running this
particular cell and then come back to
show you the results all right so let's
go ahead and run it so it is running now
and it is also important that at the end
you close the video writer so that it is
similar to a file pointer when you open
a file you should also make sure you
close it so that it doesn't of the
resources so it's very similar at the
end of it the last piece or last line of
code should be video underscore writer
Dot close all right so I'll pause and
then I'll come back okay so I will see
you in a little bit all right so now as
you can see here the processing is done
The Hourglass has disappeared that means
the video has been processed so let's go
back and check the annotated video we'll
go back to my file manager so this was
the original
traffic.mp4 and now you have here
traffic underscore annotated MP4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here it has got each of these
cars getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car 70
let us allow it to go a little further
it detects something on top what is that
truck okay so I think because of the
board on top it somehow thinks there is
a truck let's play some more and see if
it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us here so
this is a car and it has confidence
level of 69 percent okay this is again a
car all right so basically till the end
it goes and detects each and every car
that is passing by now we can quickly
repeat this process for another video
let me just show you the other video
which is a cat again there is uh this
cat is not really moving or anything but
it is just standing there staring and
moving a little slowly and our
application will our network will detect
that this is a cat and even when the cat
moves a little bit in the other
direction it'll continue to detect and
show that it is a cat Okay so yeah so
this is our original video is let's go
ahead and change our code to analyze
this one and see if it detects how
Network detects this cat close this here
we go and go back to my code all we need
to do is change this traffic to cat the
extension it will automatically pick up
because it is given here and then it
will run through so very quickly once
again what it is doing is this video
reader video underscore reader has a
neat little feature or interface whereby
you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you are in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works out is very easy to handle this
all right so now let's once again run
just this cell rest of the stuff Remains
the Same so I will run this cell again
it will take a little while so the r
classes come back I will pause and then
come back in a little while all right so
the processing is done let's go and
check the annotated video go here so we
have get annotated dot MP4 let's play
this all right so you can see here it is
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like I detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here let's see
yes so what is it trying to show here
it's too small not able to see but it is
trying to detect something I think it is
saying it is a car I don't know all
right okay so in this video there's only
pretty much only one object which is the
cat and uh let's wait for some time and
see if it continues to detect it when
the cat turns around and moves as well
just in a little bit that's going to
happen and we will see there we go and
in spite of turning the other way I
think our network is able to detect that
it is a cat so let me freeze and then
show here it is actually still continues
to detect it as a cat all right so
that's pretty much it I think that's the
only object that it detects in this
particular video okay so close this so
that's pretty much it thank you very
much for watching this video and you
have a great day and in case you have
any questions please put them below the
video here and we will be more than
happy to get back to you and make sure
you put your email ID so that we can
contact you in case you have any
questions thank you once again bye-bye
today we're going to be covering the
conflict solutional neural network
tutorial do you know how deep learning
recognizes the objects in an image and
really this particular neural network is
how image recognition works is very
Central one of the biggest building
blocks for image recognition it does it
using convolution neural network and we
over here we have the basic picture of a
hummingbird pixels of an image fed as
input you have your input layer coming
in so it takes that graphic and puts it
into the input layer you have all your
hidden layers and then you have your
output layer and your output layer one
of those is going to light up and say oh
it's a bird we're going to go into depth
we're going to actually go back and
forth on this a number of times today so
if you're not catching all the image
don't worry we're going to get into the
details so we have our input layer
accepts the pixels of the image as input
in the form of arrays and you can see up
here where they've actually labeled each
block of the bird in different arrays so
we'll dive into deep as to how that
looks like and how those matrixes are
set up your hidden layer carry out
feature extract action by performing
certain calculations and manipulation so
this is the part that kind of
reorganizes that picture multiple ways
until we get some data that's easy to
read for the neural network this layer
uses a matrix filter and performs
convolution operation to detect patterns
in the image and if you remember that
convolution means to coil or to twist so
we're going to twist the data around and
alter it and use that operation to
detect a new pattern there are multiple
hidden layers like convolution layer Rel
U is how that is pronounced when that's
the rectified linear unit that has to do
with the activation function that's used
pooling layer also uses multiple filters
to detect edges corners eyes feathers
beak Etc and just like the term says
pooling is pulling information together
and we'll look into that a lot closer
here so if you're if it's a little
confusing now we'll dig in deep and try
to get you squared away with that and
then finally there is a fully connected
layer that identifies the object in the
image so we have these different layers
coming through in the hidden layers and
they come into the final area and that's
where we have a one node or one neural
network entity that lights up that says
it's a bird what's in it for you we're
going to cover an introduction to the
CNN what is convolution neural network
how CNN recognizes images we're going to
dig deeper into that and really look at
the individual layers in the
convolutional neural network and finally
we do a use case implementation using
the CNN we'll begin our introduction to
the CNN by introducing the pioneer of
convolutional neural network Jan lekun
he was the director of Facebook AI
research group built the first
convolutional neural network called
Lynette in 1988 so these have been
around for a while and have had a chance
to mature over the years it was used for
character recognition tasks like reading
zip code digits imagine processing mail
and automating that process CNN is a
feed-forward neural network that is
generally used to analyze visual images
by producing data with a grid-like
topology a CNN is also known as a
convenect and very key to this is we are
looking at images that was what this was
designed for and you'll see the
different layers as we dig in Mirror
some of the other some of them are
actually now used since we're using
tensorflow and Karas in our code later
on you'll see that some of those layers
appear in a lot of your other neural
network Frameworks but in this case this
is very Central to processing images and
doing so in a variety that captures
multiple images and really drills down
into their different features in this
example here you see flowers of two
varieties orchid in a rows I think the
Orchid is much more dainty and beautiful
and the rose smells quite beautiful I
have a couple roast bushes in my yard
they go into the input layer that data
is in sent to all the different nodes in
the next layer one of the Hidden layers
based on its different weights and it's
set up it then comes out and gives those
a new value those values then are
multiplied by their weights and go to
the next hidden layer and so on and then
you have the output layer and one of
those nodes comes out and says it's an
orchid and the other one comes out and
says it's a rose depending on how it was
well it was trained what separates the
CNN or the convolutional neural network
from other neural networks is a
convolutional operation forms the basis
of any convolutional neural network in a
CNN every image is represented in the
form of arrays of pixel values so here
we have a real image of the digit 8.
that then gets put on to its pixel
values represented in the form of an
array in this case you have a
two-dimensional array and then you can
see in the final in form we transform
the digit a into its representational
form of pixels of zeros in one where the
ones represent in this case the black
part of the eight and the zeros
represent the white background to
understand the
cushion neural network or how that
convolutional operation Works we're
going to take a side step and look at
matrixes in this case we're going to
simplify it and we're going to take two
matrices A and B of one dimension now
kind of separate this from your thinking
as we learned that you want to focus
just on the Matrix aspect of and then
we'll bring that back together and see
what that looks like when we put the
pieces for the convolutional operation
here we've set up two arrays we have in
this case they're a single Dimension
Matrix and we have a equals five three
seven five nine seven and we have b
equals one two three so in the
convolution as it comes in there's going
to look at these two and we're going to
start by doing multiplying them a times
B and so we multiply the arrays element
wise and we get five six six where five
is the five times one six is three times
two and then the other six is two times
three and since the two arrays aren't
the same size they're not the same setup
we're going to just truncate the first
one and we're going to look at the
second array multiplied just by the
first three elements of the first array
now that's going to be a little
confusing remember a computer gets to
repeat these processes hundreds of times
so we're not going to just forget those
other numbers later on we'll see we'll
bring those back in and then we have the
sum of the product in this case 5 plus 6
plus 6 equals 17. so in our a times B
our very first digit in that Matrix of a
times B is 17. and if you remember I
said we're not going to forget the other
digits so we now have 3 2 5 we move one
set over and we take three two five and
we multiply that times B and you'll see
that 3 times 1 is 3 2 times 2 is 4 and
so on and so on WE sum it up so now we
have the second digit of our a times B
product in The Matrix and we continue on
with that same thing so on and so on so
then we would go from 375 to 759 to 597.
this short Matrix that we have for a
we've now covered all the different
entities in a that match three different
levels of B now in a little bit we're
going to cover where we use this math at
this multiplying of matrixes and how
that works but it's important to
understand that we're going through the
Matrix of multiplying the different
parts to it to match the smaller Matrix
with the larger Matrix I know a lot of
people get lost at is you know what's
going on here with these matrixes uh oh
scary math not really that scary when
you break it down we're looking at a
section of a and we're comparing it to B
so when you break that down your mind
like that you realize okay so I'm just
taking these two matrixes and comparing
them and I'm bringing the value down
into one Matrix a times B we're reducing
that information in a way that will help
the computer see different aspects let's
go ahead and flip over again back to our
images here we are back to our images
talking about going to the most basic
two-dimensional image you can get to
consider the following two images the
image for the symbol backslash when you
press the backslash the above image is
processed and you can see there for the
image for the forward slash is the
opposite so we click the forward slash
button that flips uh very basic we have
four pixels going in can't get any more
basic than that here we have a little
bit more complicated picture we take a
real image of a smiley face
then we represent that in the form of
black and white pixels so if this was an
image in the computer it's black and
white and like we saw before we convert
this into the zeros in one so where the
other one would have just been a matrix
of just four dots now we have a
significantly larger image coming in so
don't worry we're going to bring this
all together here in just a little bit
layers in convolutional neural network
when we're looking at this we have our
convolution layer and that really is the
central aspect of processing images and
the convolutional neural network that's
why we have it and then that's going to
be feeding in and you have your relu
layer which is you know as we talked
about the rectified linear unit we'll
talk about that a little bit later the
Rel U is in how it Act is how that layer
is activated is the math behind it what
makes the neurons fire you'll see that
in a lot of other neural networks when
you're using it just by itself is for
processing smaller amounts of data where
you use the atom activation feature for
large data coming in now because we're
processing small amounts of data in each
image the relu layer works great you
have your pooling layer that's where
you're pulling the data together pooling
is a neural network term it's very
commonly used I like to use the term
reduce so if you're coming from the map
and reduce side you'll see that we're
mapping all this data through all these
networks and then we're going to reduce
it we're going to pull it together and
then finally we have the fully connected
layer that's where our output is going
to come out so we have started to look
at matrixes we've started to look at the
convolutional layer and where it fits in
and everything we've taken a look at
images so we're going to focus more on
the convolution layer since this is a
convolutional neural network a
convolution layer has a number of
filters and perform convolution
operation every image is considered as a
matrix of pixel values consider the
following 5x5 image whose pixel values
are only zero and one now obviously when
we're dealing with color there's all
kinds of things that come in on color
processing but we want to keep it simple
and just keep it black and white and so
we have our image pixels so we're
sliding the filter Matrix over the image
and Computing the dot product to detect
the patterns it here you're going to ask
where does this filter come from this is
a bit confusing because the filter is
going to be derived later on we build
the filters when we program or train our
model so you don't need to worry what
the filter actually is but you do need
to understand how a convolution layer
works is what is the filter doing filter
and you'll have many filters you don't
have just one filter you'll have lots of
filters that are going to look for
different aspects and so the filter
might be looking for just edges it might
be looking for different parts we'll
cover that a little bit more detail in a
minute right now we're just focusing on
how the filter works as a matrix
remember earlier we talked about
multiplying matrixes together and here
we have our two dimensional Matrix and
you can see we take the filter and we
multiply it in the upper left image and
you can see right here one times one one
times zero one times one we multiply
those all together then sum them and we
end up with the convolved feature of
four you're going to take that and
sliding the filter Matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
patterns so we're just going to slide
this over we're going to predict the
first one and slide it over one notch
predict the second one and so on and so
on all the way through until we have a
new Matrix and this Matrix which is the
same size as the filter has reduced the
image and whatever filter whatever
that's filtering out is going to be
looking at just those features reduced
down to a smaller Matrix so once the
feature maps are extracted the next step
is to move them to the relu layer so the
Rel you layer The Next Step first is
going to perform an element wise
operation so each of those Maps coming
in if there's negative pixels so it says
all the negative pixels to zero and you
can see this nice graph where it just
zeros out the negatives and then you
have a value that goes from 0 up to
whatever value is coming out of the
Matrix this introduces non-linearity to
the network so up until now we have a we
say linearity we're talking about the
fact the feature has a value so it's a
linear feature this feature came up and
has let's say the feature is the edge of
the beak
or the backslash that we saw um you'll
look at that and say okay this feature
has a value from negative 10 to 10 in
this case if it was one it'd say yeah
this might be a beak it might not might
be an edge right there a minus five
means no we're not even going to look at
it to zero and so we end up with an
output and the output takes all these
features all these filtered features
remember we're not just running one
filter on this we're running a number of
filters on this image and so we end up
with a rectified feature map that is
looking at just the features coming
through and how they weigh in from our
filters so here we have an input of a
looks like a toucan bird
very exotic looking real image is
scanned in multiple convolution and the
relu layers for locating features and
you can see up here is turn it into a
black and white image and in this case
we're looking in the upper right hand
corner for a feature and that box scans
over a lot of times it doesn't scan one
pixel at a time a lot of times it will
Skip by two or three or four pixels to
speed up the process that's one of the
ways you can compensate if you don't
have enough resources on your
computation for large images and it's
not just one filter it slowly goes
across the image you have multiple
filters have been programmed in there so
you're looking at a lot of different
filters going over the different aspects
of the image and just sliding across
there and forming a new Matrix one more
aspect to note about the relu layer is
we're not just having one relu coming in
so not only do we have multiple features
going through but we're generating
multiple relu layers for locating the
features it's very important to note you
know so we have a quite a bundle we have
multiple filters multiple railue which
brings us to the next step forward
propagation now we're going to look at
the pooling layer the rectified feature
map now goes through a pooling layer
pooling is a down sampling operation
that reduces the dimensionality of the
feature map that's all we're trying to
do we're trying to take a huge amount of
information and reduce it down to a
single answer this is a specific kind of
bird this is an iris this is a rose so
you have a rectified feature map and you
see here we have a rectified feature map
coming in we set the max pooling with a
two by two filters and a stride of Two
And if you remember correctly I talked
about not going one pixel at a time well
that's where the stride comes in we end
up with a two by two pooled feature map
but instead of moving one over each time
and looking at every possible
combination we skip we skip a few there
we go by two we skip every other pixel
and we just do every other one and this
reduces our rectified feature map which
as you can see over over here 16 by 16
to a four by four so we're continually
trying to filter and reduce our data so
that we can get to something we can
manage and over here you see that we
have the max 3 4 1 and 2 and in the max
pooling we're looking for the max value
a little bit different than what we were
looking at before so coming from the
rectified feature we're now finding the
max value and then we're pulling those
features together so instead of think of
this as image of the map think of this
as how valuable is a feature in that
area how much of a feature value do we
have we just want to find the best or
the maximum feature for that area they
might have that one piece of the filter
of the beak said oh I see a one in this
beak in this image and then it skips
over and says I see a 3 in this image
and says oh this one is rated as a four
we don't want to sum it together because
then you know you might have like five
ones and it'll say ah five but you might
have four zeros in one ten and that 10
says well this is definitely a beak
where the 1 ones will say probably not a
beak a little strange analogy since
we're looking at a bird but you can see
how that pulled feature map comes down
and we're just looking for the max value
in each one of those matrixes pooling
layer uses different filters to identify
different parts of the image like edges
corners body feathers eyes beak Etc I
know I focus mainly on the beak but
obviously each feature could be a
different part of the bird coming in so
let's take a look at what that looks
like a structure of a convolution neural
network so far this is where we're at
right now we have our input image coming
in and then we use our filters and
there's multiple filters on there that
are being developed to kind of twist and
change that data and so we multiply the
matrixes we take that little filter
maybe it's a two by two we multiply it
by each piece of the image and if we
step two then it's every other piece of
the image that generates multiple
convolution layers so we have a number
of convolution layers we have set up in
there is looking at that day data we
then take those convolution layers we
run them through the relu setup and then
once we've done through the religious
setup and we have multiple values going
on multiple layers that are relative
then we're going to take those multiple
layers and we're going to be pooling
them so now we have the pooling layers
or multiple poolings going on up until
this point we're dealing with sometimes
it's multiple Dimensions you can have
three dimensions some strange data
setups that aren't doing images but
looking at other things they can have
four five six seven dimensions so right
now we're looking at 2D image Dimensions
coming in into the pooling layer so the
next step is we want to reduce those
Dimensions or flatten them so flattening
flattening is a process of converting
all of the resultant two-dimensional
arrays from pooled feature map into a
single long continuous linear Vector so
over here you see where we have a pooled
feature map maybe that's the bird wing
and it has values 6847 and we want to
just flatten this out and turn it into
6847 or a single linear vector and we
find out that not only do you do each of
the pooled feature Maps we do all of
them into one long linear Vector so now
we've gone through our convolutional
neural network part and we have the
input layer into the next setup all
we've done is taken all those different
pooling layers and we've flattened them
out and combine them into a single
linear Vector going in so after we've
done the flattening we have just a quick
recap because we've covered so much so
it's important to go back and take a
look at each of the steps we've gone
through the structure of the network so
far is we have our convolution where we
twist it and we filter it and multiply
the matrixes we end up with our
convolutional layer which uses the relu
to figure out the values going out into
the pooling because you have numerous
convolution layers that then create
numerous pooling layers pooling that
data together which is the max value
which one we want to send forward we
want to send the best value and then
we're going to take all of that from
each of the pooling layers and we're
going to flatten it and we're going to
combine them into a single input going
into the final layer once you get to
that step you might be looking at that
going boy that looks like the normal
Intuit to most neural network station
using the CNN we'll be using the cfar10
data set from Canadian Institute for
advanced research for classifying images
across 10 categories Unfortunately they
don't let me know whether it's going to
be a toucan or some other kind of bird
but we do get to find out whether it can
categorize between a ship a frog deer
bird airplane automobile cat dog horse
truck so that's a lot of fun and if
you're looking at anything in the news
at all of our automated cars and
everything else you can see where this
kind of processing is so important in
today's world and very Cutting Edge as
far as what's coming out in the
commercial deployment I mean this is
really cool stuff we're starting to see
this just about everywhere in Industry
so great time to be playing with this
and figuring it all out let's go ahead
and dive into the code and see what that
looks like when we're actually writing
our script before we go on let's do one
more quick look at what we have here
let's just take a look at data batch one
keys and remember in Jupiter notebook I
can get by with not doing the print
statement if I put a variable down there
it'll just display the variable and you
can see in our data batch one for the
keys since this is a dictionary we have
the batch one label data and file names
so you can actually see how it's broken
up in our data set so for the next step
or step four as we're calling it uh we
want to display the image using matplot
Library there's many ways to display the
images you could even well there's other
ways to drill into it but matplot
library is really good for this and
we'll also look at our first reshape
setup or shaping the data so you can
have a little glimpse into what that
means so we're going to start by
importing our matplot and of course
since I am doing jupyter notebook I need
to do the matplot inline command so it
shows up on my page so here we go we're
going to import matplot library.pi plot
is PLT and if you remember matplot
Library the pi AI plot is like a canvas
that we paint stuff on to and there's my
percentage sign matplot library in line
so it's going to show up in my notebook
and then of course we're going to import
numpy as NP for our numbers python array
setup and let's go ahead and set x
equals to data batch one so this will
pull in all the data going into the x
value and then because this is just a
long stream of binary data we need to go
a little bit of reshaping so in here we
have to go ahead and reshape the data we
have 10 000 images okay that looks
correct and this is kind of an
interesting thing it took me a little
bit to I had to go research this myself
to figure out what's going on with this
data and what it is is it's a 32 by 32
picture and let me do this let me go
ahead and do a drawing pad on here so we
have 32 bits by 32 bits and it's in
color so there's three bits of color now
I don't know why the data is
particularly like this I had probably do
with how they originally encoded it but
most pictures put the three afterward so
what we're doing here is we're going to
take the shape we're going to take the
data which is just a long stream of
information and we're going to break it
up into 10 000 pieces and those 10 000
pieces then are broken into three pieces
each and those three pieces then are 32
by 32. you could look at this like an
old-fashioned projector where they have
the red screen or the red projector the
blue projector and the green projector
and they add them all together and each
one of those is a 32 by 32 bit so that's
probably how this was originally
formatted was in that kind of Ideal
things have changed so we're going to
transpose it and we're going to take the
3 which was here and we're going to put
it at the end so the first part is
reshaping the data from a single line of
bit data or whatever format it is into
ten thousand by 3 by 32 by 32 and then
we're going to transpose the color
factor to the last place so it's the
image then the 30 32 by 32 in the middle
that's this part right here and then
finally we're going to take this which
is three bits of data and put it at the
end so it's more like we do we process
images now and then as type this is
really important that we're going to use
an integer 8. you can come in here and
you'll see a lot of these they'll try to
do this with a float or a float 64 which
you got to remember though is a float
uses a lot of memory so once you switch
this into something that's not integer 8
which goes up to 128 you are just gonna
the the amount of ram let me just put
that in here it's going to go way up the
amount of ram that it loads so you want
to go ahead and use this you can try the
other ones and see what happens if you
have a lot of RAM on your computer but
for this exercise this will work just
fine and let's go ahead and take that
and run this so now our X variable is
all loaded and it has all the images in
it from the batch one data batch one and
just the show we are talking about with
the as type on there if we go ahead and
take x0 and just look for its max value
let me go ahead and run that you'll see
it doesn't oops I said 128 is 255. uh
ELC doesn't go over 255 because it's
basically an ASCII character is what
we're keeping that down to we're keeping
those values down so they're only 255 0
to 255 versus uh float value which would
bring this up exponentially in size and
since we're using the matplot library we
can do oops that's not what I wanted
can take our canvas and just do a PLT
dot I am for image show and let's just
take a look at what x0 looks like and it
comes in I'm not sure what that is but
you can see it's a very low grade image
broken down to the minimal pixels on
there and if we did the same thing oh
Let's do let's see what one looks like
hopefully it's a little easier to see
run on there not enter let's hit the run
on that
is probably a semi truck that's a good
guess on there and I can just go back up
here instead of typing the same line in
over and over and we'll look at three
that looks like a dump truck unloading
and so on you can do any of the 10 000
images we can just jump to 55 looks like
some kind of animal looking at us there
probably a dog and just for fun let's do
just one more uh run on there and we can
see a nice car for our image number four
uh so you can see we paste through all
the different images and it's very easy
to look at them and they've been
reshaped to fit our view and what the
matplot library uses for its format so
the next step is we're going to start
creating some helper functions we'll
start by a one hot encoder to help us
we're processing the data remember that
your labels they can't just be words
they have to switch it and we use the
one hot encoder to do that and then
we'll also create a class cfar helper so
it's going to have a knit and a setup
for the images and then finally we'll go
ahead and run that code so you can see
what that looks like and then we get
into the fun part where we're actually
going to start creating our model our
actual neural network model so let's
start by creating our one hot encoder
we're going to create our own here and
it's going to return an out and we'll
have our Vector coming in and our values
equal 10. what this means is that we
have the 10 values the 10 possible
labels and remember we don't look at the
labels as a number because a car isn't
one more than a horse that'd be just
kind of bizarre to have horse equals
zero car equals one plane equals two cat
equals three so a cat plus a card equals
what so instead we create a numpy array
of zeros and there's going to be 10
values so we have a 10 different values
in there so you have zero or one one
means it's a cat zero means it's not a
cat in the next line it might be that
one means it's a car zero means it's not
a car so instead of having one output
with a value of 0 to 10 you have 10
outputs with the values of zero to one
that's what the one hot encoder is doing
here and we're going to utilize this in
code in just a minute so let's go ahead
and take a look at the next helpers we
have a few of these helper functions
we're going to build and when you're
working with a very complicated python
project dividing it up into separate
definitions and classes is very
important otherwise it just becomes
really ungainly to work with so let's go
ahead and put in our next helper which
is a class and this is a lot in this
class so we'll break it down here and
let's just start let's put a space right
in there there we go now this is a
little bit more readable at a second
space so we're going to create our class
the cipher Helper and we'll start by
initializing it now there's a lot going
on in here so let's start with the init
part
self.i equals zero that'll come in a
little bit we'll come back to that in
the lower part we want to initialize our
training batches so when we went through
this there was like a meta batch we
don't need the meta batch but we do need
the data batch one two three four five
and we do not want the testing batch in
here this is just the self all train
batches so we're going to come make an
array of all those different images and
then of course we left the test batch
out so we have our self.test batch we're
going to initialize the training images
and the training labels and also the
test images and the test labels so these
are just this is just to initialize
these variables in here then we create
another definition down here and this is
going to set up the images and let's
just take a look and see what's going on
in there now we could have all just put
this as part of the init part since this
is all just helper stuff but breaking it
up again makes it easier to read it also
makes it easier when we start executing
the different pieces to see what's going
on so that way we have a nice print
statement to say hey we're now running
this and this is what's going on in here
we're going to set up these self
training images at this point and that's
going to go to a numpy array v-stack and
in there we're going to load up uh in
this case the data for D itself all
trained batches again that points right
up to here so we're going to go through
each one of these files or each one of
these data sets because they're not a
file anymore we've brought them data
batch one points to the actual data and
so our self-training images is going to
stack them all into our into a nubby
array and then it's always nice to get
the training length and that's just the
total number of uh self-training images
in there and then we're going to take
the self training images let me switch
marker colors because I am getting a
little bit too much on the markers up
here
oops there we go bring down our marker
change
so we can see it a little better and at
this point this should look familiar
where did we see this well we wanted to
look at this above and we want to look
at the images in the matplot library we
had to reshape it so we're doing the
same thing here we're taking our self
training images and based on the
training length total number of images
because we stacked them all together so
now it's just one large file of images
we're going to take and look at it as
our our three video cameras that are
each displaying a 32 by 32 we're going
to switch that around so that now we
have each of our images that stays the
same place and then we have our 32 by 32
and then by our three our last our three
different values for the color and of
course we want to go ahead and they run
this where we say divide by 255. that
was from earlier it just brings all the
data into zero to one that's what this
is doing so we're turning this into a
zero to one array which is is all the
pictures 32 by 32 by 3 and then we're
going to take the self training labels
and we're going to pump those through
our one hot encoder we just made and
we're going to stack them together and
uh again we're converting this into an
array that goes from uh instead of
having horse equals one dog equals two
and then horse plus dog would equal
three which would be cat
no it's going to be uh you know an array
of 10 where each one is zero to one then
we want to go ahead and set up our test
images and labels and when we're doing
this you're going to see it's the same
thing we just did with the rest of them
we just change colors right here this is
no different than what we were doing up
here with our training set we're going
to stack the different images we're
going to get the length of them so we
know how many images are in there you
certainly could add them by hand but
it's nice to let the computer do it
especially if it ever changes on the
other end and you're using other data
and again we reshape them and transpose
them and we also do the one hot encoder
same thing we just did on our training
images so now our test images are in the
same format so now we have a definition
which sets up all our images in there
and then the next step is to go ahead
and batch them or next batch and let's
do another breakout here for batches
because this is really important to
understand tends to throw me for a
little Loop when I'm working with
tensorflow or Cross or a lot of these we
have our data coming in if you remember
we had like 10 000 photos let me just
put 10 000 down here we don't want to
run all 10 000 at once so we want to
break this up into batch sizes and you
also remember that we had the number of
photos in this case uh length of test or
whatever number is in there we also have
32 by 32 by 3. so when we're looking at
the batch size we want to change this
from 10 000 to a batch of in this case I
think we're going to do batches of a
hundred so we want to look at just 100
the first hundred of the photos and if
you remember we set self I equal to zero
so what we're looking at here is we're
going to create X we're going to get the
next batch from the very initialize
we've already initialized it for zero so
we're going to look at x from 0 to batch
size which we've set to 100 so just the
first hundred images and then we're
going to reshape that into uh and this
is important to let the data to know
that we're looking at 100 by 32 by 32 by
3. now we've already formatted it to the
32 by 32 by 3. this just sets everything
up correctly so that X has the data in
there in the correct order in the
correct shape and then the Y just like
the x is our labels so our training
labels again they go from 0 to that size
in this case they do self I plus batch
size because the selfie is going to keep
changing and then finally we increment
the self I because we have zero so we so
the next time we call it we're going to
get the next batch size and so basically
we have X and Y X being the photograph
data coming in and Y being the label and
that of course is labeled through one
hot encoder so if you remember correctly
if it was say a horse is equal to zero
it would be one for the zero position
since this is the horse and then
everything else would be zero in here
lines through there there we go there's
our array hard to see that array so
let's go ahead and take that and we're
going to finish loading it since this is
our class and now we're armed with all
this um our setup over here let's go
ahead and load that up and so we're
going to create a variable CH with the
cfar helper in it and then we're going
to do ch.setup images now we could have
just put all the setup images under the
init but by breaking this up into two
parts it makes it much more readable and
also if you're doing other work there's
reasons to do that as far as the setup
let's go ahead and run that and you can
see where it says setting up training
images and labels setting up test images
and that's one of the reasons we broke
it up is so that if you're testing this
out you can actually have print
statements in there telling you what's
going on which is really nice they did a
good job with this setup I like the way
that it was broken up in the back and
then one quick note you want to remember
that batch to set up the next batch
since we have to run batch equals CH
next batch of 100 because we're going to
use the 100 size but we'll come back to
that we're going to use that just
remember that that's part of our code
we're going to be using in a minute from
the definition we just made so now we're
ready to create our model first thing we
want to do is we want to import our
tensorflow as TF I'll just go ahead and
run that so it's loaded up and you can
see we got a warning here that's because
they're making some changes it's always
growing and they're going to be
depreciating one of the values from
float64 to float type or it's treated as
an NP float64. nothing to really worry
about because this doesn't even affect
what we're working on because we've set
all of our stuff to a 255 value or zero
to one and do keep in mind that zero to
one value that we converted the 255 is
still a float value but it'll easily
work with either the numpy float64 or
the numpy d-type float it doesn't matter
which one it goes through so the
depreciation would not affect our code
as we have it and in our tensorflow
we'll go ahead let me just increase the
size in there just moments you can get a
better view of the what we're typing in
uh we're going to set a couple
placeholders here and so we have we're
going to set x equals TF placeholder TF
float32 we just talked about the float
64 versus the numpy float we're actually
just going to keep this at float 32.
more than a significant number of
decimals for what we're working with and
since it's a placeholder we're going to
set the shape equal to and we've set it
equal to none because at this point
we're just hold holding the place on
there we'll be setting up as we run the
batches that's what that first value is
and then 32 by 32 by 3 that's what we've
reshaped our data to fit in and then we
have our y true equals placeholder TF
float 32 and the shape equals none comma
10. 10 is the 10 different labels we
have so it's an array of ten and then
let's create one more placeholder and
we'll call this a hold prob or hold
probability and we're going to use this
we don't have to have a shape or
anything for this this placeholder is
for what we call Dropout if you remember
from from our Theory before we drop out
so many nodes as looking at or the
different values going through which
helps decrease bias so we need to go
ahead and put a placeholder for that
also and we'll run this so it's all
loaded up in there so we have our three
different placeholders and since we're
in tensorflow when you use Karas it does
some of this automatically but we're in
tensorflow direct the Ross hits on
tensorflow we're going to go ahead and
create some more helper functions we're
going to create something to help us
initialize the weights initialize our
bias if we remember that each layer has
to have a bias going in we're going to
go ahead and work on our conversional 2D
our Max pool so we have our pooling
layer our convolutional layer and then
our normal full layer so we're going to
go ahead and put those all into
definitions and let's see what that
looks like in code and you can also grab
some of these helper functions from the
mnist the nist setup let me just put
that in there if you're under the
tensorflow so a lot of these are already
in there but we're going to go ahead and
do our own and we're going to create our
init weights and one of the reasons
we're doing this is so that you can
actually start thinking about what's
going on in the back end so even though
there's ways to do this with an
automation sometimes these have to be
tweaked and you have to put in your own
setup in here now we're not going to be
doing that we're just going to recreate
them for our code and let's take a look
at this we have our weights and so what
comes in is going to be the shape and
what comes out is going to be a random
number so we're going to go ahead and
just knit some random numbers based on
the shape with a standard deviation of
0.1 kind of a fun way to do that and
then the TF variable init random
distribution so we're just creating a
random distribution on there that's all
that is for the weights now you might
change that you might have a higher
standard deviation in some cases you
actually load preset weights that's
pretty rare usually you're testing that
against another model or something like
that and you want to see how those
weights configured with each other now
remember we have our bias so we need to
go ahead and initialize the bias with
the constant in this case we're using
0.1 lot of times the bias is just put in
as one and then you have your weights
add on to that but we're going to set
this as 0.1 so we want to return a
convolutional 2d in this case a neural
network this is uh would be a layer on
here what's going on with the con 2D is
we're taking our data coming in we're
going to filter it strides if you
remember correctly strides came from
here's our image and then we only look
at this picture here and then maybe we
have a stride of one so we look at this
picture here and we continue to look at
the different filters going on there the
other thing this does is that we have
our data coming in as 32 by 32 by 3. and
we want to change this so that it's just
this is three dimensions and it's going
to reformat this as just two Dimensions
so it's going to take this number here
and combine it with the 32 by 32. so
this is a very important layer here
because it's reducing our data down
using different means and it connects
down I'm just going to jump down one
here uh it goes with the convolutional
layer so you have your your kind of your
pre-formatting and the setup and then
you have your actual convolution layer
that goes through on there and you can
see here we have init weights by the
shape and knit bias shape of three
because we have the three different uh
here's our three again and then we
return the tfnn relu with the convention
2D so this convolutional has this
feeding into it right there it's using
that as part of it and of course the
input is the X Y plus b the bias so
that's quite a mouthful but these two
are the are the keys here to creating
the convolutional layers there the
convolutional 2D coming in and then the
convolutional layer which then steps
through and creates all those filters we
saw then of course we have our pooling
so after each time we run it through the
convectional layer we want to pull the
data if you remember correctly on the on
the pool side and let me just get rid of
all my marks it's getting a little crazy
there and in fact let's go ahead and
jump back to that slide let's just take
a look at that slide over here so we
have our image coming in we create our
convolutional layer with all the filters
remember the filters go you know the
filter is coming in here and it looks at
these four boxes and then if it's a step
let's say step two it then goes to these
four boxes and then the next step and so
on uh so we have our convolutional layer
that we generate or convolutional layers
they use the relu function there's other
functions out there for this though the
real U is the most the one that works
the best at least so far I'm sure that
will change then we have our pooling now
if you remember correctly the pooling
was Max so if we had the filter coming
in and they did the multiplication on
there and we have a one and maybe a two
here and another one here and a three
here three is the max and so out of all
of these you then create an array that
would be three and if the max is over
here two or whatever it is that's what
goes into the pooling and what's going
on in our pooling uh so again we're
reducing that data down reducing it down
as small as we can and then finally
we're going to flatten it out into a
single array and that goes into our
fully connected layer and you can see
that here in the code right here we're
going to create our normal full layer so
at some point we're going to take from
our pooling layer this will go into some
kind of flattening process and then that
will be fed into the full the different
layers going in down here and so we have
our input size you'll see our input
layer gets shape which is just going to
get the shape for whatever's coming in
and then input size initial weights is
also based on the input layer coming in
and the input size down here is based on
the input layer shape so we're just
going to already use the shape and
already have our sides coming in and of
course you have to make sure you init
the bias always put your bias on there
and we'll do that based on the size so
this will return TF dot matte mole input
layer W plus b this is just a normal
full layer that's what this means right
down here that's what we're going to
return so that was a lot of steps we
went through let's go ahead and run that
so those are all loaded in there and
let's go ahead and create the layers
let's see what that looks like now that
we've done all the heavy lifting and
everything we get to do all the easy
part let's go ahead and create our
layers we'll create a convolution layer
one and two two different convolutional
layers and then we'll take that and
we'll flatten that out and create a
reshape pooling in there for our reshape
and then we'll have our full layer at
the end so let's start by creating our
first convolutional layer and then we
come in here and let me just run that
real quick and I want you to notice on
here the 3 and the 32. this is important
because coming into this convolutional
layer we have three different channels
and 32 pixels each so that has to be in
there the four and four you can play
with this is your filter size so if you
remember you have a filter and you have
your image and the filter is slowly
steps over and filters out this image
depending on what your step is for this
particular setup 4 4 is just fine that
should work pretty good for what we're
doing and for the size of the image and
then of course at the end once you have
your convolutional layer set up you also
need to pull it and you'll see that the
pooling is automatically set up so that
it would see the different shape based
on what's coming in so here we have Max
toolba 2x2 and we put in the
convolutional one that we just created
the convolutional layer we just created
goes right back into it and that right
up here as you can see is the x is
coming in from here so it knows to look
at the first model and set the the data
accordingly set that up so it matches
and we went ahead and ran this already I
think all right let me go and run it
again and if we're going to do one layer
let's go ahead and do a second layer
down here and it's we'll call it convo
2. it's also a convolutional layer on
this and you'll see that we're feeding
convolutional one in the pooling so it
goes from convolution additional 1 into
convolutional one pooling from
convolutional one pooling into
convolutional two and then from
convolutional 2 into convolutional 2
pooling and we'll go ahead and take this
and run this so these variables are all
loaded into memory and for our flattened
layer let's go ahead and we'll do since
we have 64 coming out of here and we
have a four by four going in let's do
eight by eight by 64. so let's do
4096. this is going to be the flat layer
so that's how many bits are coming
through on the flat layer and we'll
reshape this so we'll reshape our convo
2 pooling and that will feed into here
the combo two pulling and then we're
going to set it up as a single layer
that's 4096 in size that's what that
means there we'll go ahead and run this
so we've now created this variable the
convo 2 flat and then we have our first
full layer this is the final neural
network where the flat layer going in
and we're going to again use the relief
for our setup on there in a neural
network for evaluation and you'll notice
that we're going to create our first
full layer our normal full layer that's
our definition so we created that that's
creating the normal full layer and our
input for the data comes right here from
the this goes right into it the convo 2
flat so this tells it how big the data
is and we're going to have it come out
it's going to have a 1024 that's how big
the layer is coming out we'll go ahead
and run this so now we have our full
layer one and with the full layer one we
want to also Define the full one Dropout
to go with that so our full layer one
comes in keep probability equals hold
probability remember we created that
earlier and the full layer 1 is what's
coming into it and this is going
backwards and training the data we're
not training every weight we're only
training a percentage of them each time
which helps get rid of the bias so let
me go ahead and run that and finally
we'll go ahead and create a y predict
which is going to equal the the normal
full one drop out and 10 because we have
10 labels in there now in this neural
network we could have added additional
layers that would be another option to
play with you can also play with instead
of 1024 you can use other numbers for
the way that sets up and what's coming
out going into the next one we're only
going to do just the one layer and the
one layer drop out and you can see if we
did another layer it'd be really easy
just to feed in the full one drop out
into full layer two and then full Layer
Two Dropout would have full layer two
feet into it and then you'd switch that
here for the Y prediction for right now
this is great this particular data set
is tried and true and we know that this
will work on it and if we just type in y
predict and we run that we'll see that
this is a tensor object shape question
mark 10 d-type 32. a quick way to double
check what we're working on so now we've
got all of our we've done a setup all
the way to the Y predict which we just
did we want to go ahead and apply the
loss function and make sure that set up
in there create the optimizer and then
trainer Optimizer and create a variable
to initialize all the global TF
variables so before we dive in to the
loss function let me point out one quick
thing or just kind of a rehab over a
couple things and that is when we're
playing with this these setups we
pointed out up here we can change the 4
4 and use different numbers there they
change your outcome so depending on what
numbers you use here we'll have a huge
impact on how well your model fits and
that's the same here of the 1024 also
this is also another number that if you
continue to raise that number you'll get
possibly a better fit you might overfit
and if you lower that number you'll use
less resources and generally you want to
use this in the exponential growth an
exponential being 2 4 8 16 and in this
case the next one down would be 512. you
can use any number there but those are
the ideal numbers when you look at this
data so the next step in all this is we
need to also create a way of tracking
how good our model is and we're going to
call this a loss function and so we're
going to create a cross entropy loss
function and so before we discuss
exactly what that is let's take a look
and see what we're feeding it we're
going to feed it our labels and we have
our true labels and our prediction
labels so coming in here is where the
two different variables we're sending in
or the two different probability
distributions is one that we know is
true and what we think it's going to be
now this function right here when they
talk about cross entropy in information
Theory the cross entropy between two
probability distributions over the same
underlying set of events measures the
average number of bits needed to
identify an event drawn from the set
that's a mouthful really we're just
looking at the amount of error in here
how many of these are correct and how
many of these are incorrect so how much
of it matches and we're going to look at
that we're just going to look at the
average that's what the mean the reduced
to the mean means here so we're looking
at the average error on this
and so the next step is we're going to
take the error we want to know our cross
entropy or our loss function how much
loss we have that's going to be part of
how we train the model so when you know
what the loss is and we're training it
you feed that back into the back
propagation setup and so we want to go
ahead and optimize that here's our
Optimizer we're going to create the
optimizer using an atom Optimizer
remember there's a lot of different ways
of optimizing the data atom is the most
popular used so our Optimizer is going
to equal the TF train atom Optimizer if
you don't remember what the learning
rate is let me just pop this back into
here here's our learning rate when you
have your weights you have all your
weights and your different nodes that
are coming out here's our node coming
out and it has all its weights and then
the error is being prop sent back
through in reverse on our neural network
so we take this error and we adjust
these weights based on the different
formulas in this case the atom formula
is what we're using we don't want to
just adjust them completely we don't
want to change this weight so it exactly
fits the data coming through because if
we made that kind of adjustment it's
going to be biased to whatever the last
data we sent through is instead we're
going to multiply that by 0.001 and make
a very small shift in this weight so our
Delta W is only 0.001 of the actual
Delta W or the full change we're going
to compute from the atom and then we
want to go ahead and train it so our
training or set up a training variable
or function and this is going to equal
our Optimizer minimize cross entropy and
we make sure we go ahead and run this so
it's loaded in there and then we're
almost ready to train our model but
before we do that we need to create one
more variable in here and we're going to
create a variable to initialize all the
global TF variables and when we look at
this the TF Global variable initializer
this is a tensorflow object it goes
through there and it looks at all our
different setup that we have going under
our tensorflow and then initializes
those variables so it's kind of like a
magic wand because it's all hidden in
the back end of tensorflow all you need
to know about this is that you have to
have the initialization on there which
is an operation and you have to run that
once you have your setup going so we'll
go ahead and run this piece of code and
then we're going to go ahead and train
our data so let me run this so it's load
it up there and so now we're going to go
ahead and run the model by creating a
graph session graph session is a
tensorflow term so you'll see that
coming up it's one of the things that
throws me because I always think of
graphx and Spark and graph as just
general graphing but they talk about a
graph session so we're going to go ahead
and run the model and let's go ahead and
walk through this what's going on here
and let's paste this data in here and
here we go so we're going to start off
with it with a TF session as cess so
that's our actual TF session we've
created so we're right here with the TF
session our session we're creating we're
going to run TF Global variable
initializer so right up off the bat
we're initializing our variables here
and then we have for I in range
500. so what's going on here remember
500 we're going to break the data up and
we're going to batch it in at 500 points
each we've created our session run so
we're going to do with TF session as
session right here we've created our
variable session and then we're going to
run and we're going to go ahead and
initialize it so we have our TF Global
variables initializer that we created
that initializes our session in here the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to go for I in range of 500 batch
equals ch.next batch so if you remember
correctly this is loading up 100
pictures at a time and this is going to
Loop through that 500 times so we are
literally doing uh what is that 500
times 100 is 50 000. so that's 50 000
pictures we're going to process right
there in the first process is we're
going to do a session run we're going to
take our train we created our trained
variable or Optimizer in there we're
going to feed it the dictionary we had
our feed dictionary that we created and
we have x equals batch 0 coming in y
true batch 1 hold the probability 0.5
and then just so that we can keep track
of what's going on we're going to every
100 steps we're going to run a print So
currently on step format accuracy is and
we're going to look at matches equals TF
dot equal TF argument y prediction One
tf.org Max y true comma one so we're
going to look at this as how many
matches it has and here are ACC all
we're doing here is we're going to take
the matches how many matches they have
it creates it generates a chart we're
going to convert that to float that's
what the TF cast does and then we just
want to know the average we just want to
know the average of the accuracy and
then we'll go ahead and print that out
print session run accuracy feed
dictionary so it takes all this and it
prints out our accuracy see on there so
let's go ahead and take this oops
screens there let's go ahead and take
this and let's run it and this is going
to take a little bit to run so let's see
what happens on my old laptop and we'll
see here that we have our current we're
currently on step 0 it takes a little
bit to get through the accuracy and this
will take just a moment to run we can
see that on our step 0 it has an
accuracy of 0.1 or 0.1028 and as it's
running we'll go ahead you need to watch
it run all the way but this accuracy is
going to change a little bit up and down
so we've actually lost some accuracy
during our step two but we'll see how
that comes out let's come back after we
run it all the way through and see how
the different steps come out I was
actually reading that backwards the way
this works is the closer we get to one
the more accuracy we have so you can see
here we've gone from a 0.1 to a 0.39 and
we'll go ahead and pause this and come
back and see what happens when we're
done with the full run all right now
that we've prepared the mill got it in
the oven and pulled out my finished dish
here if you've ever watched any of the
old cooking shows let's discuss a little
bit about this accuracy going on here
and how do you interpret that we've done
a couple things first we've defined
accuracy the reason I got it backwards
before is you have loss or accuracy and
with loss you'll get a graph that looks
like this it goes oops that's an S by
the way there we go you get a graph that
curves down like this and with accuracy
you get a graph that curves up this is
how good it's doing now in this case one
is supposed to be really good accuracy
that means it gets close to one but it
never crosses one so if you have an
accuracy of one that is phenomenal in
fact that's pretty much you know unheard
of and the same thing with loss if you
have a loss of zero that's also unheard
of the zero is actually on this this
axis right here as we go in there so how
do we interpret that because you know if
I was looking at this and I go oh 0.51
that's uh 51 you're doing 50 50. no this
is not percentage let me me just put
that in there it is not percentage this
is logarithmic what that means is that
0.2 is twice as good as 0.1 and we see
0.4 that's twice as good as 0.2 real way
to convert this into a percentage you
really can't say this is is a direct
percentage conversion what you can do
though is in your head if we were to
give this a percentage we might look at
this as 50 percent we're just guessing
equals 0.1 and if 50 percent roughly
equals 0.1 that's where we started up
here at the top remember at the top here
here's our 0.1028 the accuracy of 50
percent then 75 percent is about 0.2 and
so on and so on don't quote those
numbers because it doesn't work that way
they say that if you have
0.95 that's pretty much saying a hundred
percent and if you have a anywhere
between you'd have to go look this up we
go go and remove all my drawings there
so the magic number is 0.5 we really
want to be over a 0.5 in this whole
thing and we have both 0.504 remember
this is accuracy if we were looking at
loss then we'd be looking the other way
but Point O you know instead of how high
it is we want how low it is but with
accuracy being over a 0.5 is pretty
valid that means this is pretty solid
and if you get to a 0.95 then it's a
direct correlation that's what we're
looking for here in these numbers you
can see we finished with this model at
0.5135 so still good and if we look at
when they ran this in the other end
remember there's a lot of Randomness
that goes into it when we see the
weights they got 0.5251 so a little
better than ours but that's fine you'll
find your own comes up a little bit
better or worse depending on just that
Randomness and so we've gone through the
whole model we've created we've trained
the model and we've also gone through on
every 100th run to test the model to see
how accurate it is welcome to the RNN
tutorial that's the recurrent neural
network so we talk about a feed forward
neural network in a feed forward neural
network information flows only in the
forward direction from the input nodes
through the hidden layers if any into
the output nodes there are no Cycles or
Loops in the network and so you can see
here we have our input layer I was
talking about how it just goes straight
forward into the hidden layers so each
one of those connects and then connects
to the next hidden layer connects to the
output layer and of course we have a
nice simplified version where it has a
predicted output the refer to the input
is X a lot of times and the output as y
decisions are based on current input no
memory about the past no future scope
why recurrent neural network issues in
feed forward neural network so one of
the biggest issues is because it doesn't
have a scope of memory or time a feed
forward neural network doesn't know how
to handle sequential data it only
considers only the current input so if
you have a series of things and because
three points back X what's happening now
and what your output affects what's
happening that's very important so
whatever I put as an output is going to
affect the next one a feed forward
doesn't look at any of that it just
looks at this is what's coming in and it
cannot memorize previous inputs so it
doesn't have that list of inputs coming
in solution to feed forward neural
network you'll see here where it says
recurrent neural network and we have our
X on the bottom going to H going to Y
that's your feed forward but right in
the middle it has a value C so there's a
whole another process so it's memorizing
what's going on in the hidden layers and
the hidden layers as they produce data
feed into the next one so your hidden
layer might have an output that goes off
to Y but that output goes back into the
next prediction coming in what this does
is this allows it to handle sequential
data it considers the current input and
also the previously received inputs and
if we're going to look at General
drawings and solutions we should also
look at applications of the RNN image
captioning RNN is used to caption image
image by analyzing the activities
present in it a dog catching a ball in
midair that's very tough I mean you know
we have a lot of stuff that analyzes
images of a dog in the image of a ball
but it's able to add one more feature in
there that's actually catching the ball
in midair time series prediction anytime
series problem like predicting the
prices of stocks in a particular month
can be solved using RNN and we'll dive
into that in our use case and actually
take a look at some stock one of the
things you should know about analyzing
stock today is that it is very difficult
and if you're analyzing the whole stock
the stock market at the New York Stock
Exchange in the U.S produces somewhere
in the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades and fluctuations by
the second it's like three terabytes a
day of data so we're only going to look
at one stock just analyzing One stock is
really tricky in here we'll give you a
little jump on that so that's exciting
but don't expect to get rich off of it
immediately another application of the
RNN is natural language processing text
Mining and sentiment analysis can be
carried out using RNN for natural
language processing and you can see
right here the term natural language
processing when you stream those three
words together is very different than
ice if I said processing language
naturally so the time series is very
important when we're analyzing
sentiments it can change the whole value
of a sentence just by switching the
words around or if you're just counting
the words you may get one sentiment
where if you actually look at the order
they're in you get a completely
different sentiment when it rains look
for rainbows when it's dark look for
stars both of these are positive
sentiments and they're based upon the
order of which the sentence is going in
machine translation given an input in
one language RNN can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output I myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking English you would say
big cat and if you're speaking Spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in English and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in English in this
little diagram I guess that's denoted by
the flags I have a flag I own it no
um but they're speaking in English and
it's getting translated into Chinese
Italian French German and Spanish
languages some of the tools coming out
are just so cool so somebody like myself
who's very linguistically challenged I
can now travel into Worlds I would never
think of because I can have something
translate my English back and forth
readily and I'm not stuck with a
communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down it'll make more
sense and usually we have a propagation
forward neural network with the put
layers of hidden layers the output layer
with the recurrent neural network we
turn that on its side so here it is and
now our X comes up from the bottom into
the hidden layers into Y and they
usually draw a very simplified X to H
with c as a loop a to Y where a B and C
are the perimeters a lot of times you'll
see this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the H and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the C goes in and then the X
goes in so the x is going Upward Bound
and C is going to the right a is going
out and C is also going out that's where
it gets a little confusing so here we
have xn CN and then we have y out and C
out and C is based on H T minus one so
our value is based on the Y and the H
value are connected to each other
they're not necessarily the same value
because H can be its own thing and
usually we draw this or we represent it
as a function h of T equals a function
of C where a to T minus this one that's
the last H output and X of T going in so
it's the last output of H bind with the
new input of X where H T is the new
state FC is a function with a parameter
C that's a common way of denoting it h t
minus 1 is the Old State coming out and
then X of T is an input Vector at time
of Step T well we need to cover types of
recurrent neural networks and so the
first one is the most common one which
is a one to one single output one to one
neural network is usually known as a
vanilla neural network used for regular
machine learning problems why because
vanilla's usually considered kind of a
just a real basic flavor but because
it's very basic a lot of times they'll
call it the vanilla neural network which
is not the common term but it is you
know kind of a slang term people will
know what you're talking about usually
if you say that then we run one to mini
so you have a single input and you might
have a multiple outputs in this case
image captioning as we looked at earlier
where we have not just I looking at it
as a dog but a dog catching a ball in
the air and then you have many to One
Network takes in a sequence of inputs
examples sentiment analysis where a
given sentence can be classified as
expressing positive or negative
sentiments and we looked at that as we
were discussing if it rains look for a
rainbow so positive sentiment where rain
might be a negative sentiment if you're
just adding up the words in there and
then of course if you're going to do a
one-to-one many to one one to many
there's many to many networks takes in a
sequence of inputs and generates a
sequence of outputs example machine
translation so we have a lengthy
sentence coming in in English and then
going out in all the different languages
you know just a wonderful tool very
complicated set of computations you know
if you're a translator you realize just
how difficult it is to translate into
different languages one of the biggest
things you need to understand when we're
working with this neural network is
what's called The Vanishing gradient
problem well training in RNN your slope
can be either too small or are very
large and this makes training difficult
when the slope is too small the problem
is known as Vanishing gradient and
you'll see here they have a nice image
lots of information through time so if
you're pushing not enough information
forward that information is lost and
then when you go to train it you start
losing the third word in the sentence or
something like that or it doesn't quite
follow the full logic of what you're
working on exploding gradient problem Oh
this is one that runs into everybody
when you're working with this particular
neural network when the slope tends to
grow exponentially instead of decaying
this problem is called exploding
gradient issues in gradient problem Long
training time poor performance bad
accuracy and I'll add one more in there
your computer if you're on a lower end
computer testing out a model will lock
up and give you the memory error
explaining gradient problem consider the
following two examples to understand
what should be the next word in the
sequence the person who took my bike and
blank a Chief the students who got into
engineering with blank from Asia and you
can see in here we have our x value
going in we have the previous value
going forward and then you back
propagate the error like you do with any
neural network and as we're looking for
that missing word maybe we'll have the
person took my bike and blank was a
thief and the student who got into
engineering with a blank were from Asia
consider the following example the
person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike it
was blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the RNN must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief is singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the RNN must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
Asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the air to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the solution to the gradient
problem first we're going to look at
exploding gradient where we have three
different solutions depending on what's
going on one is identity initialization
so the first thing we want to do is see
if we can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the back propagation
so instead of having whatever
information it's sending to the next
series we can truncate when it's sending
we can lower that particular set of
layers make those smaller and finally as
a gradient clipping so when we're
training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a Vanishing gradient the option
problem we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation functions so we'll
look at that just minimally there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short term memory
networks the lstms and we can make
adjustments to that so just like we can
clip the gradient as it comes out we can
also expand on that we can increase the
memory Network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's setup is
what they call long-term dependencies
suppose we try to predict the last word
in the text the clouds are in the and
you probably said sky here we do not
need any further context it's pretty
clear that the last word is going to be
Sky suppose we try to predict the last
word in the text I have been staying in
Spain for the last 10 years I can speak
fluent maybe you said Portuguese or
French no you probably said Spanish the
word we predict will depend on the
previous few words in context here we
need the context of Spain to predict the
last word in the text it's possible that
the gap between the relevant information
and the point where it is needed to
become very large LST M's help us solve
this problem so the lstms are a special
kind of recurrent neural network capable
of learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default Behavior All
recurrent neural networks have the form
of a chain of repeating modules of
neural network connections in standard
rnns this repeating module have a very
simple structure such as a single
tangent H layer lstm s's also have a
chain-like structure but the repeating
module has a different structure instead
of having a single neural network layer
there are four interacting layers
communicating in a very special way
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependency remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default Behavior lstms's also have
a chain-like structure but the repeating
module has a different structure instead
of having a single neural network layer
there are four interacting layers
communicating in a very special way as
you can see the deeper we dig into this
the more complicated the graphs kit in
here I want you to note that you have X
at T minus 1 coming in you have X of T
coming in and you've got X at t plus one
and you have a to T minus 1 and H of T
coming in and H of t plus one going out
and of course on the other side is the
output a in the middle we have our
tangent H but it occurs in two different
places so not only when we're Computing
the X at t plus one are we getting the
tangent H from X and T but we're also
getting that value coming in from the X
of T minus one so the short of it is as
you look at these layers not only does
it does the propagate through the first
layer goes into the second layer back
into itself it's also going into the
third layer so now we're kind of
stacking those up and this can get very
complicated as you grow that in size it
also grows in memory two and in the
amount of resources it takes but it's a
very powerful tool to help us address
the problem of complicated long
sequential information coming in like we
were just looking at in the sentence and
when we're looking at our long short
term memory Network there's three steps
of processing assessing in the lstms
that we look at the first one is we want
to forget irrelevant parts of the
previous state you know a lot of times
like you know is as in a unless we're
trying to look at whether it's a plural
noun or not they don't really play a
huge part in the language so we want to
get rid of them then selectively update
cell State values so we only want to
update the cell State values that
reflect what we're working on and
finally we want to put only output
certain parts of the cell state so
whatever is coming out we want to limit
what's going out too and let's dig a
little deeper into this let's just see
what this really looks like so step one
decides how much of the past it should
remember first step in the lstm is to
decide which information to be omitted
in from the cell in that particular time
step it is decided by the sigmoid
function it looks at the previous state
a to T minus 1 and the current input
exit T and computes the function so you
can see over here we have a function of
T equals the sigmoid function of the
weight of f the H at T minus 1 and then
X of t plus of course you have a bias in
there with any of our neural network so
we have a bias function so F of T equals
forget gate decides which information to
delete that is not important from the
previous time step considering an lstm
is fed with the following inputs from
the previous and present time step Alice
is good in physics John on the other
hand is good in chemistry so previous
output John plays football well he told
me yesterday over the phone that he had
served as a captain of his college
football team that's our current m put
so as we look at this the first step is
the forget gate realizes there might be
a change in context after encounting the
First full stop comparers with the
current input sentence of X of T so
we're looking at that full stop and then
Compares it with the input of the new
sentence the next sentence talks about
John so the information on Alice is
deleted okay that's important to know so
we have this input coming in and if
we're going to continue on with John
then that's going to be the primary
information we're looking at the
position of the subject is vacated and
is assigned to John and so in this one
we've seen that we've weeded out a whole
bunch of information and we're only
passing information on John since that's
now the new topic so step two is then to
decide how much should this unit add to
the current state in the second layer
there are two parts one is a sigmoid
function and the other is a tangent H in
the sigmoid function it decides which
values to let through 0 or 1. tangent H
function gives the weightage to the
values which are passed deciding their
level of importance minus one to one and
you can see the two formulas that come
up the I of T equals the sigmoid of the
weight of I a to T minus one X of t plus
the bias of I and the C of T equals the
tangent of H of the weight of C of H of
T minus one X of t plus the bias of C so
our I of T equals the input gate
determines which information to let
through based on its significance in the
current time step if this seems a little
complicated don't worry because a lot of
the programming is already done when we
get to the case study understanding
though that this is part of the program
is important when you're trying to
figure out these what to set your
settings at you should also note when
you're looking at this it should have
some semblance to your forward
propagation neural networks where we
have a value assigned to a weight plus a
bias very important steps than any of
the neural network layers whether we're
propagating into them the information
from one to the next or we're just doing
a straightforward neural network
propagation let's take a quick look at
this what it looks like from the human
standpoint as I step out in my suit
again consider the current input at X of
T John plays football well he told me
yesterday over the phone that he had
served as a captain of his college
football team that's her input input
gate analysis the important information
John plays football and he was a captain
of his college team is important he told
me over the phone yesterday is less
important hence it is forgotten this
process of adding some new information
can be done via the input gate now this
example is as a human form and we'll
look at training this stuff in just a
minute but as a human being if I wanted
to get this information from a
conversation maybe it's a Google Voice
listening in on you or something like
that
um how do we weed out the information
that he was talking to me on the phone
yesterday well I don't want to memorize
that he talked to me on the phone
yesterday or maybe that is important but
in this case it's not I want to know
that he was the captain of the football
team I want to know that he served I
want to know that John plays football
and he was a captain of the college
football team those are the two things
that I want to take away as a human
being again we measure a lot of this
from the human Viewpoint and that's also
how we try to train them so we can
understand these neural networks finally
we get to step three decides what part
of the current cell State makes it to
the output the third step is to decide
what will be our output first we run a
sigmoid layer which decides what parts
of the cell State make it to the output
then we put the cell State through the
tangent H to push the values to be
between -1 and 1 and multiply it by the
output of the sigmoid gate so when we
talk about the output of T we set that
equal to the sigmoid of the weight of 0
of the H of T minus one and back One
Step in Time by the x of t plus of
course the bias the a to T equals the
out of T times the tangent of the
tangent h of C at T so our o oft equals
the output gate allows the passed in
information to impact the output in the
current time step let's consider the
example to predicting the word in the
sentence John played tremendously well
against the opponent and one for his
team for his contributions Brave blank
was awarded player of the match there
could be a lot of choices for the empty
space current input Brave is an
adjective adjectives describe a noun
John could be the best output after
Brave thumbs up for John awarded player
of the match and if he were to pull just
the nouns out of the sentence team
doesn't look right because that's not
really the subject we're talking about
contributions you know Brave
contributions or Brave team Brave player
Brave match so you look at this and you
can start to train this these this
neural network so it starts looking at
and goes oh no John is what we're
talking about so brave is an adjective
John's going to be the best output and
we give John a big thumbs up and then of
course we jump into my favorite part the
case study use case implementation of
lstm let's predict the prices of stocks
using the LST em network based on the
stock price data between 2012 2016.
we're going to try to predict the stock
prices of 2017. and this will be a
narrow set of data we're not going to do
the whole stock market it turns out that
the New York Stock Exchange generates
roughly three terabytes of data per day
that's all the different trades up and
down of all the different stocks going
on and each individual one second to
second or nanosecond to nanosecond but
we're going to limit that to just some
very basic fundamental information so
don't think you're going to get rich off
this today but at least you can give an
uh you can give a step forward in how to
start processing something like stock
prices a very valid use for machine
learning in today's markets use case
implementation of lstm let's dive in
we're going to import our libraries
we're going to import the training set
and get the scaling going now if you
watch any of our other tutorials a lot
of these pieces should start to look
very familiar because it's very similar
our setup let's take a look at that and
just a reminder we're going to be using
Anaconda the Jupiter notebook so here I
have my anaconda Navigator when we go
under environments I've actually set up
a cross python 36 I'm in Python 36 and
uh nice thing about Anaconda especially
the newer version remember a year ago
messing with Anaconda different versions
of python and different environments
Anaconda now has a nice interface and I
have this installed both on a Ubuntu
Linux machine and on windows so it works
fine on there you can go in here and
open a terminal window and then in here
once you're in the terminal window this
is where you're going to start
installing using pip to install your
different modules and everything now
we've already pre-installed them so we
don't need to do that in here but if you
don't have them installed in your
particular environment you'll need to do
that and of course you don't need to use
the anaconda or the Jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python IDE you like
I'm just a big fan of this because it
keeps all my stuff separate you can see
see on this machine I have specifically
installed one for cross since we're
going to be working with Karas under
tensorflow we go back to home I've gone
up here to application and that's the
environment I've loaded on here and then
we'll click on the launch Jupiter
notebook now I've already in my Jupiter
notebook have set up a lot of stuff so
that we're ready to go kind of like
Martha Stewart's in the old cooking show
so we want to make sure we have all our
tools for you so you're not waiting for
them to load and if we go up here to
where it says new you can see where you
can create a new python 3. that's what
we did here underneath the setup so it
already has all the modules installed on
it and I'm actually rename this if you
go under file you can rename it I'm
calling it RNN stock and let's just take
a look at start diving into the code
let's get into the exciting part now
we've looked at the tool and of course
you might be using a different tool
which is fine let's start putting that
code in there and seeing what those
Imports and uploading everything looks
like now first half is kind of boring
when we hit the Run button because we're
going to be importing numpy as NP that's
uh the number python which is your numpy
array and the matplot library so we're
going to do some plotting at the end and
our pandas for our data set our pandas
is PD and when I hit run it really
doesn't do anything except for load
those modules just a quick note let me
just do a quick draw here oops shift alt
there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if I was to divide this
up oops I'm going to actually let's
overlap these here we go
this first part that we're going to do
is
our data
prep
a lot of prepping involved
in fact depending on what your system
instance we're using Karas I put an
overlap here but you'll find that almost
maybe even half of the code we do is all
about the data prep and the reason I
overlap this with Karas let me just put
that down because that's what we're
working in is because Karas has like
their own preset stuff so it's already
pre-built in which is really nice so
there's a couple Steps A lot of times
that are in the Karas setup we'll take a
look at that to see what comes up in our
code as we go through and look at stock
and the last part is to evaluate and if
you're working with shareholders or you
know classroom whatever it is you're
working with the evaluate is the next
biggest piece so the actual code here
crosses a little bit more but when
you're working with some of the other
packages you might have like three lines
that might be it all your stuff is in
your pre-processing and your data since
Karas has is is Cutting Edge and you
load the individual layers you'll see
that there's a few more lines here and
cross is a little bit more robust and
then you spend a lot of times like I
said with the evaluate you want to have
something you present to everybody else
and say hey this is what I did this is
what it looks like so let's go through
those steps this is like a kind of just
general overview and let's just take a
look and see what the next set of code
looks like and in here we have a data
set train and it's going to be read
using the PD our pandas dot read CSV and
it's a Google stock price train dot CSV
and so under this we have training set
equals dataset train dot eye location
and we've kind of sorted out part of
that so what's going on here let's just
take a look at let's look at the actual
file and see what's going on there now
if we look at this ignore all the extra
files on this I already have a train and
a test set where it's sorted out this is
important to notice because a lot of
times we do that as part of the
pre-processing of the data we take 20
percent of the data out so we can test
it and then we train the rest of it as
we use to create our neural network that
way we can find out how how good it is
but let's go ahead and just take a look
and see what that looks like as far as
the file itself and I went ahead and
just opened this up in a basic word pad
and text editor just so we can take a
look at it certainly you can open up an
Excel or any other kind of spreadsheet
and we note that this is a comma
separated variables we have a date open
high low close volume this is the
standard stuff that we import into our
stock and we're the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download in this case
we downloaded it from Google that's why
we call it the Google stock price and it
specifically is Google this is the
Google stock values from as you can see
here we started off at 1 3 2012. so when
we look at this first setup up here we
have a data set train equals PD
underscore CSV and if you noticed on the
original frame let me just go back there
they had it set to home Ubuntu downloads
Google stock price rain I went ahead and
changed that because we're in the same
file where I'm running the code so I've
saved this particular python code and I
don't need to go through any special
paths or how the full path on there and
then of course we want to take out
certain values in here and you're going
to notice that we're using our data set
and we're now in pandas so pandas
basically it looks like a spreadsheet
and in this case we're going to do I
location which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
in the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns one and
two and if you remember here from our
data as we switch back on over columns
we always start with zero which is the
date and we're going to be looking at
open
and high which would be one and two
we'll just label that right there so you
can see now when you go back and do this
you certainly can extrapolate and do
this on all the columns
um but for the example let's just limit
a little bit here so that we can focus
on just some key aspects of stock
and then we'll go up here and run the
code and again I said the first half is
very boring whenever we hit the Run
button it doesn't do anything because
we're still just loading the data and
setting it up now that we've loaded our
data we want to go ahead and scale it we
want to do what they call feature
scaling and in here we're going to pull
it up from the sklearn or the SK kit
pre-processing import min max scalar and
when you look at this you got to
remember that biases in our data we want
to get rid of that so if you have
something that's like a really high
value let's just draw a quick graph and
I have something here like the maybe the
stock has a value One stock has a value
of a hundred and another stock has a
value of five
um you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100 is going to
be the Max and 5 is going to be the Min
and then everything else goes and then
we change this so we just squish it down
I like the word squish so it's between 1
and 0. so 100 equals one or one equals
100 and 0 equals five and you can just
multiply it's usually just a simple
multiplication we're using
multiplication so it's going to be minus
5 and then 100 divided or 95 divided by
one so or whatever value is is divided
by 95. and once we've actually created
our scale we're telling it's going to be
from zero to one we want to take our
training set and we're going to create a
training set scaled and we're going to
use our scalar SC and we're going to fit
we're going to fit and transform the
training set so we can now use the SC
this particular object we'll use it
later on our testing set because
remember we have to also scale that when
we go to test our model and see how it
works and we'll go ahead and click on
the run again uh it's not going to have
any output yet because we're just
setting up all the variables
all right so we pasted the data in here
and we're going to create the data
structure with the 60 time steps and
output first note we're running 60 time
steps and that is where this value here
also comes in so the first thing we do
is we create our X train and Y train
variables and we set them to an empty
python array very important to remember
what kind of array we're in and what
we're working with and then we're going
to come in here we're going to go for I
in range 60 to 1258 there's our 60 60
time steps and the reason we want to do
this is as we're adding the data in
there's nothing below the 60. so if
we're going to use 60 time steps we have
to start at 0.60 because it includes
everything underneath of it otherwise
you'll get a pointer error and then
we're going to take our X train and
we're going to append training set
scaled this is the scaled value between
0 and 1. and then as I is equal to 60
this value is going to be 60 minus 60 is
zero so this actually
0 to I so it's going to be 0 60 1 to 61.
let me just circle this part right here
1 to 61 2 to 62 and so on and so on and
if you remember I said 0 to 60 that's
incorrect because it does not count
remember it starts at zero so this is a
count of 60. so it's actually 59.
important to remember that as we're
looking at this and then the second part
of this that we're looking at so if you
remember correctly here we go we go from
0 to 59 of I and then we have a comma a
0 right here and so finally we're just
going to look at the open value now I
know we did put it in there for one to
two
if you remember correctly it doesn't
count the second one so it's just the
open value we're looking at just open
um and then finally we have y train dot
append training set I to zero and if you
remember correctly I2 or I comma zero if
you remember correctly this is 0 to 59
so there's 60 values in it uh so when we
do I down here this is number 60. so
we're going to do this is we're creating
an array and we have 0 to 59
and over here we have number 60 which is
going into the Y train it's being
appended on there and then this just
goes all the way up so this is down here
is a 0 to 59 and we'll call it 60. since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to
1258 that's where this value here comes
in that's the length of the data we're
loading
so we've loaded two arrays we've loaded
one array that has which is filled with
arrays from 0 to 59 and we loaded one
array which is just the value and what
we're looking at you want to think about
this as a Time sequence uh here's my
open open open open open what's the next
one in the series so we're looking at
the Google stock and each time it opens
we want to know what the next one 0
through 59 what's 60 1 through 60 what's
61. 2 through 62 what's 62 and so on and
so on going up and then once we've
loaded those in our for Loop we go ahead
and take X trade and Y train equals
np.arrayxtrain.np array y train we're
just converting this back into a numpy
array that way we can use all the cool
tools that we get with numpy array
including reshaping so if we take a look
and see what's going on here we're going
to take our X train
we're going to reshape it wow what the
heck does reshape mean uh that means we
have an array if you remember correctly
so many numbers by 60.
that's how wide it is and so we're when
you when you do xtrain.shape that gets
one of the shapes and you get X
trained.shape of one gets the other
shape and we're just making sure the
data is formatted correctly and so you
use this to pull the fact that it's 60
by
um in this case where's that value 60 pi
11 99 1258 minus 60 11.99 and we're
making sure that that is shaped
correctly so the data is grouped into
1199 by 60 different arrays and then the
one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the in layer needs to be
one value that's like the leaf of a tree
where this is the branch and then it
branches out some more and then you get
the Leaf NP dot reshape comes from and
using the existing shapes to form it
we'll go ahead and run this piece of
code again there's no real output and
then we'll import our different cross
modules that we need so from Cross
models we're going to import the
sequential model we're dealing with
sequential data we have our dense layers
we have actually three layers we're
going to bring in our dense our lstm
which is what we're focusing on and our
Dropout and we'll discuss three layers
more in just a moment but you do need
the with the lstm you do need the drop
out and then the final layer will be the
dense but let's go ahead and run this
and that'll bring Porter modules and
you'll see we get an error on here and
if you read it closer it's not actually
an error it's a warning what does this
warning mean these things come up all
the time when you're working with such
Cutting Edge modules that are completely
being updated all the time we're not
going to worry too much about the
warning all it's saying is that the H5
py module which is part of cross is
going to be updated at some point and if
you're running new stuff on cross and
you start updating your cross system you
better make sure that your H5 Pi is
updated too otherwise you're going to
have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the H5 Pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and I said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean I meant that and we're going
to start off with initializing the RNN
and then we'll start adding those layers
in and you'll see that we have the lstm
and then the Dropout lstm then Dropout
lstm then drop out what the heck is that
doing so let's explore that we'll start
by initializing the RNN regressor equals
sequential because we're using the
sequential model and we'll run that and
load that up and then we're going to
start adding our lstm layer and some
Dropout regularization and right there
should be the queue Dropout
regularization and if we go back here
and remember our exploding gradient well
that's what we're talking about the
Dropout drops out unnecessary data so
we're not just shifting huge amounts of
data through the network so and so we go
in here let's just go ahead and add this
in I'll go ahead and run this and we had
three of them so let me go ahead and put
all three of them in and then we can go
back over them here's the second one and
let's put one more in let's put that in
and we'll go and put two more in I mean
I said one more in but it's actually two
more n and then let's add one more after
that and as you can see each time I run
these they don't actually have an output
so let's take a closer look and see
what's going on here so we're going to
add our first lstm layer in here we're
going to have units 50. the units is the
positive integer and it's the
dimensionality of the output space this
is what's going out into the next layer
so we might have 60 coming in but we
have 50 going out we have a return
sequence because it is a sequence data
so we want to keep that true and then
you have to tell it what shape it's in
well we already know the shape by just
going in here and looking at x train
shape so input shape equals the X train
shape of 1 become a one it makes it real
easy you don't have to remember all the
numbers that we put in 60 or whatever
else is in there you just let it tell
the regressor what model to use and so
we follow our STM with a Dropout layer
now understanding the Dropout layer is
kind of exciting because one of the
things that happens is we can over train
our Network that means that our neural
network will memorize such specific data
that it has trouble predicting anything
that's not in that specific realm to fix
for that each time we run through the
training mode we're going to take 0.2 or
20 percent of our neurons and just turn
them off so we're only going to train on
the other ones and it's going to be
random that way each time we pass
through this we don't over train these
nodes come back in in the next training
cycle we randomly pick a different 20.
and finally they see a big difference as
we go from the first to the second and
third and fourth the first thing is we
don't have to input the shape because
the shape's already the output units is
50 here this Auto the next step out of
automatically knows this layer is
printing out 50 and because it's the
next layer it automatically sets that it
says oh 50 is coming out from our last
layer is coming out you know goes into
the regressor and of course we have our
Dropout and that's what's coming into
this one and so on and so on and so the
next three layers we don't have to let
it know what the shape is it
automatically understands that and we're
going to keep the units the same we're
still going to do 50 units it's still a
sequence coming through 50 units and a
sequence now the next piece of code is
what brings it all together let's go
ahead and take a look at that and we
come in here we put the output layer the
dense layer and if you remember up here
we had the three layers we had lstm drop
out and dense dense just says we're
going to bring this all down into one
output instead of putting out a sequence
we just know I want to know the answer
at this point and let's go ahead and run
that and so in here you notice all we're
doing is setting things up one step at a
time so far we've brought in our way up
here we brought in our data we brought
in our different modules we formatted
the data for training it we set it up
you know we have our wide X train and
our y train we have our source of data
and the answers where we know so far
we're going to put in there we've
reshaped that we've come in and built
our cross we've imported our different
layers and we have in here if you look
we have what uh five total layers now
cross is a little different than a lot
of other systems there's a lot of other
systems put this all in one line and do
it automatic but they don't give you the
options of how those layers interface
and they don't give you the options of
how the data comes in Cross is Cutting
Edge for this reason so even there's a
lot of extra steps in building the model
this has a huge impact on the output and
what we can do with this these new
models from Karas so we brought in our
dense we have our full model put
together a regressor so we need to go
ahead and compile it and then we're
going to go ahead and fit the data we're
going to compile the pieces so they all
come together and then we're going to
run our training data on there and
actually recreate our regressor so it's
ready to be you used so let's go ahead
and compile that and I can go ahead and
run that and if you've been looking at
any of our other tutorials on neural
networks you'll see we're going to use
the optimizer atom atom is optimized for
Big Data there's a couple other
optimizers out there beyond the scope of
this tutorial but certainly Adam will
work pretty good for this and loss
equals mean squared value so when we're
training it this is we want to base the
loss on how bad is our error well we're
going to use the mean squared value for
our error and the atom Optimizer for its
differential equations you don't have to
know the math behind them but certainly
it helps to know what they're doing and
where they fit into the bigger models
and then finally we're going to do our
fit fitting the RN into the training set
we have the regressor.fit X train y
train epics and batch size so we know
where this is this is our data coming in
for the X train our y train is the
answer we're looking for of our data our
sequential input Apex is how many times
we're going to go over the whole data
set we created a whole data set of X
trains so this is each each of those
rows which includes a Time sequence of
60. and that size another one of those
things where Karas really shines is if
you were pulling the save from a large
file instead of trying to load it all
into RAM it can now pick smaller batches
up and load those indirectly we're not
worried about pulling them off a file
today because this isn't big enough to
cause a computer too much of a problem
to run not too straining on the
resources but as we run this you can
imagine what happened if I was doing a
lot more than just one column in one set
of stock in this case Google stock
imagine if I was doing this across all
the stocks and I had instead of just the
open I had open close a high low and you
can actually find yourself with about 13
different variables times 60 because
there's a Time sequence suddenly you
find yourself with a gig of memory
you're loading into your RAM which will
just completely you know if it's just if
you're not on multiple computers or
cluster you can start running into
resource problems but for this we don't
have to worry about that so let's go
ahead and run this and this will
actually take a little bit on my
computer because it's an older laptop
and give it a second to kick in there
there we go all right so we have epic so
this is going to tell me it's running
the first run through all the data and
as it's going through it's batching them
in 32 pieces so 32 lines each time and
there's 1198 I think I said 11.99
earlier but it's 11.98 is off by one and
each one of these is 13 seconds so you
can imagine this is roughly 20 to 30
minutes run time on this computer like I
said it's an older laptop running at 0.9
gigahertz on a dual processor and that's
fine what we'll do is I'll go ahead and
stop go get a drink of coffee and come
back and let's see what happens at the
end and where this takes us and like any
good cooking show I've kind of gotten my
latte I also had some other stuff
running in the background so you'll see
these numbers jumped up to like 19
seconds 15 seconds but you just scroll
through and you can see we've run it
through a hundred steps or 100 epics so
the question is what does all this mean
one of the first things you'll notice is
that our loss can is over here I kind of
stopped at 0.0014 we can see it kind of
goes down until we hit about 0.014 three
times in a row so we guessed our epic
pretty close since our losses remained
the same on there so to find that we're
looking at we're going to go ahead and
load up our test data the test data that
we didn't process yet and a real stock
price data set test eye location this is
the same thing we did when we prepped
the data in the first place so let's go
ahead and go through this code and we
can see we've labeled it part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing we need
to do is go ahead and read the data in
from our test CSV you see I've changed
the path on it for my computer and then
we'll call it the real stock price and
again we're doing just the one column
here and the values from I location so
it's all the rows and just the values
from these that one location that's the
open Stock open let's go ahead and run
that so that's loaded in there and then
let's go ahead and create we have our
inputs we're going to create input here
and this should all look familiar
because this is the same thing we did
before we're going to take our data set
total we're going to do a little pandas
can cat from the datasate train now
remember the end of the data set train
is part of the data going in and let's
just visualize that just a little bit
here's our train data let me just put TR
for train and it went up to this value
here but each one of these values
generated a bunch of columns it was 60
across and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and this value here equals this one and
so we need these top 60 to go into our
new data so to find that we're looking
at we're going to go ahead and load up
our test data the test data that we
didn't process yet and a real stock
price data set test I location this is
the same thing we did when we prepped
the data in the first place so let's go
ahead and go through this code and we
can see we've labeled it part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing we need
to do is go ahead and read the data in
in from our test CSV you see I've
changed the path on it for my computer
and then we'll call it the real stock
price and again we're doing just the one
column here and the values from I
location so it's all the rows and just
the values from these that one location
that's the open Stock open let's go
ahead and run that so that's loaded in
there and then let's go ahead and create
we have our inputs we're going to create
inputs here and this should all look
familiar because this is the same thing
we did before we're going to take our
data set total we're going to do a
little pandas can cat from the data
State train now remember the end of the
data set train is part of the data going
in and let's just visualize that just a
little bit here's our train data let me
just put TR for train and it went up to
this value here but each one of these
values generated a bunch of columns it
was 60 across and this value here equals
this one and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and so we need these tops 60 to go into
our new data because that's part of the
next data or it's actually the top 59.
so that's what this first setup is over
here is we're going in we're doing the
real stock price and we're going to just
take the data set test and we're going
to load that in and then the real stock
price is our data test.test location so
we're just looking at that first column
the open price and then our data set
total we're going to take pandas and
we're going to concat and we're going to
take our data set train for the open and
our data state test open and this is one
way you can reference these columns
we've referenced them a couple different
ways we've referenced them up here with
the one two but we know it's labeled as
a panda set as open so pandas is great
that way lots of Versatility there and
we'll go ahead and go back up here and
run this there we go and you'll notice
this is the same as what we did before
we have our open data set repented our
two different or concatenated our two
data sets together we have our inputs
equals data set total length data set
total minus length of data set minus
test minus 60 values so we're going to
run this over all of our and you'll see
why this works because normally when
you're running your test set versus your
training set you run them completely
separate but when we graph this you'll
see that we're just going to be we'll be
looking at the part that we didn't train
it with to see how well it graphs and we
have our inputs equals inputs.reshapes
or reshaping like we did before we're
Transforming Our inputs so if you
remember from the transform between 0
and 1 and finally we want to go ahead
and take our X test and we're going to
create that X test and for I in range 60
to 80. so here's our X test and we're
appending our inputs I to 60 which
remember is 0 to 59 and I comma 0 on the
other side so that's just the First
Column which is our open column and once
again we take our X test we convert it
to a numpy array we do the same reshape
we did before and then we get down to
the final two lines and here we have
something new right here on these last
two lines let me just highlight those or
or mark them predicted stock price
equals regressor.predicts X test so
we're predicting all the stock and
including both the training and the
testing model here and then we want to
take this prediction and we want to
inverse the transform so remember we put
it between 0 and 1 well that's not going
to mean very much to me to look at a
float number between 0 and 1. I want the
dollar amounts I want to know what the
cash value is and we'll go ahead and run
this and you'll see it runs much quicker
than the training that's what's so
wonderful about these neural networks
once you put them together it takes just
a second to run the same neural network
that took us what a half hour to train
add and plot the data we're going to
plot what we think it's going to be and
we're going to plot it against the real
data what the Google stock actually did
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that in code and let's uh pull this code
up so we have our PLT that's our if you
remember from the very beginning let me
just go back up to the top we have our
matplot library.pi plot as PLT that's
where that comes in and we come down
here we're going to plot and let me get
my drawing thing out again we're going
to go ahead and PLT is basically kind of
like an object it's one of the things
that always threw me when I'm doing
graph in Python because I always think
you have to create an object and then it
loads that class in there well in this
case PLT is like a canvas you're putting
stuff on so if you've done HTML5 you'll
have the canvas object this is the
canvas so we're going to plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
and we're going to give that color red
so it's going to be in bright red we're
going to label it real Google stock
price and then we're going to do our
predicted stock and we're going to do it
in blue and it's going to be labeled
predicted and we'll give it a title
because it's always nice to give a title
to your graph especially if you're going
to present this to somebody you know to
your shareholders in the office and the
X label is going to be time because it's
a Time series and we didn't actually put
the actual date and times on here but
that's fine we just know they're
incremented by time and then of course
the Y label is the actual stock price
plt.legend tells us to build the legend
on here so that the color red and real
Google stock price show up on there and
then the plot shows us that actual graph
so let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like and you can see
here we have a nice graph and let's talk
just a little bit about this graph
before we wrap it up here's our Legend I
was telling you about that's why we have
the legend to show the prices we have
our title and everything and you'll
notice on the bottom we have a Time
sequence we didn't put the actual time
in here now we could have we could have
gone ahead and plotted the X since we
know what the dates are and plotted this
to dates but we also know that it's only
the last piece of data that we're
looking at so last piece of data which
in somewhere probably around here on the
graph I think it's like about 20 percent
of the data probably less than that we
have the Google price and the Google
price has this little up jump and then
down and you'll see that the actual
Google instead of a turn down here just
didn't go up as high and didn't go down
so our prediction has the same pattern
but the overall value is pretty far off
as far as stock but then again we're
only looking at one column we're only
looking at the open price we're not
looking at how many volumes we're traded
like I was pointing out earlier we talk
about stock just right off the bat
there's six columns there's open high
low close volume then there's whether I
mean volume shares then there's the
adjusted open adjusted High adjusted low
adjusted close they have a special
formula to predict exactly what it would
really be worth based on the value of
the stock and then from there there's
all kinds of other stuff you can put in
here so we're only looking at one small
aspect the opening price of the stock
and as you can see here we did a pretty
good job this curve follows the curve
pretty well it has like a little jumps
on it bins they don't quite match up so
this bin here does not quite match up
with that bin there but it's pretty darn
close we have the basic shape of it and
the prediction isn't too far off and you
can imagine that as we add more data in
and look at different aspects in the
specific domain of stock we should be
able to get a better representation each
time we drill in deeper of course this
took a half hour for my program my
computer to train so you can imagine
that if I was running it across all
those different variables might take a
little bit longer to train the data not
so good for doing a quick tutorial like
this so we're going to dive right into
what is Karas we'll also go all the way
through this into a couple tutorials
because that's where you really learn a
lot is when you roll up your sleeves so
we talk about what is cross cross is a
high level deep learning API written in
Python for easy Implement implementation
of neural networks it uses deep learning
Frameworks such as tensorflow Pi torch
Etc is back in to make computation
faster
and this is really nice because as a
programmer there is so much stuff out
there and it's evolving so fast it can
get confusing and having some kind of
high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different neural networks uh is
really powerful it's really powerful to
to have something out really quick and
also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going so
cross works by using complex deep
learning Frameworks such as tensorflow
pipe torch ml played
Etc is a back end for fast computation
while providing a user-friendly and easy
to learn front-end and you can see here
we have the cross API specifications and
under that you'd have like TF Karas for
tensorflow thano cross and so on and
then you have your tensorflow workflow
that this is all sitting on top of
and this is like I said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensorflow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to
um dig as deeply into the heavy and
stuff while still having a very robust
package you can get up and running
rather quickly and it doesn't distract
from the processing time because all the
heavy lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow this is the organization on
top of it so the working principle of
Karas
uh the working principle of karas's
cross uses computational graphs to
express and evaluate mathematical
expressions
you can see here we put them in blue
they have the expression expressing
complex problems as a combination of
simple mathematical operators where we
have like the percentage or in this case
in Python that's usually your left your
remainder or multiplication you might
have the operator of x to the power of
0.3 and it uses useful for calculating
derivatives by using back propagation so
if we're doing with neural networks we
send the error back up to figure out how
to change it this makes it really easy
to do that without really having not
banging your head and having to hand
write everything it's easier to
implement distributed computation and
for solving complex problems specify
input and outputs and make sure all
nodes are connected
and so this is really nice as you come
in through is that as your layers are
going in there you can get some very
complicated uh different setups nowadays
which we'll look at in just a second
and this just makes it really easy to
start spinning this stuff up and trying
out the different models
so we look at Cross models uh cross
model we have a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like the SK learn with their neural
networks and propagation in any of these
setups this should look familiar you
should have your input layer it goes
into your layer one layer two and then
to the output layer
and it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential and this
is the actual code you can see how easy
it is we have a layer that's dense your
layer one as an activation they're using
the relu in this particular example and
then you have your name layer one layer
dense relu name Layer Two and so forth
and they just feed right into each other
so it's really easy just to stack them
as you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model
this is really where things are at this
is new make sure you update your cross
or you'll find yourself running this
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release
and he uses multi-input and multi-output
model the complex model which Forks into
two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your cross input shape
equals 32 by 32 by 3.
you have your dense layers dens 64
activation relu and this should look
similar to what you already saw before
but if you look at the graph on the
right it's going to be a lot easier to
see what's going on you have two
different inputs and one way you can
think of this is maybe one of those is a
small image and one of those is a full
sized image and that feedback goes into
you might feed both of them into one
note because it's looking for one thing
and then only into one node for the
other one and so you can start to get
kind of an idea that there's a lot of
use for this kind of split and this kind
of setup we have multiple information
coming in but the information is very
different even though it overlaps and
you don't want it to send it through the
same neural network and they're finding
that this trains faster and is also has
a better result depending on how you
split the data up and how you Fork the
models coming down
and so in here we do have the two
complex models coming in we have our
image inputs which is a 32 by 32 by
three or three channels or four if
you're having an alpha channel uh you
have your dense your layers dense is 64
activation using the relu very common x
equals dense inputs X layers dense x64
activation equals relu x outputs equals
layers dense 10 X model equals cross
model inputs equals inputs outputs
equals outputs name equals minced model
uh so we've got a little name on there
and again this is this kind of split
here this is setting us up to have the
input go into different areas
so if you're already looking across you
probably already have this answer what
are neural networks uh but it's always
good to get on the same page and for
those people who don't fully understand
neural networks to dive into them a
little bit or do a quick overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations to break down
and solve complex mathical problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer
and you can see here we have the really
standard graph input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer one of the
biggest parts of any data processing is
your data pre-processing
so we always have to touch base on that
with a neural network like many of these
models they're kind of uh when you first
start using them they're like a black
box you put your data in you train it
and you test it and see how good it was
and you have to pre-process that data
because bad data in is bad outputs so in
data pre-processing we will create our
own data examples set with Karas the
data consists of a clinical trial
conducted on 2100 patients ranging from
ages 13 to 100 with a the patients under
65 and the other half over 65 years of
age
we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects due to
their age and you can think of this in
today's world with covid what's going to
happen on there and we're going to go
ahead and do an example of that in our
live Hands-On like I said most of this
you really need to have Hands-On to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and open that up and
open up a Jupiter notebook for doing the
python code in now if you're not
familiar with those you can use pretty
much any of your setups I just like
those for doing demos and showing people
especially shareholders it really helps
because it's a nice visual so let me go
and flip over to our anaconda and the
Anaconda has a lot of cool two tools
they just added datalore and IBM Watson
Studio Cloud into the Anaconda framework
but we'll be in the Jupiter lab or
Jupiter notebook I'm going to do a
jupyter notebook for this because I use
the lab for like large projects with
multiple pieces because it has multiple
tabs where the notebook will work fine
for what we're doing
and this opens up in our browser window
because that's how Jupiter dope so
Jupiter notebook is set to run
it will go under new create a new Python
3 and it creates an Untitled python
we'll go ahead and give this a title and
we'll just call this uh cross
tutorial
and let's change that to Capital there
we go I'm going to just rename that and
the first thing we want to go ahead and
do is uh
did some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy do
some random number Generation
Um I mentioned SK learner your site kit
if you're installing sklearn the sklearn
stuff it's a site kit you want to look
up
that should be a tool of anybody who is
doing data science if you're not if
you're not familiar with the sklearn
toolkit it's huge but there's so many
things in there that we always go back
to and we want to go ahead and create
some train labels and train samples for
training our data
and then just a note of what we're we're
actually doing in here let me go ahead
and change this this is kind of a fun
thing you can do we can change the code
to markdown
and then markdown code is nice for doing
examples once you've already built this
our example data we're going to do
experimental
there we go experimental drug was tested
on 2100 individuals between 13 to 100
years of age half the participants are
under 65 and 95 percent of participants
are under 65. experience no side effects
well 95 percent of participants over 65
experience side effects
so that's kind of where we're starting
at
um and this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more complicated
information
and so we want to go ahead and generate
our setup so we want to do for I and
range and we want to go ahead and create
if you look here we have random integers
train the labels of pen so we're just
creating some random data
uh let me go ahead and just run that
and so once we've created our random
data and if you if I mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from Simply learning they'll send you a
copy of this or you can zoom in on the
video and see how we went ahead and did
our train samples a pin
[Music]
and we're just using this I do this kind
of stuff all the time I was running a
thing on uh that had to do with errors
following a bell-shaped curve on a
standard distribution error and so what
do I do I generate the data on a
standard distribution error to see what
it looks like and how my code processes
it since that was the Baseline I was
looking for in this we're just doing uh
generating random data for our setup on
here
and we could actually go in print some
of the data up let's just do this print
we'll do train
samples and we'll just do the first five
pieces of data in there to see what that
looks like and you can see the first
five pieces of data in our train samples
is 49 85 41 68 19 just random numbers
generated in there that's all that is
and we generated significantly more than
that
let's see 50 up here 1000 yes so there's
one thousand here 1 000 numbers we
generated and we could also if we wanted
to find that out we could do a quick
print the links of it
and so or you could do a shape kind of
thing and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo setup in there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels oh that was our train labels
we also did samples didn't we
so we could also print
do the same thing
oop labels
um and let's change this to
labels
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one zero one zero one zero I
guess that's if they have symptoms or
not one symptoms zero none and so we
want to go ahead and take our trade
labels and we'll convert it into a numpy
array and the same thing with our
samples
and let's go ahead and run that
and we also Shuffle this is just a neat
feature you can do in numpy right here
put my drawing thing on which I didn't
have on earlier I can take the data and
I can Shuffle it so we have our so it's
it just randomizes it that's all that's
doing we've already randomized it so
it's kind of an Overkill it's not really
necessary
but if you're doing a larger package
where the data is coming in and a lot of
times it's organized somehow and you
want to randomize it just to make sure
that that you know the input doesn't
follow a certain pattern
that might create a bias in your model
and we go ahead and create a scalar the
scalar range minimum Max scalar feature
range zero to one
uh then we go ahead and scale the scaled
train samples so we're going to go ahead
and fit and transform the data so it's
nice and scaled and that is the age so
you can see up here we have 49 85 41.
we're just moving that so it's going to
be between 0 and 1. and so this is true
with any of your neural networks
you really want to convert the data to
zero and one otherwise you create a bias
so if you have like a hundred creates a
bias versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated
if you actually start multiplying stuff
because a lot of multiplication addition
going on in there that higher end value
will eventually multiply down and it
will have a huge bias as to how the
model fits it and then it will not fit
as well and then one of the fun things
we can do in jupyter Notebook is that if
you have a variable and you're not doing
anything with it it's the last one on
the line it will automatically print
and we're just going to look at the
first five samples on here it's just
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go
0.9195 0.791 so everything's between 0
and 1.
and that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good it really
helps a lot to do these kind of
print-ups halfway through uh you never
know what's going to go on there
I don't know how many times I've gotten
down and found out that the data sent to
me that I thought was scaled was not
and then I have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
uh so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensorflow and cross
tensorflow
if you don't know the history of
it helps to jump into we'll just use
Wikipedia
careful don't quote Wikipedia on these
things because you get in trouble
but it's a good place to start back in
2011 Google brain built disbelief as a
proprietary machine learning setup
tensorflow became the open source for it
so tensorflow is a Google product and
then it became
open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the de factos when it
comes for neural networks as far as
where we're at so when you see the
tensorflow setup
it's got like a huge following there are
some other setups like the side kit
under the sklearn has their own little
neural network but the tensorflow is the
most robust one out there right now and
cross sitting on top of it makes it a
very powerful tool so we can leverage
both the cross easiness in which we can
build a sequential setup on top of
tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensorflow and then
we have the rest of this is all Karas
here from number two down uh we're going
to import from tensorflow the cross
connection and then you have your
tensorflow across models import
sequential it's a specific kind of model
we'll look at that in just a second if
you remember
from the files that means it goes from
one layer to the next layer to the next
layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that
uh and then we have from tensorflow
across layers we're going to import our
activation and our dense layer
and we have our Optimizer atom
um this is a big thing to be aware of
how you optimize uh your data when you
first do it atoms as good as any atom is
usually there's a number of Optimizer
out there there's about uh there's a
couple main ones but atom is usually
assigned to bigger data
it works fine usually the lower data
does it just fine but atom is probably
the mostly used but there are some more
out there and depending on what you're
doing with your layers your different
layers might have different activations
on them and then finally down here
you'll see our setup where we want to go
ahead and use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics for categorical cross
entropy so we can see how everything
performs when we're done that's all that
is a lot of times you'll see us go back
and forth between tensorflow and then
sidekit has a lot of really good metrics
also for measuring these things again
it's the end of the day you know at the
end of the story how good is your model
do and we'll go ahead and load all that
and then comes the fun part I actually
like to spend hours messing with these
things
and uh four lines of code you're like oh
you're gonna spend hours on four lines
of code
um no we don't spend hours on four lines
of code that's not what we're talking
about when I say spend hours on four
lines of code uh what we have here let
me explain that in just a second we have
a model and it's a sequential model if
you remember correctly we mentioned the
sequential up here where it goes from
one layer to the next
and our first layer is going to be your
input
it's going to be what they call dense
which is uh usually it's just dense and
then you have your input and your
activation
how many units are coming in we have 16
what's the shape What's the activation
and this is where it gets interesting
because we have in here uh relu
on two of these and softmax activation
on one of these
there are so many different options for
what these mean and how they function
how does the relu how does the softmax
function
and they do a lot of different things
um we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different activations
and just some of it is just almost like
you're playing with it
like an artist you start getting a fill
for like a inverse tangent activation or
the 10h activation
takes up a huge processing amount so you
don't see it a lot yet it comes up with
a better solution especially when you're
doing uh when you're analyzing Word
documents and you're tokenizing the
words and so you'll see this shift from
one to the other because you're both
trying to build a better model and if
you're working on a huge data set
it'll crash the system it'll just take
too long to process
and then you see things like soft Max
softmax
generates an interesting
setup
where a lot of these when you talk about
Rayleigh oops let me do this uh regular
there we go relu has a setup where if
it's less than zero it's zero and then
it goes up and then you might have what
they call Lazy setup where it has a
slight negative to it so that the errors
can translate better same thing with
softmax it has a slight laziness to it
so that errors translate better all
these little details
make a huge difference on your model so
one of the really cool things about data
science that I like is you build your
what they call you build to fail and
it's an interesting design setup oops I
forgot the end of my code here
to build a fail is you want the model as
a whole to work so you can test your
model out
so what you can do uh
you can get to the end and you can do
your let's see where was it overshot
down here you can test your test out the
quality of your setup on there and
see what did I do my tensorflow oh here
we go I did it was right above me there
we go we started doing your cross
entropy and stuff like that is you need
a full functional set of code so that
when you run it
you can then test your model out and say
hey it's either this model works better
than this model and this is why and then
you can start swapping in these models
and so when I say spend a huge amount of
time on pre-processing data is probably
eighty percent of your programming time
well between those two it's like 80 20.
you'll spend a lot of time on the models
once you get the model down once you get
the whole code and the flow down set
depending on your data your models get
more and more robust as you start
experimenting with different inputs
different data streams and all kinds of
things and we can do a simple model
summary here
's our sequential here's our layer our
output our parameter
this is one of the nice things about
cross is you just you can see right here
here's our sequential one model boom
boom boom boom everything's set and
clear and easy to read so once we have
our model built the next thing we're
going to want to do is we're going to go
ahead and train that model
and so the next step is of course model
training and when we come in here this a
lot of times it's just paired with the
model because it's so straightforward
it's nice to print out the model set up
so you can have a tracking
but here's our model
the keyword in Cross is compile
Optimizer atom learning rate another
term right there that we're just
skipping right over that really becomes
the meat of
the setup is your learning rate uh so
whoops I forgot that I had an arrow but
I'll just underline it
a lot of times the learning rate's set
to 0.0 uh set to 0.01 depending on what
you're doing this learning rate can
overfit and underfit uh so you'd want to
look up I know we have a number of
tutorials out on overfitting and
underfitting that are really worth
reading once you get to that point in
understanding and we have our loss
sparse categorical cross entropy so this
is going to tell Karas how far to go
until it stops
and then we're looking for metrics of
accuracy so we'll go ahead and run that
and now that we've compiled our model
we want to go ahead and run it fit it so
here's our model fit we have our scale
to train samples
our train labels our validation split in
this case we're going to use 10 percent
of the data for validation
batch size another number you kind of
play with not a huge difference as far
as how it works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit most of the time though a
batch size is between 10 to 100
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we want to go ahead
and Shuffle it we're going to go through
30 epics
and we'll put a verbose of two let me
just go and run this and you can see
right here here's our epic here's our
training here's our loss now if you
remember correctly up here we set the
loss let's see where was it
compiled our data
there we go loss so it's looking at the
sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
much how much does the error go down is
the best way to look at that and you can
see here the lower the number the better
it just keeps going down and vice versa
accuracy we want let's see where's my
accuracy
value accuracy at the end
and you can see 0.619 0.69 0.74 it's
going up we want the accuracy would be
ideal if I made it all the way to one
but we also the loss is more important
because
it's a balance you can have 100 accuracy
and your model doesn't work because it's
overfitted
again you will look up overfitting and
underfitting models
and we went ahead and went through 30
epics it's always fun to kind of watch
your code going
to be honest I usually uh the first time
I run it I'm like oh that's cool I get
to see what it does and after the second
time of running it I'm like I like to
just not see that and you can request
those of course in your code repress the
warnings in the printing
foreign and so the next step is going to
be building a test set and predicting it
now so here we go we want to go ahead
and build our test set and we have just
like we did our training set
a lot of times you just put your your
initial set up but we'll go ahead and do
a separate set on here
and this is just what we did above
there's no difference as far as
the randomness that we're using to build
this set on here the only difference is
that
we are already did our scalar up here
well it doesn't matter because the the
data is going to be across the same
thing but this should just be just
transformed down here instead of fit
transform because you don't want to
refit your data on your testing data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data easy to mistake to make
especially on an example like this where
we're not doing uh you know we're
randomizing the data anyway so it
doesn't matter too much because we're
not expecting something weird
and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model is we take our model we
predict and we're going to do here's our
X scale data batch size 10 verbose and
now we have our predictions in here and
we could go ahead and do a
oh we'll print
predictions
and then I guess I could just put down
predictions in five so we can look at
the first five of the predictions
and what we have here is we have our age
and the prediction on this age versus on
what is what we think it's going to be
but what we think is going to they're
going to have symptoms or not and the
first thing we notice is that's hard to
read because we really want a yes no
answer
so we'll go ahead and just round off the
predictions
using the ARG Max the numpy ARG Max for
prediction so it just goes to a zero one
and if you remember this is a Jupiter
notebook so I don't have to put the
print I could just put in rounded
predictions and we'll just do the first
five and you can see here zero one zero
zero zero so that's what the predictions
are that we have coming out of this is
no symptoms symptoms no symptoms
symptoms no symptoms and just as we were
talking about at the beginning we want
to go ahead and take a look at this
there we go confusion matrixes for
accuracy check
most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the site kit the SK learn metrics site
kit being where that comes from
import confusion Matrix some iteration
tools and of course a nice matplot
Library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to um
I have a nice graph to look at pictures
worth a thousand words
um and then we'll go ahead and call it
CM for confusion Matrix y true equals
test labels y predict rounded
predictions
and we'll go ahead and load in our cm
and I'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting going over the different
plotting code
you can spend like whole we have whole
tutorials on how to do your different
plotting on there but we do have here is
we're going to do a plot confusion
Matrix there's our CM our classes
normalize false title confusion Matrix
cmap is going to be in blues
and you can see here we have to the
nearest cmap titles all the different
pieces whether you put tick marks or not
the marks the classes the color bar
so a lot of different information on
here as far as how we're doing the
printing of the of the confusion Matrix
you can also just dump the confusion
Matrix into a Seaborn and real quick get
an output it's worth knowing how to do
all this when you're doing a
presentation to the shareholders you
don't want to do this on the Fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice like our guys in the back
did and let's go ahead and do this we
forgot to put together our CM plot
labels
we'll go ahead and run that
and then we'll go ahead and call the
little the definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
Matrix that's our the little script we
just wrote and we're going to dump our
data into it so our confusion Matrix our
classes title confusion Matrix and let's
just go ahead and run that
and you can see here we have our basic
setup no side effects 195 had side
effects 200 no side effects that had
side effects so we predicted the 10 of
them who actually had side effects and
that's pretty good I mean I don't know
about you but you know that's five
percent error on this and this is
because there's 200 here that's where I
get five percent is uh divide these both
by by two and you get five out of a
hundred uh you can do the same kind of
math up here not as quick on the Fly
because it's 15 and 195 not an easily
rounded number but you can see here
where they have 15 people
who predicted to have no uh with the no
side effects but had side effects
kind of set up on there and these
confusion Matrix are so important at the
end of the day this is really where
where you show whatever you're working
on comes up and you can actually show
them hey this is how good we are or not
how messed up it is
so this was a uh I spent a lot of time
on some of the parts but you can see
here is really simple we did the random
generation of data but when we actually
built the model coming up here here's
our model summary
and we just have the layers on here that
we built with our model on this and then
we went ahead and trained it and ran the
prediction
now we get a lot more complicated let me
flip back on over here because we're
going to do another demo so that was our
basic introduction to it we talked about
the uh oops there we go okay so
implementing a neural network with Karas
after creating our samples and labels we
need to create our cross neural network
model we will be working with a
sequential model which has three layers
and this is what we did we had our input
layer our hidden layers and our output
layers and you can see the input layer
coming in was the age Factor we had our
hidden layer and then we had the output
are you going to have symptoms or not so
we're going to go ahead and go with
something a little bit more complicated
training our model is a two-step process
we first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set so we
have compiling compiling converts the
code into a form of understandable by
machine
we use the atom in the last example a
gradient descent algorithm to optimize a
model and then we trained our model
which means it let it learn on training
data
and I actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had oops we go back here
um
here's our model that we created
summarized we come down here and we
compile it
so it tells it hey we're ready to build
this model and use it and then we train
it and this is the part where we go
ahead and fit our model and and put that
information in here and it goes through
the training on there and of course we
scaled the data which was really
important to do and then you saw we did
the creating a confusion Matrix with
Karas as we are performing
classifications on our data we need a
confusion Matrix to check the results a
confusion Matrix breaks down the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the accuracy
um and so you can see here this is what
we did with the true positive false
positive true negative false negative
and that is what we went over let me
just scroll down here
on the end we printed it out and you see
we have a nice printout of our confusion
Matrix with the true positive false
positive false negative true negative so
the blue ones we want those to be the
biggest numbers because those are the
better side and then we have our false
predictions on here as far as this one
so I had no side effects but we
predicted
let's see no side effects predicting
side effects and vice versa if getting
your learning started it's half the
battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now uh saving and loading models with
Karas we're going to dive into a more
complicated demo
uh and you're gonna say oh that was a
lot of complication before well if you
broke it down we randomized some data we
created the cross setup we compiled it
we trained it we predicted and we ran
our Matrix
uh so we're gonna dive into something a
lot a little bit more fun is we're going
to do a face mask detection with Karas
so we're going to build a cross model to
check if a person is wearing a mask or
not in real time and this might be
important if you're at the front of a
store this is something today which is
um might be very useful as far as some
of our you know making sure people are
safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
no mask and let's start with a little
bit on the data
and so in my data I have with a mask you
can see they just have a number of
images showing the people in masks and
again if you want some of this
information contact simply learn and
they can send you some of the
information as far as people with and
without masks so you can try it on your
own and this is just such a wonderful
example of this setup on here
so before I dive into the mass detection
talk about being in the current with
covid and seeing if people are wearing
masks this particular example I had to
go ahead and update to a python 3.8
version it might run in a three seven
I'm not sure I haven't I kind of skipped
three seven and installed three eight
so I'll be running in a three Python 3 8
and then you also want to make sure your
tensorflow is up to date because the the
call functional
uh layers with that's where they split
if you remember correctly from back uh
let's take a look at this remember from
here the functional model in a
functional layer allows us to feed in
the different layers into different you
know different nodes into different
layers and split them a very powerful
tool very popular right now in the edge
of where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so I've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and go through
our next example which includes multiple
layers
programming it to recognize whether
someone wears a mask or not and then
saving that model so we can use it in
real time so we're actually almost a
full
end-to-end development of a product here
of course this is a very simplified
version and it'd be a lot more to it
you'd also have to do like recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this so
let's go ahead and jump into that code
and we'll open up a new Python 3 oops
python3
it's working on it there we go
and then we want to go ahead and train
our mask we'll just call this train mask
and we want to go ahead and train mask
and save it
so it's it's uh it's save mask train
mask detection not to be confused with
masking data a little bit different
we're actually talking about our
physical mask on your face
and then from the cross standpoint we
got a lot of imports to do here
and I'm not going to dig too deep on the
Imports we're just going to go ahead and
notice a few of them so we have in here
oops we go alt D there we go
have something to draw with a little bit
here we have our image processing
and the image processing right here let
me underline that
deals with how do we bring images in
because most images are like a a square
grid and then each value in there has
three values for the three different
colors cross and tensorflow do a really
good job of working with that so you
don't have to do all the heavy listening
and figuring out what's going to go on
and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2D this again is how do we deal
with the images and pulling them uh
dropout's a cool thing worth looking up
if you haven't when as you get more and
more into Karas and tensorflow it'll
Auto drop out certain nodes that way
you'll get a better
um the notes just kind of die and they
find that they actually create more of a
bias and help
and they also add processing time so
they remove them and then we have our
flattened that's where you take that
huge array with the three different
colors and you find a way to flatten it
so it's just a one-dimensional array
instead of a two by two by three
uh dense input we did that in the other
one so that should look a little
familiar
go our input our model again these are
things we had on the last one here's our
Optimizer with our atom
um we have some pre-processing on the
input that goes along with bringing in
the data in more pre-processing with
image to array loading the image this
stuff is so nice it looks like a lot of
works you have to import all these
different modules in here but the truth
is is it does everything for you you're
not doing a lot of pre-processing you're
letting the software do the
pre-processing
um and we're gonna be working with the
setting something to categorical
again that's just a conversion from a
number to a category 0 1 doesn't really
mean anything it's like true false
um label binarizer the same thing uh
we're changing our labels around and
then there's our train test split
classification report
our IM utilities let me just go ahead
and scroll down here a notch for these
this is something a little different
going on down here this is not part of
the tensorflow or the SK learn this is
the site kit setup and tensorflow above
the path this is part of opencv and
we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the opencv so if you want
to know more about opencv you'll get a
glance on it in this software especially
the net the second piece when we reload
up the data and hook it up to a video
camera we're going to do that on this
round
but this is part of the opencv thing and
you'll see CV2 is usually how that's
referenced but the IM utilities has to
do with how do you rotate pictures
around and stuff like that
and resize them and then the matplot
library for plotting because it's nice
to have a graph tells us how good we're
doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just a straight OS
access wow so that was a lot of imports
uh like I said I'm not going to spend I
spend a little time going through them
uh but we didn't want to go too much
into them
and then I'm going to create some
variables that we need to go ahead and
initialize we have the learning rate
number of epics to train for and the
batch size and if you remember correctly
we talked about the learning rate to the
negative
4.0001 a lot of times it's 0.001 or
0.001
usually it's in that variation depending
on what you're doing and how many epics
and they kind of play with the epics the
epics is how many times we're going to
go through all the data
and now I have it as two the actual
setup is for 20 and 20 works great the
reason I have it for two is it takes a
long time to process one of the
downsides of Jupiter
is that Jupiter isolates it to a single
kernel so even though I'm on an eight
core processor with 16 dedicated threads
only one thread is running on this no
matter what so it doesn't matter so it
takes a lot longer to run even though
tensorflow really scales up nicely and
the batch size is how many pictures do
we load at once in process again those
are numbers you have to learn to play
with depending on your data and what's
coming in and the last thing we want to
go ahead and do is there's a directory
with a data set we're going to run
uh and this just has images of mass and
not masks
and if we go in here you'll see data set
and you have pictures with mass they're
just images of people with mass on their
face
and then we have the opposite let me go
back up here without masks so it's
pretty straightforward they look kind of
Askew because they tried to format them
into very similar setup on there so
they're they're mostly squares you'll
see some that are slightly different on
here
and that's kind of important thing to do
on a lot of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run in
the in this processing of images up here
and the cross layers and importing and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these and a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with
so you have a couple things going on
there
and so we're now going to be this is now
loading the images and let me see
and we'll go ahead and create data and
labels here's our here's the features
going in which is going to be our
pictures and our labels going out and
then for categories in our list
directory directory and if you remember
I just flashed that at you it had a face
mask or or no face mask those are the
two options
and we're just going to load into that
we're going to append the image itself
and the labels so we're just going to
create a huge array and you can see
right now this could be an issue if you
had more data at some point
thankfully I have a 32 gig hard drive or
Ram
even that doesn't you could do with a
lot less of that probably under 16 or
even eight gigs we'd easily load all
this stuff
and there's a conversion going on in
here I told you about how we are going
to convert the size of the image so it
resizes all the images that way our data
is all identical the way it comes in
and you can see here with our labels we
have without mask without mask without
mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
and then we need to change it to the why
not hot encoding
and this is going to take our
up here we had was it labels and data we
want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to categorical and our labels then equal
a categorical list
we'll run that and again if we do uh
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10. let's do the last 10 just
because
minus 10 to the end there we go just so
we can see what the other side looks
like we now have one that means they
have a mask one zero one zero so on
one being they have a mask and zero no
mask
and if we did this in reverse
I just realized that this might not make
sense if you've never done this before
let me run this
0 1. so 0 is uh do they have a mask on
zero do they not have a mask on one so
this is the same as what we saw up here
without mask one equals the second value
is without mass so with mass without
mask
and that's just a with any of your data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a zero
one output
it causes issues as far as training and
setting it up so we always want to use a
one hot encoder if the values are not
actual linear value or regression values
they're not actual numbers
if they represent a thing
and so now we need to go ahead and do
our trainex test X train y test y train
split test data
and we'll go ahead and make sure it's
going to be random and we'll take 20
percent of it for testing and the rest
for setting it up as far as training
their model
this is something that's become so cool
when they're training these set they
realize we can augment the data what
does augment mean well if I rotate the
data around and I zoom in I zoom out I
rotate it share it a little bit flip it
horizontally
fill mode as they do all these different
things to the data it is able to it's
kind of like increasing the number of
samples I have uh so if I have all these
perfect samples what happens when we
only have part of the face or the face
is tilted sideways or all those little
shifts cause a problem if you're doing
just a standard set of data so we're
going to create an augment in our image
data generator which is going to rotate
zoom and do all kinds of cool things and
this is worth looking up this image data
generator and all the different features
it has
a lot of times I'll the first time
through my models I'll leave that out
because I want to make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know you build the whole
process and then you start adding these
different things in so that you can
better train your model and so we go and
run this and then we're going to load
um and then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have gotten an error if
you hadn't put this piece in right here
I haven't run it myself because the guys
in the back did this we take our base
model and one of the things we want to
do is we want to do a mobile net V2 and
this will be this is a big thing right
here include the top equals false
a lot of data comes in with a label on
the top row so we want to make sure that
that is not the case and then the
construction of the head of the model
that will be placed on the top of the
base model
we want to go ahead and set that up
and you'll see a warning here I'm kind
of ignoring the warning because it has
to do with the size of the pictures and
the weights for input shape
so they'll switch things to defaults to
say hey we're going to Auto shape some
of this stuff for you you should be
aware of that with this kind of imagery
we're already augmenting it by moving it
around and flipping it and doing all
kinds of things to it so that's not a
bad thing in this but another data it
might be if you're working in a
different domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have we have our base
model we're going to do our head model
equals our base model output
and what we've got here is we have an
average pooling 2D pool size 77 head
model
head model flatten so we're flattening
the data so this is all processing and
flattening the images and the pooling
has to do with some of the ways it can
process some of the data we'll look at
that a little bit when we get down to
the lower level in this processing it
um and then we have our dense we've
already talked a little bit about a
dense just what you think about and then
the head model has a drop out of 0.5
what we can do with a dropout
the Dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training so when you actually use the
model it will use all the nodes but this
drops certain ones out and it helps stop
biases from forming so it's really a
cool feature in here they discovered
this a while back we have another dense
mode and this time we're using soft Max
activation lots of different activation
options here softmax is a real popular
one for a lot of things so is a relu
and you know there's we could do a whole
talk on activation formulas uh and why
what their different uses are and how
they work
when you first start out you'll you'll
use mostly the relu and the softmax for
a lot of them just because they're
they're some of the basic setups that's
a good place to start
and then we have our model equals model
inputs equals base model dot input
outputs equals head model so again we're
still building our model here we'll go
ahead and run that
and then we're going to Loop over all
the layers in the base model and freeze
them so they will not be updated during
the first training process
uh so for layer and base model layers
layers.trainable equals false
a lot of times when you go through your
data you want to kind of jump in part
way through I I'm not sure why in the
back they did this for this particular
example but I do this a lot when I'm
working with series and and specifically
in stock data I wanted to iterate
through the first set of 30 Data before
it does anything
um I would have to look deeper to see
why they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model so compiling the model atom
init layer Decay
initial learning rate over epics and we
go ahead and compile our loss is going
to be the binary cross entropy which
will have that print out Optimizer for
opt metrics is accuracy
same thing we had before not a huge jump
as far as the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model so train the
head of the network print info training
head run
now I skipped a little time because
until you'll see the run time here is at
80 seconds per epic takes a couple
minutes for it to get through on a
single kernel
one of the things I want you to notice
on here while we're well it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on so anytime the trainex and
trading y go in there's some Randomness
going on there it is jiggling it around
what's going into our setup of course
we're batch sizing it so it's going
through whatever we set for the batch
values how many we process at a time
and then we have the steps per epic uh
the trainx the batch size validation
data here's our test X and Test Y where
we're sending that in
uh and this again it's validation one of
the important things to know about
validation is our when both our training
data and our test data have about the
same accuracy that's when you want to
stop that means that our model isn't
biased if you have a higher accuracy on
your testing you know you've trained it
and your accuracy is higher on your
actual test data then something in there
is probably has a bias and it's
overfitted
uh so that's what this is really about
right here with the validation data and
validation steps
so it looks like it's let me go ahead
and see if it's done processing looks
like we've gone ahead and gone through
two epics again you could run this
through about 20 with this amount of
data and it would give you a nice
refined model at the end we're going to
stop at two because I really don't want
to sit around all afternoon and I'm
running this on a single thread so now
that we've done this we're going to need
to evaluate our model and see how good
it is and to do that we need to go ahead
and make our predictions
these are predictions on our test X to
see what it thinks they're going to be
so now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then we'll go ahead and go
down here
and we will need to uh turn the index in
because remember it's it's either 0 or 1
it's a zero one zero one so you have two
outputs uh not wearing uh wearing a mask
not wearing a mask and so we need to go
ahead and take that argument at the end
and change those predictions to a zero
or one coming out and then to finish
that off we want to go ahead and let me
just put this right in here and do it
all in one shot we want to show a nicely
formatted classification report so we
can see what that looks like on here
and there we have it we have our
Precision uh it's 97 with the mask
there's our F1 score support without a
mask 97 percent
um so that's pretty high high setup on
there you know you three people are
going to sneak into the store who are
without a mask and the things they have
a mask and there's going to be three
people with a mask that's going to flag
the person at the front to go oh hey
look at this person you might not have a
mask that's if I guess it's a setup in
front of a store
um so there you have it and of course
one of the other cool things about this
is if someone's walking into the store
and you take multiple pictures of them
um you know this is just an it would be
a way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those pictures and make
sure they match or don't match if you're
on the back end and this is an important
step because we're gonna this is just
cool I love doing this stuff uh so we're
going to go ahead and take our model and
we're going to save it so model save
massdetector.model we're going to give
it a name we're going to save the format
in this case we're going to use the H5
format
and so this model we just programmed has
just been saved so now I can load it up
into say another program what's cool
about this is let's say I want to have
somebody work on the other part of the
program well I just save the model they
upload the model now they can use it for
whatever and then if I get more
information and we start working with
that at some point
I might want to update this model and
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where I take this model
and maybe I'm running a prediction on
making money for a company and as my
model gets better
I want to keep updating it and then it's
really easy just to push that out to the
actual end user and here we have a nice
graph you can see the training loss and
accuracy as we go through the epics we
only did the you know only shows just
the one Epic coming in here but you can
see right here as the
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy
it starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're I know
when I work in the site kit with SK
learn neural networks this is what
they're talking about a convergence is
our loss and our accuracy come together
and also up here and this is why I'd run
it more than just two epics as you can
see they still haven't converged all the
way so that would be a cue for me to
keep going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new Python 3
program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it and show you in a live action
get a view of both myself in the
afternoon along with my background of an
office which is in the middle still of
reconstruction for another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
we have our
mobilenet V2 import pre-processing input
so we're still going to need that we
still have our tensorflow image to array
we have our load model that's where most
of this stuff's going on
this is our CV2 or opencv again I'm not
going to dig too deep into that we're
going to flash a little opencv code at
you and we actually have a tutorial on
that coming out
um our numpy array our IM utilities
which is part of the opencv or CV2 setup
and then we have of course time and just
our operating system so those are the
things we're going to go ahead and set
up on here and then we're going to
create
this takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting
so we're going to detect and predict the
mask we have frame face net Mass net
these are going to be generated by our
opencv we have our frame coming in and
then we want to go ahead and create a
mask around the face it's going to try
to detect the face and then set that up
so we know what we're going to be
processing through our model
and then there's a frame shape here this
is just our height versus width that's
all each W stands for they've called it
blob which is a CV2 DNN blob form image
frame so this is reformatting this Frame
it's going to be coming in literally
from my camera and we'll show you that
in a minute that little piece of code
that shoots that in here
uh and we're going to pass the blob
through the network and obtain the face
detections so facenet.set in Port blob
detections face net forward print
detections shape
so this is this is what's going on here
this is that model we just created we're
going to send that in there and I'll
show you in a second where that is but
it's going to be under facenet
and then we go ahead and initialize our
list of faces their corresponding
locations and the list of predictions
from our face mask Network
we're going to Loop over the detections
and this is a little bit more work than
you think as far as looking for
different faces what happens if you have
a crowd of faces
um so We're looping through the
detections and the shapes going through
here
and probability associated with the
detection here's our confidence of
detections
we're going to filter out weak detection
by ensuring the confidence is greater
than the minimum confidence
so we've said it remember zero to one so
0.5 would be our minimal confidence
probably is pretty good
[Music]
um
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if I'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an opencv and I really want
to stick to just the cross part
and so I'm just kind of jumping through
all this code you can get a copy of this
code from Simply learn and take it apart
or look for the opencv coming out
and we'll create a box the box sets it
around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
dimensions of the frame
uh so we create a box around what's
going to we hope it's going to be the
face extract the face Roi convert it
from BGR to RGB Channel
again this is an opencv issue not really
an issue but it has to do with the order
I don't know how many times I forgot to
check the order colors we're working
with opencv because there's all kinds of
fun things when red becomes blue
and blue becomes red and we're going to
go ahead and resize it process it frame
it face frame setup again the face the
CBT color we're going to convert it
we're going to resize it image to array
pre-process the input
pin the face locate face start X start y
and x boy that was just a huge amount
and I skipped over a ton of it but the
bottom line is we're building a box
around the face and that box because the
opencv does a decent job of finding the
face and that box is going to go in
there and see hey does this person have
a mask on it
uh and so that's what that's what all
this is doing on here and then finally
we get down to this where it says
predictions equals massnet.predict faces
batch size 32. so these different images
where we're guessing where the face is
are then going to go through and
generate an array of faces if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it and
that's what's going right here is our
prediction that's the big thing that
we're working for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the location just tells
where on the picture it is and then the
prediction tells us what it is is it a
mask or is it not a mask
all right so we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from disk
and we have our the path that it was
saved in obviously going to put it in a
different path depending on where you
have it or however you want to do it and
how you saved it on the last one where
we trained it
uh then we have our weights path
and so finally our face net here it is
equals
cb2.dnn dot read net
prototext path awaits path and we're
going to load that up on here so let me
go ahead and run that
and then we also need to I'll just put
it right down here I always see it's
separating these things in there and
then we're going to load the actual mass
detector model from disk this is the the
model that we saved so let's go ahead
and run that on there also so this is
pulling in all the different pieces we
need for our model and then the next
part is we're going to create open up
our video
uh and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the open CV
and video setup
let's put this all in as one
there we go so we're going to go ahead
and open up our video we're going to
start it and we're going to run it until
we're done
and this is where we get some real like
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what I like to work about with
images and videos is that when you start
working with images and videos it's all
like right there in front of you it's
Visual and you can see what's going on
uh so we're going to start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream Source zero start
that means it's grabbing my main camera
I have hooked up
um and then you know starting video
you're going to print it out here's our
video Source equals zero start Loop over
the frames from the video stream
oops a little redundancy there uh let me
close
I'll just leave it that's how they had
it in the code so so while true we're
going to grab the frame from the
threaded video stream and resize it to
have the maximum width of 400 pixels so
here's our frame we're going to read it
from our visual stream
we're going to resize it
and then we have a returning remember we
returned from the our procedure the
location and the prediction so detect
and predict mask we're sending it the
frame we're sending it the face net and
the Mast net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on here
and then it returns our location and
predictions and then for our box and
predictions in the location and
predictions
and the boxes is again this is an open
CV set that says hey this is a box
coming in from the location because you
have the two different points on there
and then we're going to unpack the box
and predictions and we're going to go
ahead and do mask without a mask equals
prediction
we're going to create our label no mask
and create color if the label equals
mask l0225 and you know it's going to
make a lot more sense when I hit the Run
button here but we have the probability
of the label
we're going to display the label
bounding box rectangle on the output
frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
show the output from the frame CV2 IM
show frame frame and then the key equals
CV2 weight key one we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our feed
and we're going to do this until we hit
the stop button pretty much
so are you ready for this to see if it
works we've distributed our our model
we've loaded it up into our distributed
code here we've got it hooked into our
camera and we're going to go ahead and
run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
pop-up
and there I am in my office with my
funky headset on
uh and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here no
mask oh no I don't have a mask on I
wonder if I cover my mouth
what would happen
you can see my no mask
goes down a little bit I wish I brought
a mask into my office it's up at the
house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98 chance
that I don't have a mask on and it's
true I don't have a mask on right now
and this could be distributed this is
actually an excellent little piece of
script that you can start you know you
install somewhere on a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then you'd have this really neat setup
saying hey do you have a mask on when
you enter a store or a public
transportation or whatever it is where
they're required to wear a mask
let me go ahead and stop that
now if you want a copy of this code
definitely give us a holler we will be
going into opencv and another one so I
skipped a lot of the opencv code in here
as far as going into detail really
focusing on the cross saving the model
uploading the model and then processing
a streaming video through it so you can
see it that the model works we actually
have this working model that hooks into
the video camera
which is just pretty cool and a lot of
fun
so I told you we're going to dive in and
really Roll Up Our Sleeve and do a lot
of coding today we did the basic uh demo
up above for just pulling it across and
then we went into a cross model uh where
we pulled in data to see whether someone
was wearing a mask or not so very useful
in today's world as far as a fully
running application
and we're going to take a look at image
classification using cross and the basic
setup and we'll actually look at two
different demos on here
uh what's in it for you today what is
image classification
Intel image classification data creating
neural networks with Karas and the vgg16
model
what is image classification
the process of image classification
refers to assigning classes to an entire
image images can be classified based on
different categories like weather it is
a nighttime or daytime shot what the
image represents Etc you can see here we
have mountains looking for mountains I'm
actually doing some
pictures of scenery and stuff like that
in deep learning we perform image
classification by using neural networks
to extract features from images and
classifies them based on these features
and you can see here where it has like
what computer sees and this is oh yeah
we see mostly forests maybe a little bit
of mountains because the way the image
is and this is really where one of the
areas that neural networks really shines
if you try to run this stuff through
more like a linear regression model
you'll still get results but the results
kind of miss a lot of things as the as
the neural networks get better and
better at what they do with different
tools we have out there
uh so Intel image classification data
the data being used is the Intel image
classification data set which consists
of images of six types of land areas
let's say we have Forest building
glaciers and mountains sea and Street
and you can see here is a couple of the
images out of there as a setup in the in
the
Intel image classification data that
they use
and then we're going to go into creating
a neural networks with Karas
the convolutional neural network that we
are creating from scratch looks as shown
below
you'll see here we have our input layer
um
they haven't listed Max pooling so you
have
as you're coming in with the input layer
and this the input layer is actually
before this but the first layer that
it's going to go into is going to be a
convolutional neural network then you
have a Max pooling that pulls those the
the convolutional neural networks
returns in this case they have two of
those that is very standard with
convolutional neural networks one of the
ones that I was looking at earlier that
was standard being used by I want to one
of the larger companies I can't remember
which one for doing a large amount of
identification had two convolutional
neural networks each with their Max
pooling and then about 17 dense layers
after it we're not going to do that
heavy duty of a of a code but we'll get
you ahead in the right direction and
that gives you an idea of what you're
actually going to be looking at when you
look at the flattened part and then the
dense we're talking like 17 dense layers
afterwards
I find that a lot of the stuff I've been
working on I end up maxing it out right
around nine dense layers it really
depends on what you have going in and
what you're working with
and the vgg16 model
uh vgg16 is a pre-trained CNN model
which is used for image classification
it is trained on a large varied data set
and fine-tuned to fit image
classification data sets with ease
and you can see down here we have the
input coming in the convolutional neural
network one to one one to two and then
pooling and then we do two to one two to
two convolutional Network then pooling
three to two and you can see there's
just this huge layering of convolutional
neural networks and in this case they
have five such layers going in and then
in three dents going out or more now
when they took this setup this actually
won an award back in 2019 for this
particular setup
uh and it does it does really good
except that again we only show the three
dense layers here and as you find out
depending on your data going in what you
have set up that really isn't enough on
one of these setups and I'm going to
show you why we restricted it because it
does take up a lot of processing power
in some of these things
so let's go ahead and rope our sleeves
and we're going to look at both the
setups we're going to start with the the
first classification and then we'll go
into the vgg 16 and show you how that's
set up now I'm going to be using
anaconda and let me flip over to my
anaconda so you can see what that looks
like
now I'm running in the Anaconda here
you'll see that I've set up a main
Python 3 8 I always put that in there
because this is where I'm doing like
most of my kind of playing around uh
this is done in Python version 3.8 we're
not going to dig too much into versions
uh at this point you should already have
cross installed on there usually cross
takes a number of extra steps
and then our usual
setup is the numpy the pandas uh your SK
your site kit which is going to be the
SK learn your Seaborn and I'll show you
those in just a minute and then I'm just
going to be in the Jupiter lab where
I've created a new
notebook in here
and let's flip on over there to my blank
notebook
now there's a couple cool things to note
in here is that
um one I use the the Anaconda Jupiter
notebook setup because it keeps
everything separate except for cross
cross is actually running separately in
the back I believe it's a c program
what's nice about that is that it
utilizes the multi-processors on the
computer and I'll mention that just in a
little bit when we actually get down to
running the code
and when we look in here a couple things
to note is here's our
oops I thought I grabbed the other
drawing thing but here's our numpy and
our pandas right here and our operating
system this is our PSI kit you always
import it as SK learn for the
classification report we're going to be
using well usually import like Seabourn
brings in all of your pipelot library
also
kind of nice to throw that in there I
can't remember if we're actually using
Seabourn if they just the people in the
back just threw that together and then
we have the sklearn shuffle for
shuffling data here's our matplot
library that the Seaborn is pretty much
built on
CV2 if you're not familiar with that
that is our image module for importing
the image and then of course we have our
tensorflow down here which is what we're
really working with
and then the last thing is just for
visual effect while we're running this
if you're doing a demo and you're
working with the partners or the
shareholders this TQ DM is really kind
of cool it's an extensible progress bar
for Python and I'll show you that too
remember data science is not I mean you
know most is code when I'm looking
through this code I'm not going to show
half of this stuff to the shareholders
or anybody I'm working with they don't
really care about pandas and all that we
do because we want to understand how it
works
uh so we need to go ahead and import
those different
um
setup on there and then the next thing
is we're going to go ahead and set up
our classes uh now we remember if we had
Mountain Street Glacier Building C and
Forest those were the different images
that we have coming in
and we're going to go ahead and just do
class name labels and we're going to
kind of match that class name of ifri
class name
equals the class names so our labels are
going to match the names up here
and then we have the number of classes
in the print the class names and the
labels and we'll go ahead and set the
image size this is important that we
resize everything because if you
remember with neural networks they take
one size data coming in and so when
you're working with images you really
want to make sure they're all resized
the same setup it might squish them it
might stretch them that generally does
not cause a problem in these and some of
the other tricks you can do with if you
if you need more data and this is one
that's used regularly we're not going to
do it in here is you can also take these
images and not only resize them but you
can tilt them one way or the other crop
parts of them so they process slightly
differently and it'll actually increase
your accuracy of some of these
predictions and so you can see here we
have Mountain equals zero that's what
this class name label is Street equals
one Glacier equals two buildings equals
three C4 Forest equals five
now we did this as an enumerator so each
one is 0 through 5. a lot of times we do
this instead as
um
0 1 0 1 0 1 so you have five outputs and
each one's a zero or a one coming out so
the next thing we really want to do is
we want to go ahead and load the data up
and just put a label in there loading
data just just so you know what we're
doing I'm going to put in the loading
data down here make sure it's well
labeled and we'll create a definition
for this
and this is all part of your
pre-processing
at this point you could replace this
with all kinds of different things
depending on what you're working on and
if you once you download you can go
download this data set send a note to
the simply learned team here in YouTube
and they'll be happy to direct you in
the right direction and make sure you
get this path here so you have the right
whatever wherever you saved it a lot of
times I'll just abbreviate the path or
put it as a sub thing and just get rid
of the directory but again double check
your paths we're going to separate this
into a segment for training and a
segment for testing and that's actually
how it is in the folder let me just show
you what that looks like
so when I have my lengthy path here
where I keep all my programming simply
learned this particular setup we're
working on image classification and
image classification clearly you
probably wouldn't have that lengthy of a
list
and when we go in here you'll see
sequence train sequence test they've
already split this up this is what we're
going to train the data in and again you
can see buildings Force Glacier Mountain
C Street and if we double click let's go
under Forest you can see all these
different Forest images and there's a
lot of variety here I mean we have
winter time we have summertime so it's
kind of interesting you know here's like
a Fallen Tree versus a road going down
the middle that's really hard to train
and if you look at the buildings
a lot of these buildings you're looking
up a skyscraper we're looking down the
setup
here's some trees with one I want to
highlight this one it has trees in it uh
let me just open that up so you can see
it a little closer
the reason I want to highlight this is I
want you to think about this we have
trees growing is this the city or a
forest
so this kind of imagery makes it really
hard for a classifier and if you start
looking at these you'll see a lot of
these images do have trees and other
things in the foreground weird angles
really a hard thing for a computer to
sort out and figure out whether it's
going to be a forest or a city
and so in our loading of data uh one we
have to have the path the directory
we're going to come in here we have our
images and our labels
so we're going to load the images in one
section the label is in another
um
and if you look through here it just
goes through the different folders in
fact let me do this let me
there we go as we look at this we're
just going to Loop through the three the
six different folders that have the
different Landscapes and then we're
going to go through and pull each file
out
and each label so we set the label we
set the folder for file and list here's
our image path join the paths this is
all kind of not General stuff so I'm
kind of skipping through it really quick
and here's our image setup if you
remember we're talking about the images
we have our CV2 reader so it reads the
the image in it's going to go ahead and
take the image and convert it to from
blue green red to red green green blue
this is a CV2 thing almost all the time
it Imports it and instead of importing
it as a standard this used just about
everywhere it Imports it with the BGR
versus RGB RGB is pretty much a standard
in here you have to remember that with
CV2 and then we're going to go ahead and
resize it this is the important part
right here we've set it we've decided
what the size is and we want to make
sure all the images have the same size
on them
and then we just take our images we're
just going to impend the image append
the label and then the images it's going
to turn into a numpy array this just
makes it easier to process and
manipulate and then the labels is also a
numpy array and then we just return the
output append images and labels and we
return the output down here
so we've loaded these all into memory we
haven't talked much there'd be a
different setup in there because there
is ways to feed the files directly into
your cross model but we want to go ahead
and just load them all because it's
really
he for today's processing and what our
computers can handle that's not a big
deal
and then we go ahead and set the train
images train labels test images test
labels and that's going to be returned
in our output append and you can see
here we did um images and labels set up
in there and it just loads them in there
so we'll have these four different
categories let me just go ahead and run
that
uh
so now we've gone ahead and loaded
everything on there
and then if you remember from before uh
we imported let me just go back up there
Shuffle here we go here's our SK learn
utilities import Shuffle and so we want
to take these labels and shuffle them
around a little bit
um just mix them up so it's not having
the same if you run the same process
over and over uh then you might run into
some problems on there
and just real quick let's go ahead and
do
a plot so we can just you know we've
looked at them as far as from outside of
our code we pulled up the files and I
showed you what that was going on we can
go ahead and just display them here too
and I tell you when you're working with
different people
this should be highlighted right here
um this thing is like when I'm working
on code and I'm looking at this data and
I'm trying to figure out what I'm doing
I skipped this process
the second I get into a meeting and I'm
showing what's going on to other people
I skip everything we just did so and go
right to here where we want to go ahead
and display some images and take a look
at it
and in this display I've taken them and
I've resized the images to 20 by 20.
that's pretty small uh so we're going to
lose just a massive amount of detail and
you can see here these nice pixelated
images I might even just stick with the
folder showing them what images we're
processing
again this is yeah be a little careful
this
maybe resizing it was a bad idea in fact
let me try it without resizing it see
what happens oops so I took out the
image size and then we put this straight
in here one of the things again this is
um
put the D there we go one of the things
again that we want to note
whenever we're working on these things
uh is the CV2
there are so many different uh image
classification setups it's really a
powerful package when you're doing
images
but you do need to switch it around so
that it works with the pi plot and so
make sure you take your numpy array and
change it to a u integer 8 format
because it comes in as a float otherwise
you'll get some weird images down there
and so this is just basically we've
split up or we've created a plot
we went ahead and did the plot 20 by 20
um or plot figure size is 20 by 20 and
then we're doing 25 so 5x5 subplot
nothing really going on here too
exciting but you can see here where we
get the images and really when you're
showing people what's going on this is
what they want to see so you skip over
all the code and you have your meeting
you say okay here's our images of the
building
um don't get caught up in how much work
you do get caught up in what they want
to see so if you want to work in data
science that's really important to know
and this is where we're going to start
having fun uh here's our model this is
where it gets exciting when you're
digging into these models
and you have here let me get
there we go
when you have here if you look here
here's our convolutional neural network
2D
and 2D is an image you have two
different dimensions x y and even though
there's three colors it's still
considered 2D if you're running a video
you'd be convolutional neural network 3D
if you're doing a series going across a
Time series it might be one D
and on these you need to go ahead and
have your convolutional neural network
if you look here there's a lot of really
cool settings going on to dig into we
have our input shape so everything's
been set to 150 by 150 and it has of
course three different color schemes in
it that's important to notice
activation
default is relu this is small amounts of
data being processed on a bunch of
little
um neural networks
and right here is the 32 that's how many
of these convolutional neural networks
are being strung up on here and then the
three by three
uh when it's doing its steps it's
actually looking at a little three by
three Square on each image and so that's
what's going on here and with
convolutional neural networks the window
floats across and adds up all these
numbers going across on this data and
then eventually it comes up with a 30 in
this case 32 different feature options
that it's looking for and of course you
can change that 32 you can change the
three by three so you might have a
larger setup you know if you're going
across 150 by 150 that's a lot of steps
so we might run this as 15 by 15.
there's all kinds of different things
you can do here
we're just putting this together again
that would be something you would play
with to find out which ones are going to
work better on this setup and there's a
lot of play involved
that's really where it becomes an art
form is guessing at what that's going to
be the second part I mentioned earlier
and I can only begin to highlight this
when you get to these dense layers one
is the activation is a relu they use a
raylu and a soft Max here
um it's a whole a whole setup just
explaining why these are different
um
and how they're different because
there's also an exponential there's a
tangent in fact there's just a ton of
these and you can build your own custom
activations depending on what you're
doing
a lot of different things go into these
activations there are two or three major
thoughts on these activations and
Rayleigh and softmax are uh
well rayleu
you're really looking at just the number
you're adding all the numbers together
and you're looking at euclidean geometry
ax plus b x 2 plus c x three plus bias
with softmax this belongs to the party
of
um it's activated or it's not except
it's they call it soft Max because when
you get the the to zero instead of it
just being zero uh it's actually
slightly
a little bit less than zero so that when
it trains it doesn't get lost
um there's a whole series of these
activations another activation is the
tangent
um where it just drops off and you have
like a very narrow area where you have
from minus one to one or exponential
which is zero to one so there's a lot of
different ways to do the activation
again we can do that would be a whole
separate lesson on here we're looking at
the convolutional neural network and
we're doing the two pools this is so
common you'll see two two convolutional
neural networks depth on top of each
other each with its own Max pole
underneath and let's go ahead and run
that so we built our model there and
then we need to go ahead and
compile the model so let's go ahead and
do that
uh we are going to use the atom
Optimizer the bigger the data the atom
fits better on there just some other
Optimizer but I think atom is a default
I don't really play with the optimizer
too much that's like the you if once you
get a model that works really good you
might try some different optimizers but
atoms usually the most and then we're
looking at loss
pretty standard we want to minimize our
lot we want to
maximize the loss of error and then
we're going to look at accuracy
everybody likes theocracy I'm going to
tell you right now
I start talking to people and like okay
what's what's the loss on this and that
and as a data science yeah I want to
know how the lot what's going on with
that we'll show you why in a minute
but everybody wants to see accuracy we
want to know how accurate this is
and then we're going to run the fit and
I wanted to do this just so I can show
you
even though we're in Python setup in
here where Jupiter notebook is using
only a single processor I'm going to
bring over my little CPU tool this is
eight cores on 16 dedicated threads so
it shows up as 16 processors
and actually I got to run this and then
move it over so we're going to run this
and hopefully it doesn't destroy my mic
and as it comes in you can see it's
starting to do go through the epics and
we said I said it for five epics
and then this is really nice because
cross uses all the different uh threads
available
so it does a really good job of doing
that this is going to take a while if
you look at here it's uh
ETA 2 minutes and 25 seconds 24 seconds
so this is roughly two and a half
minutes per epic and we're doing five
epics so this is going to be done in
roughly 15 minutes
I don't know about you but I don't think
you want to sit here for 15 minutes
watching The Green bars go across so
we'll go ahead and let that run
and there we go uh there was our 15
minutes it's actually less than that uh
because I did when I went in here
realized that uh where was it
here we go here's our model compile
here's our model flip fit and here's our
epics so I did four epics so a little
bit better a little more like 10 to 11
minutes instead of uh doing the full
15. and when we look at this here's our
model we did we talked about the
compiler here's our history we're going
to history equals the model fit we'll go
into that in just a minute
and we're looking at is we have our
epics here's our validation split so as
we train it uh we're weighing the
accuracy versus you kind of pull some
data off to the side while you're
training it
and the reason we do that is that you
don't want to overfit and we'll look at
that chart in just a minute
uh here's back size
this is just how many images you're
sending through at a time the larger the
batch it actually increases the
processing speed and there's reasons to
go up or down on the batch size because
of the uh the the smaller the batch
there's a certain point where you get
two large of a batch and it's trying to
fit everything at once
so yeah 128 is kind of big depends on
the computer you're on what it can
handle
and then of course we have our crane
images and our train labels going in
telling it what we're going to train on
and then we look at our four epics here
uh here's our accuracy we want the
accuracy to go up and we get all the way
up to 0.83 or 83 percent now this is
actual percentage based pretty much and
we can see over here our loss we want
our loss to go down really fluctuates uh
1.2.77 0.48
uh so we have a lot of things going on
there let's go ahead and graph those
turn that up
and our team in the back did a wonderful
job of putting together this basic plot
set up here's our subplot coming in
we're going to be looking at um
uh from the history we're going to see
that the accuracy and the value accuracy
labels and set up on there and we're
going to also look at loss and value
loss so you can see what this looks like
what's really interesting about this
setup and let me let me just go ahead
and show you because without actually
seeing the plots it doesn't make a whole
lot of sense
it's just basic plotting of of the data
using the pi plot Library
and I want you to look at this this is
really interesting
um when I ran this the first time I had
very different results
and they they vary greatly and you can
see here our accuracy continues to climb
um and there's a cross over here
put it in here right here's our
crossover
and I point that out because as we get
to the right of that crossover where our
accuracy and we're like oh yeah I got
0.8 percent we're starting to get an
overfit here that's what this this
switchover means
um as our value as a training set versus
a value accuracy stays the same and so
that this is the one we're actually
really want to be aware of and where it
crosses
that's kind of where you want to stop at
and we can see that also with the train
loss versus the value loss right here we
did one Epic and look how it just
flat lines right there with our loss
so really one Epic is probably enough
and you're going to say wow okay point
eight percent
um certainly if I was working with the
shareholders
um telling them that it has an 80
accuracy isn't quite true and we'll look
at that a little deeper it really comes
out here that the accuracy of our actual
values is closer to point four one
percent right here even after running at
this number of times and so you really
want to stop right here at that
crossover one Epic would have been
enough so the data is a little
overfitted on this when we do four epics
and uh oops there we are okay
my drawing won't go away
um let me see if I can get there we go
um for some reason I've killed my
drawing ability and my recorder
I took a couple extra clicks uh so let's
go ahead and take a look at our actual
test loss so you see where it crosses
over that's where I'm looking at that's
where we start over fitting the model
and this is where if we were going to go
back and continually upgrade the model
we would start taking a look at the
images and start rotating them we might
start playing with the convolutional
neural network instead of doing the
three by three window we might expand
that or you know find different things
that might make a big difference as far
as the way it processes these things
so let's go ahead and take a look at our
uh our test loss now remember we had our
training data now we're going to look at
our test images and our test labels
for our test loss here this is just
model evaluate just like we did fit up
here where was it
um one more model fit with our training
data going in now we're going to
evaluate it on the and and this data has
not been touched yet so this model has
never seen this data this is on uh
completely new information as far as the
model is concerned of course we already
know what it is from the labels we have
and this is what I was talking about
here's the actual accuracy right here
0.48 or 4847 so this 49 of the Time
guesses what the image is
uh and I mean really that's the bottom
dollar uh does this work for what you're
needing does 49 work do we need to
upgrade the model more
um in some cases this might be uh oh
what was I doing I was working on uh
stock evaluations and
we were looking at what stocks were the
top performers well if I get that 50
correct on top performers uh I'm good
with that
um that's actually pretty good for stock
evaluation in fact the number I had for
stock was more like
30 something percent as far as being a
top performer stock much harder to
predict but at that point you're like
well you'll make money off of that so
again this number right here depends a
lot on the domain you're working on
foreign
bring this home a little bit more as far
as looking at the different setup in
here and one of the from sklearn if you
remember actually let's go back to the
top we had the classification report and
this came in from our sklearn or PSI kit
setup and that's right here you can see
it right here on the
see there we go
classification report right here
sklearnmetrics import classification
report this we're going to look at next
a lot of this stuff uh depends on who
you're working with
so when we start looking at precision
you know this is like for each value I
can't remember what 111 was probably
mountains so if 44 percent is not good
enough if you're doing like
um you're in the medical department and
you're doing cancer is it is this
cancerous or not and I'm only 44
accurate not a good deal you know I
would not go with that
um so it depends on what you're working
with on the different labels and what
they're used for Facebook
you know 44 I'm guessing the right
person I would hope it does a little bit
better than that
um but here's our main accuracy this is
what almost everybody looks at they say
oh 48 that's what's important
um again it depends on what domain
you're in and what you're working with
and now we're going to do the same model
oops somehow I got my there it goes I
thought I was gonna get stuck on there
again uh this time we're going to be
using the vgg 16. and remember this one
is uh all those layers
going into it so it's basically a bunch
of convolutional neural networks getting
smaller and smaller on here and so we
need to go ahead and um import all our
different stuff from Karas we're
importing the main one is the V
g16 setup on there and just aim that
there we go
um
there's kind of a pre-processing images
applications pre-process input this is
all part of the VG g16 setup on there
and once we have all those we need to go
ahead
and create our model
and we're just going to create a vgg16
model in here inputs model inputs
outputs model inputs I'm not going to
spend as much time as they did on the
other one uh we're going to go through
it really quickly one of the first
things I would do is if you remember in
Cross you can trade treat a model like
you would a layer
and so at this point I would probably
add a lot of dense layers on after the
vgg16 model and create a new model with
all of those things in there and we'll
go ahead and run this because here's our
model coming in and our setup
and I'll take it just a moment to
compile that what's funny about this is
I'm waiting for it to download the
package since I pre-ran this
um it takes it a couple minutes to
download the vgg 16 model into here and
so we want to go ahead and train
features for the model we're going to
predict that we're going to predict the
train images and we're going to test
features on the predict test images on
here
and then I told you I was going to
create another model too and the people
in the back did not disappoint me they
went ahead and did just that
and this is really an important part
um this is worth stopping for I told you
I was going to go through this really
quick
so here's our uh
we at we have our model two
um coming in and we've created a model
up here with the vgg16 model equals
model inputs model inputs and so we have
our vgg16 this has already been
pre-programmed uh and then we come down
here and I want you to notice on this
right here layered model two layers
minus four to One X layer X
um
we're basically taking this model and
we're adding stuff on to it and so uh
we've taken we've just basically
duplicated this model we could have done
the same thing by using model up here as
a layer we could have the input go to
this model
and then have that go down here so we've
added on this whole setup this whole
block of code from 13 to 17 has been
added on to our vgg16 model and we have
a new model with the layer my input and
X down here
let's go ahead and run that and compile
it and that was a lot to go through
right there when you're building these
models this is the part that gets so
complicated
did you get stuck playing it and yet
it's so fun uh it's like a puzzle how
can I Loop these models together
and in this case you can see right here
that the layers we're just copying
layers over and adding each layer in
this is one way to build a new model
and we'll go ahead and run that
like I said the other way is you can
actually use the model as a layer I've
had a little trouble playing with it
sometimes when you're using the Straight
model over
you run into issues
um
it seems like it's going to work and
then you mess up on the input and the
output layers there's all kinds of
things that come up
let's go ahead and do the new model
we're going to compile it again here's
our metrics accuracy sparse categorical
loss pretty straightforward just like we
did before you got to compile the model
and just like before we're going to take
our create a history on the history is
going to be a new model fit train 128
and just like before if you remember
when we started running this stuff we're
going to have to go ahead and it's going
to light up our setup on here and this
is going to take a little bit to get us
all set up it's not going to just happen
in a couple minutes so let me go ahead
and pause the video and run it and then
we'll talk about what happened
okay now when I ran that these actually
took about six minutes each
um so it's a good thing I put it on hold
we did four epics I actually had this
topic says at 10 and switch it to four
because I didn't want to wait an hour
and you can see here our accuracy
um and our loss numbers going down and
just at a glance
it actually performed if you look at the
accuracy
0.2658 so our accuracy is going down or
you know 26 percent
um 34 35 percent and you can see here at
some point it just kind of kicks the
bucket again this is overfitting
that's always an issue when you're
running on programming these different
neural networks
and then we're going to go ahead and
plot the accuracy history we built that
nice little subroutine up above so we
might as well use it
and you can see it right here
there's that crossover again
and if you look at this look how the how
the the red shifts up how the uh our
loss functions and everything crosses
over we're over fitting after one Epic
we're clearly
not helping the problem or doing better
we're just going to it's just going to
Baseline this one actually shows what
the training versus the loss
value loss maybe second epic so on here
we're now talking more between the first
and the second epic and that also shows
kind of here so somewhere in here it
starts over fitting
and right about now you should be saying
uh oh uh something went wrong there I
thought that
we went up here and ran this
look at this we have the accuracy up
here is hitting that 48 percent
and we're down here
um
you look at the score down here that
looks closer to 20 percent not nearly
anywhere in the ballpark of what we're
looking for
and we'll go ahead and run it through
the the actual test features here and
and there it is
um we actually run this on the Unseen
data and everything
0.18 or 18 percent
um I don't know about two but I wouldn't
want you know at 18 this did a lot worse
than the other one
I thought this was supposed to be the
supermodel the model that beats all
models the vgg16 that won the awards and
everything
well the reason is is that
um one we're not pre-processing the data
so it needs to be more there needs to be
more
um as far as like rotating the data at
you know 45 degree angle taking partials
of it so you can create a lot more data
to go through here and that would
actually greatly change the outcome on
here and then we went up here we only
added a couple dense layers and we added
a couple convolutional neural networks
this huge pre-trained setup is looking
for a lot more information coming in as
far as how it's going to train and so
this is one of those things where I
thought it would have done better and I
had to go back and research it and look
at it and say well why didn't this work
why am I getting only uh 18 here instead
of 44 or better
and that would be wise it doesn't have
enough training data coming in and again
you can make your own training data so
it's not that we have a shortage of data
it's that that some of that has to be
switched around and moved around a
little bit
and this is interesting right here too
if you look at the Precision
we're getting it on number two and yet
we had zero on everything else so for
some reason it's not seeing uh the
different variables in here so it'd be
something else to look in and try to
track down
um
and that probably has to do with the
input but you can see right here we have
a really good solid 0.48 up here and
that's where I'd really go with is
starting with this model and then we
look at this model and find out why are
these numbers not coming up better is it
the data coming in where's the setup on
there
and that is the art of data science
right there is finding out which models
work better and why
so sequential models so what makes this
a sequential model sequential models are
linear stacks of layers where one layer
leads to the next it is simple and easy
to implement and you just have to make
sure that the previous layer is the
input to the next layer
so you have used for plain stack of
layers where each layer has one input
and one output tensor and this is what
tensorflow is named after is each one of
these layers is like a tensor each node
is a tensor and then the layer is also
considered a tensor of values
and it's used for simple classifier
declassifier models you can it's also
used for regression models too so it's
not just about this is something this is
a teapot this is a cat this is a dog
it's also used for generating
um regret the actual values you know
this is worth ten dollars that's worth
thirty dollars the weather's going to be
90 degrees out or whatever it is so you
can use it for both classifier and
declassifier models
and one more note when we talk about
sequential models the term sequential is
used a lot and it's used in different
areas in different notations when you're
in data science so when we talk about
time series we'll talk about sequential
that is something very different uh
sequential in this case means it goes
from the input to layer 1 to layer 2 to
the output so it's very directional it's
important to note this because if you
have a sequential model can you have a
non-sequential model and the answer is
yes
if you master the basics of a sequential
model you can just as easily have
another model that shares layers you can
have another model where the you have an
input coming in and it splits and then
you have one set that's doing one set of
nodes maybe they're doing a yes no kind
of node where it's either putting out a
zero or a one a classifier and the other
one might be regression it's just
processing numbers and then you
recombine them for the output that's
what they call across the cross AP AI
so there's a lot of different
availabilities in here and all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as
encoding and decoding and all kinds of
things and you can share layers and
things like that
we're just focusing on the basic cross
model with the sequential model
so let's dive into the meat of the
matter let's go and do a demo on here
today's demo in this demo we'll be
performing flower classification using
sequential model and cross and we'll use
our model to classify between five
different types of flowers
now for this demo and you can do this
demo whatever platform you want or
whatever
user interface for developing python I'm
actually using anaconda and then I'm
using Jupiter notebooks to develop in
and if you're not familiar with this you
can go under environment once you've
created an environment you can come in
here to open a terminal window and if
you don't have the different modules in
here you can do your conda install
whatever module it is
just happened that this particular setup
didn't have a Seaborn in it which I
already installed uh
so here's our anaconda and then I'm
going to go back
and start up my Jupiter notebook
where I already created a new python
project python3 come in Python 3.8 on
this particular one
sequential model for flowers
so lots of fun there so we're going to
jump right into this the first thing is
to make sure you have all your modules
installed
so if you don't have numpy pandas
matplot library in Seabourn in the cross
and SK learn or Sidekicks not actually
sklearn you'll need to go ahead and
install all of those
now having done this for years and
having switched environments and doing
different things
I get all my imports done and then we
just run it and if we get an error we
know we have to go back and install
something
um right off the bat though we have
numpy pandas matplot Library Seaborn
these are built on top of each other
panda is a data frame and built on top
of numpy the uh
data array
and then we bring in our SK learn or
scikit this is the site kit setup SCI
kit even though you use SK learn to
bring it in it's a site kit and then our
cross we have our pre-processing the
images image data generator
or model this is our basic model our
sequential model
and then we bring in from Cross layers
import dents optimizers
these optimizers a lot of them already
come in these are your different
optimizers and it's almost a lot of this
is so automatic now Adam
is the a lot of times the default
because you're dealing with a large data
and then we get our SGD which is uh
smaller data does better on smaller
pieces of data and I'm not going to go
into all of these uh different
optimizers we didn't even use these in
the actual demo you just have to be
aware that they are different optimizers
and the Digger the more you dig into
these models you'll hit a point where
you do need to play with these a little
bit but for the most part leave it at
the default when you're first starting
out
and we're doing just the sequential
you'll see here layers dense
and then if we come down a little bit
more when they put this together and
they're running the dense layers you'll
also see they have drop out they have
flattened they have activation they have
the convolutional layer 2D Max pooling
2D batch normalization
what are all these layers and we get to
the model we're going to talk about them
a lot of times when you're just starting
you can just import cross dot layers and
then you have your drop out your
flattened your convolutional neural
network 2D
and we'll we'll cover what these do in
the actual example when we get down
there what I want you to take from here
though is you need to run your Imports
and load your different aspects of this
and of course your tensorflow TF because
this is all built on tensorflow
and then finally import random is RN
just for random generation
and then we get down here we have our
CV2
that is your open image or your opencv
they call it for processing images
that's what the cvd 2 is
uh we have our tqdm
the TQ DM is for um is a progress bar
just a fancy way um of adding when
you're running a process you can view
the bar going across in the Jupiter uh
setup not really necessary but it's kind
of fun to have
um we want to be able to shuffle some
files uh again these are all different
things pills and other
um
image processor it goes with the CV2 a
lot of times you'll see both of those
and so we run those we've got to bring
them all in
and the next thing is to set up our
directories
and so we come into the directories
there's an important thing to note on
here other than we're looking at a lot
of flowers which is fun
uh as we get down here we have our
directory archive flowers that just
happens to be where the different files
for different flowers are put in
we're denoting an X and a z and the x is
the date of the image and the Z is the
tag for it what kind of flower is this
uh and the image size is really
important because we have to resize
everything if you have a neural network
and if you remember from our neural
networks let me flip back to that slide
we look at this slide we have two input
nodes here with an image you have an
input node depending on how you set it
up for each pixel and that pixel has
three different color schemes usually in
it sometimes four so if you have a
picture that's 150 by 150 you multiply
150 times 150 times three that's how
many nodes input layers coming in that
means this is a massive input a lot of
times you think oh yeah it's just a
small amount of data or something like
that no it's a full image coming in and
then you have your hidden layers A lot
of times they match what the image size
is coming in so each one of those is
also just as big and then we get down to
just a single output
so that's kind of a thing to note in
here what's going on behind the scenes
and of course each one of these layers
has a lot of processes and stuff going
on
and then we have our different
directories on here let me go ahead and
run that so I'm just setting the
directories that's all this is archive
flowers Daisy sunflower tulip dandelion
Rose just our different directories that
we're going to be looking at
and then we want to go ahead and we need
to assign labels remember we defined x
and z
so we're just going to create a
definition here
and the first thing is a return flower
type okay it just returns it what kind
of flower it is I guess assign the label
to it but we're going to go ahead and
make our train data
and when you look at this there's a
couple things to take away from here the
first one is we're just appending right
onto our numpy array the image we're
going to let numpy handle all that
different aspects as far as 150 by 150
by three we just dump it right into the
numpy which makes it really easy we
don't have to do anything funky on the
processing and we want to leave it like
that and I'm going to talk about that in
a minute and then of course we have to
have the string a pin the label on there
and I want you to notice right here
we're going to read the image in
and then we're going to size it and this
is important because we're just changing
this to 150 by 150 we're resizing the
image so it's uniform every image comes
in identical to the other ones this is
something that's so important is
um when you're resizing or reformatting
your data you really have to be aware of
what's going on
with images it's not a big deal because
with an image you just resize it so it
looks squishy or spread out or stretched
the neural network picks up on that and
it doesn't really change how it
processes it
so let's go ahead and run that
and now we've got our definition set up
on there
and then we want to go ahead and make
our
training data so make the train data uh
daisy flower daisy directory print
length of X so here we go let's go ahead
and run that and we're just loading up
the flower daisy so this is going all in
there and it's setting it's adding it in
to the our setup on there that to our x
and z set up and we see we have 769.
um and then of course you can see this
nice bar here this is the bar going
across is that little added uh code in
there that just makes it really cool for
doing demos not necessarily when you're
building your own model or something
like that but if you're going to display
this to other people adding that little
what was it called um
tqdm I can never remember that but the
tqdm module in there is really nice and
we'll go ahead and do sunflowers and of
course you could have just created an
array of these
but this has an interesting problem
that's going to come up and I want to
show you something
it doesn't matter how good the people in
the back are or how good you are
programming
errors are going to come up and you got
to figure out how to handle them and so
when we get all the way down to
the
where is it dandelion here's our
dandelion directory we're going to build
um
Jupiter has some cool things it does
which makes this really easy to deal
with
but at the same time you want to go back
in there depending on how many times you
rerun this how many times you pull this
so when you're finding errors
I'm going in here there's a couple
things you can do and we're just gonna
um oh it wasn't there it is there's our
error I knew there was an error
this processed
1062 out of 1065.
now I can do a couple things one I could
go back into our definition
and I can just put in here try and so if
it has a bad conversion because this is
where the error is coming from uh just
skip it that's one way to do it
um when you're doing a lot of work in
data science and you look at something
like this where you're losing three
points of data at the end you just say
okay I lost three points who cares or
you can go in there and try to delete it
um it really doesn't matter for this
particular demo
and so we're just going to leave that
Arrow right alone and skip over because
it's already added all the other files
in there and this is a wonderful thing
about Jupiter notebook
is that I can just continue on there in
the x and z which we're creating is
still running and we'll just go right
into the next flower row so all these
flowers are in there
that's just a cool thing about Jupiter
notebook
and then we can go ahead and just take a
quick look and see
what we're dealing with and this is of
course really when you're dealing with
the other people and showing them stuff
this is just kind of fun where we can
display it on the plot Library here
and we're just going to go through and
um let's see what we got here uh looks
like
we're gonna do like five of each of them
I think
is that how they set this up
um
plot Library five by two okay oh I see
how they did it okay so two each so we
have five by two set up on our axes and
we're just going to go in and look at a
couple of these flowers
it's always a good thing to look at some
of your data no matter what you're doing
we've reformatted this to 150 by 150 you
can see how it really blurs this one up
here on the Tulip that is that resize to
150 by 150. and these are what's
actually going in these are all 150 by
150 images you can check the dimensions
on the side
and you can see just a quick sampling of
the flowers we're actually going to
process on here
and again like I said at the beginning
most of your work in data science is
reprocessing
this different information so we need to
go ahead and take our labels
and run a label encoder on there and
then we're just going to Ellie is a
label encoder one of the things we
imported
and then we always use the fit
to categorical y comma 5 x here's our
array
X so if you look at this here's our fit
we're going to transform Z
that's our Z array we created
and then we have Y which equals that and
then we go ahead and do to categorical
we want five different categories
and then we create our x uh NP array of
x x equals x over 255. so what's going
on here there's two different
Transformations one we've turned our
categories into zero one two three four
five as the output and we have taken our
x-ray
and remember the X array is three values
of your different colors
this is so important to understand when
we do this across a numpy array this
takes every one of those three colors so
we have 150 by 150 pixels
out of those 150 by 150 pixels they each
have three
um color arrays and those color arrays
range from 0 to 250. so when we take the
x equals x over 255
I'm sorry range between 0 to 255. this
converts all those pixels to a number
between 0 and 1. and you really want to
do that when you're working with neural
networks now if you do a linear
regression model it doesn't affect it as
much and so you don't have to do that
conversion if you're doing straight
numbers but when you're running neural
networks if you don't do this you're
going to create a huge bias and that
means they'll do really good on
predicting one or two things and they'll
just totally die on a lot of other
predictions
so now we have our
X and Y values X being the data n y
being our known output
and with any good setup we want to
divide this data into our training so we
have X train we have our X test this is
the data we're not going to program the
model with and of course your y train
corresponds to your X train and your y
test corresponds to your X test the
outputs
and this is when we do the train test
split this was from the site kit sklearn
we imported train test split and we're
just going to go ahead and do the test
size at about a quarter of the data 0.25
and of course random is always good
this is such a good tool I mean
certainly you can do your own division
um
you know you could just take the first
you know 0.25 of the data or whatever to
the length of the data not real hard to
do
but this is randomized so if you're
running this test a few times you can
kind of get an idea whether it's going
to work or not
sometimes what I will do
is I'll just split the data into three
parts
and then I'll test it on two with one
being the or I train it on two of those
parts with one being the test and I
rotate it so I come up with three
different answers which is a good way of
finding out just how good your model is
but for setting up let's stick with the
X train X test and the SK learn package
and then we're going to go ahead and do
a random seed
now a lot of times the cross actually
does this automatically but we're going
to go ahead and set it up on here and
you can see we did an NP random seed
from 42 and we get a nice RN number and
then we do TF random we set the seed so
you can set your Randomness at the
beginning of your tensorflow and that's
what the tf.random dot set is
so that's a lot of prep all this prep
and then we finally get to the exciting
part this is where you probably spend
once you have the data prepped and you
have your pipeline going and you have
everything set up on there this is the
part that's exciting is building these
models
and so we look at this model one we're
going to designated as sequential
um they have the API which is across the
cross tensorflow API versus sequential
sequential means we're going one layer
to the next so we're not going to split
the layer and bring it back together
it looks almost the same with the
exception of bringing it back together
so it's not a huge step to go from this
to an API
and the first thing we're going to look
at is our convolutional neural network
in 2D
uh so what's going on here there's a lot
of stuff that's going on here the
default for well let's start with the
beginning what is a convolutional 2d
Network
well convolutional 2D Network creates a
number of small windows and those small
Windows float over the picture and each
one of them is their own neural network
and it's basically becomes like a uh a
categorization and then it looks at that
and it says oh if we add these numbers
up a certain way
we can find out whether this is the
right flower based on this this little
window floating around which looks at
different things
and we have filters 32 so this is
actually creating 32 Windows is what
that's doing
and the kernel size is five by five so
we're looking at a five by five square
remember it's 150 by 150. so this
narrows it down to a five by five it's a
2d so it has your X Y coordinates and
when we look at this five by five
remember each one of these is it's
actually looking at five by five by
three
so we're actually looking at 15 by 15
different pixels
and padding is just um usually I just
ignore that activation by default is
relu we went ahead and put the relu in
there
there's a lot of different activations
Ray Lu is for your smaller uh when you
remember I mentioned atom when you have
a lot of data data use an atom kind of
activation or use an atom processing
we're using the rayleu here uh it kind
of gives you a yes or no but it it
doesn't give you a full yes or no it has
a a zero and then it kind of shoots off
at an angle
very common it's the most common wand
and then of course here's our input
shape 150 by 150 by 3 pixels
and then we have to pool it so whenever
you have a two convolutional 2D
layer we have to bring this back
together and pull this into a neural
network and then we're going to go ahead
and repeat this
so we're going to add another Network
here one of the cool things if you look
at this is that it as it comes in it
just kind of automatically assumes
you're going down to the next layer and
so we have another convolutional null
Network 2D here's our Max pooling again
we're going to do that again Max pooling
and we're just going to filter on down
now one of the things they did on this
one is they changed the kernel size they
change the number of filters and so each
one of these steps
kind of looks at the data a little bit
differently
and that's kind of cool because then you
get a little added filtering on there
this is where you start playing with the
model you might be looking at a
convolutional neural network which is
great for image classifications
um
we get down to here one of the things we
see is flattened so we add we just
flatten it remember this is 150 by 150
by three well and actually the pool size
changes so it's actually smaller than
that flatten just puts that into a 1D
array so instead of being you know a
tensor of this really complexity with
the the pixels and everything it's just
flat and then the dense
is just another activation on there by
default it is probably relu as far as
this activation
and then oh yeah here we go in
sequential they actually added the
activation as relu so this just because
this is sequential this activation is
attached to the dents and there's a lot
of different activations but Rayleigh is
the most common one and then we also see
a soft Max uh softmax is similar but it
has its own kind of variation and one of
the cool things you know what let me
bring this up because if we if you don't
know about these activations this
doesn't make sense
and I just did a quick Google search on
images of tensorflow activations
um I should probably look at which
website this is
but this is the output of the values so
as your X as it adds in all those
weighted X values going into the node
it's going to activate it a certain way
and that's a sigmoid activation and you
can see it goes between 0 and 1 and has
a nice curve there this also shows the
derivatives and if we come down the
seven popular activation functions
non-linear activations there's a lot of
different options on this let me see if
I can find the
oops let me find the specific to relu
so this is a leaky Ray Lou and you can
see instead of it just being zero and
then a value between going up it has a
little leaky there otherwise your
Rayleigh loses some notes they just
become inactive
um but you can see there's a lot of
different options here here's a good one
right here with the ray Lou you can see
the Rayleigh function on the upper on
the upper left here and then the Leaky
Rayleigh over here on the right which is
very commonly used also
one of the things I use with processing
um language is the Sig is the
exponential one or the tangent H the
hyperbolic tangent because they have
that nice funky curve that comes in that
has a whole different meaning and
captures word use better
again these are very specific to domain
and you can spend a lot of time playing
with different models for a basic model
we'll stick to the relu and the soft Max
on here and we'll go ahead and run and
build this model
so now that we've had fun playing with
all these different models that we can
add in there we need to go ahead and
have a batch size on here
128 epics 10
this means that we're going to send 128
uh rows of data or flowers at a time to
be processed
and the epics 10 that's how many times
we're going to Loop through all the data
and then there's all kinds of stuff you
can do again this is now built into a
lot of cross models already by default
um
so there's different ways to reduce the
values and verbose verbose equals one
means that we're going to show what's
going on
value monitor what we're monitoring
we'll see that as we actually train the
model this is what's what's going to
come out of there if you set the verbose
equal to zero you don't have to watch it
train the model although it is kind of
nice to actually know what's going on
sometimes
and since we're still working on
bringing the data in here's our batch
side here's our epics we need to go
ahead and create a data generator this
is our image data generator
and it has all the different settings in
here almost all of these are defaults so
if you're looking at this going oh my
gosh this is confusing most of the time
you can actually just ignore most of
this vertical flip so you can randomly
flip pictures you can randomly
horizontally flick them you can shift
the picture around this kind of helps
gives you multiple data off of them
zooming rotation there's all kinds of
different things you can do with images
most of these we're just going to leave
as false we don't really need to do all
that um
um setup because we already have a huge
amount of data if your short data you
can start flipping like a horizontal
picture and it will generate it's like
doubling your data almost
so the upside is you double your data
the downside is that if you already have
a bias in your data you already have
[Music]
um
5 000 sunflowers and only two roses
that's a huge bias it's also going to
double that bias that is the downside of
that
and so we have our model compile and
this you're going to see in all the
cross we're going to take this model
here we're going to take all this
information as far as how we want it to
go and we're going to compile it
this actually builds the model and so
we're going to run that and I want you
to notice uh learning rate
very important this is the default zero
zero one there's there you really don't
this is how slowly it adjusts to find
the right answer
and the more data you have you might
actually make this a smaller number with
larger with you have a very small sample
of data you might go even larger in that
and then we're going to look at the loss
categorically categorical cross entropy
most commonly used
and this is uh how how much it improves
the model is improving is what this
number means or yeah that's that's
important on there and then the accuracy
we want to know just how good our model
is on the accuracy
and then
one of the cool things to do is if
you're in a group of people who are
studying the model if you're in
shareholders you don't want to do this
is you can run the model summary
I do this by default and you can see the
different layers that you built into
this model just a quick summary on there
so we went ahead and we're going to go
ahead and create a
we'll call it history but we want to do
a model fit generator
and so what this history is doing is
this is tracking what's going on as well
it fits the model
now there's a lot of new setups in here
where they just use fit and then you put
the generator in here
we're going to leave it like this even
though the new default
is a little different on that it doesn't
really matter it does the same thing and
we'll go ahead and just run that
and you can see while it's running right
here uh we're going through the epics we
have one of ten now we're going through
6 to 25. here's our loss we're printing
that out so you can see how it's
improving and our accuracy the accuracy
gets better and better and this is 6 out
of 25. this is going to take a couple
minutes to process because we are
training 150 by 150 by 3 pixels across
uh six layers or eight layers whatever
it was
that is a huge amount of processing so
this will take a few minutes to process
this is when we talk about the hardware
and the problems that come up in data
science and why it's only now just
exploding being able to do neural
networks this is why this process takes
a long time
now you should have seen a jump on the
screen here because I did pause the
recorder to let this go ahead and run
all the way through it's epics
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what these epics are and if you set the
verbose to zero instead of one it won't
show what's going on in the behind the
scene because it's training it so we
look at this epic 10 epic so we went
through all the data 10 times if I
remember correctly there's roughly a gig
of data there so that's a lot of data
the first thing you're going to notice
is the 270 seconds that's how much each
of those epics took to run and so if you
divide 60 in there you roughly get about
five minutes worth of each epic so if I
have 10 epics that's 50 minutes almost
an hour of run time
that's a big deal we talk about
processing uh in on this particular
computer I actually have what is it uh
eight cores with 16 dedicated threads so
it runs like a 16 core computer it
alternates the threads going in and it
still takes it five minutes for each one
of these epics so you start to see that
if you have a lot of data this is going
to be a problem if you have a number of
models you want to find out how good the
models are doing what model to use
and so each of those models could take
all night to run in fact I have a model
I'm running now that takes over uh takes
about a day and a half to test each
model it takes four days to do the whole
data so what I do is I actually take a
small piece of the data
test it out to find out get an idea of
how the different setups are going to do
and then I increase that size of the
data and then increase it again and I
can just take that that curve and kind
of say okay if the data is doing this
then I need to add in more dense layers
or whatever so you can do a small chunks
of data then figure out what it costs to
do a large set of data and what kind of
model you want
the loss as we see here continues to go
down this is the error this is how much
error is in there it really isn't a
user-friendly number other than the more
it Trends down the better and so if you
continue to see the loss going down
eventually it'll get to the point where
it stops going down and it goes up and
down and kind of wavers a little bit at
that point you know you've run too many
epics you're starting to get a bias in
there and it's not going to give you a
good model fit
the accuracy just turns us into
something that we can use and so the
accuracy is what percentage of guesses
in this case is categorical so this is
the percentage of guesses are correct
um value loss is similar you know it's a
minus a value loss
and then you have the value accuracy and
you'll see the value accuracy is pretty
similar to the accuracy just rounds it
off basically and so a lot of times you
come down here and you go okay we're
doing 0.5 0.6
0.7 and that is 70 accuracy or in this
case
68.59 accuracy that's a very usable
number and it's very important to have
if you're identifying uh flowers that's
probably good enough if you can get
within a close distance and knowing what
flower you're identifying if you're
trying to figure out whether someone's
going to die from a heart attack or not
you might want to rethink it a little
bit or re-key how you're building your
model so if I'm working with a uh a
group of clients shareholders in a
company or something like that you don't
really want to show them this you don't
want to show them hey you know this is
what's going on with the accuracy these
are just numbers and so we want to go
and put the finishing touches just like
when you are building a house and you
you put in the frame and the trim on the
house just nice to have something a nice
view of what's going on and so we'll go
ahead and do a pie plot and we'll just
plot the history of the loss the history
of the value loss
over here epics train and test and so
we're just going to compute these this
is really important and what I want you
to notice right here is when we get to
about oh five epics a little more than
five six epics you see a cross over here
and it starts Crossing as far as the
value loss and what's going on here is
you have the loss in your actual model
and your actual data and you have the
value loss where it's testing it against
the the test data the data wasn't used
to program your model wasn't used to
train your model on
and so when we see this crossing over
this is where the bias is coming in this
is becoming overfitted and so when you
put these two together uh right around
five and six you start to see how it
does this this switch over here and
that's really where you need to stop
right around five yeah six
um it's always hard to guess because at
this point the model is kind of a black
box uh see but you know that right
around here if you're saving your model
after each run you want to use the one
that's right around five epics because
that's the one that's going to have the
least amount of bias so this is really
important as far as guessing what's
going on with your model and its
accuracy and when to stop it also is you
know I don't show people this mess up
here
um I show somebody this kind of model I
say this is where the training and the
testing comes in on this model
uh it just makes it easier to see and
people can understand what's going on
so that completes our demo and you can
see we did what we were set out to do we
took our flowers and we were able to
classify them uh within about you know
68 70 accuracy whether it's going to be
a dahlia sunflower cherry blossom Rose a
lot of other things you can do with your
output as far as a uh different tables
to see where the errors are coming from
and what problems are coming up
and that brings us to the end of this
video on artificial intelligence 2022
full course by simply learn I hope you
liked it if you have any queries then
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
[Music]